[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fantastic
[Applause]
hello and welcome to round 12 here at
the tata steel chess tournament my name
is fioneshtal anthony and i'm delighted
to be joined once again by grandmaster
daniel naraditsky
dania dropping some knowledge here right
before we're going live how are you
today
we were indeed having a great time
before the broadcast but i'm sure we'll
be having a great time during the
broadcast as well good afternoon fiona
good morning afternoon to everybody
round 11 of the tata steel tournament
and everything is going to be decided
today potentially i absolutely cannot
wait as we review the results from
yesterday
absolutely yesterday uh well first of
all daniel duboff he didn't play
unfortunately he tested uh positive two
covet so he won't be playing any of the
remaining two rounds either but
elsewhere we saw two big wins the first
one in a spectacular game uh jordan van
furis beating his fellow countryman
anishkiri if you missed that you can
watch our rapid recap of the day video
from yesterday which you can find on the
main chest.com youtube channel and
fabiano carana also got a big win with
the black pieces against pragnanda and
dania
yeah he did it was an exquisite
technical effort and it came after a
very painful loss the day before against
uh richard report and for fabia that was
a very important confidence booster in
part because who of who he is facing uh
today but yeah magnus carlson ahead of
the field by half a point a rapport
close behind so nothing has been decided
yet one loss at the top can shake
everything up fiona that's why we watch
for that kind of intrigue
and well one thing that's important to
know is that magnus tomorrow he was
paired against super for match which
won't be played so really tournament
victory uh is only going to be decided
between magnus and richard
report
if magnus draws against fabiano today he
is assured to at least be in the the
playoff and a win today against fabiano
would also guarantee seoul first
yeah and magnus knows that as we look at
the pairings but the other matchups are
very fascinating as well i mean gary
grindelius i'm looking forward to
shanklin karjak and that's a rematch of
their world cup match sam shankman is
going to be looking for
uh revenge but of course the marquee
matchup of the day undoubtedly is
fabiana caruana against magnus carlson
which is also of course a rematch from
uh their unimportant match uh for the
world championship i think
doesn't really matter
who remembers that right and oh yeah
this little that little event going on
in london
um dania before i ask you what your
prediction is for that match up uh
people who are watching us at home they
too can get involved in the action how
can they do it
yeah well they can
do some uh voting and if you go to
chess.com
events you can click on vote and you can
vote on the results of the game there's
a one thousand dollar prize fool but
make sure not to procrastinate on that
fiona because voting ends after the
tenth move just click who you think is
going to win and make sure to
participate along with
us but do that right now
absolutely get involved uh all good fun
with some prizes 2b1 as well dania we're
going to go on a very short break and
we'll be back with the start of the
round here so don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
magnus carlsen will he take revenge well
dania he is uh incredibly close to
winning an eighth uh title here in
vaikanse indeed and he has the black
pieces today which means he's definitely
not going to be doing anything crazy
he's fine of course he's fine with the
draw
under most circumstances and it would
take a monumental effort
by mr report or by somebody else well
nobody else i think can physically catch
magnus i believe if he at least makes a
draw today fiona's that i didn't major
in math but i'm pretty sure
that's the case i guess if anishiri wins
today
then he has seven and a half but then
magnus is gonna have eight and because
he wins tomorrow richard report is the
only person who can catch him but he's
gonna have to win twice if magnus draws
today
i'm certainly good if magnus loses today
then they could still catch him right or
am i then
all bets are off and then then it's
pandemonium
a lot is going to depend today what what
kind of mindset fabi uh shows up uh for
for his clash what what are your
expectations or your predictions
well you know i i hate to be the bearer
of bad tidings but
fabi hasn't been in the greatest form of
course he wants to redeem his tournament
and as we were talking about yesterday
if he can score a victory against the
world champion
that's all anybody talks about that's
what people remember you by you were the
guy who beat magnus you're the guy who
dealt magnus's only loss in the
tournament so i don't think that magnu
that fabia's gonna be forcing a berlin
draw i also don't think that he's going
to be uh throwing out any queen
sacrifices on the 15th move so i think
it's going to be some somewhere in the
middle
and um i think that fabi is going to be
playing the position i guess that
doesn't really answer the question but
i think he's going to play his normal
style and you know if if the situation
calls for a solid draw then he's going
to make it i don't think he's going to
be burning his bridges in a crazy
fashion i think what you're saying makes
a lot of sense also while i'm sure fabi
would love to to get a win um there is
nothing for him he cannot fight for
first place like there's no reason for
him to do anything
crazy today as we see i'm christophe
duda arriving for his game against irene
van fries i saw that duda tweeted
yesterday after the game let me quickly
find it so i don't yeah what did he say
he
he just said i know dot dot dot it was
an exceptional situation for me today
which is very cryptic but to me
indicates that there was maybe something
going on
behind the scenes yeah and you know
these like like we were discussing
yesterday that they're human uh it could
be anything from
waking up on the wrong side of the bed
and having a sore throat
to you know something going on in their
personal lives and you know i think it's
important to to understand that and to
respect that
uh and we know duda as a fighter i mean
we know that he doesn't do something
like that unless uh there is indeed a
situation that calls for it
look at this magnus arriving in time for
his crash against fabiano carrana he's
at the board before the clocks have been
started really
is that america say magnus carlsen or is
this an imposter
he hasn't done that any of the rounds i
think i think yeah
maybe maybe one more at most but no he
and there we see the clocks being
started as uh jordan arrives bang on
time for his game against the ancestor
of duda and one e4 is on the board in uh
karana against carlson
indeed one e4 and now again a big
decision for magnus i'm sure he has
already made this decision
my guess is he's gonna play e5 let's see
uh but he has played the sveshnikov
before against fabian particularly in
their world championship match
well right now he's attacking c5 okay
now which line of the sicilian my guess
is sveshnikov but fabio could also play
a rosalimo that is bishop b5 on the
third move and i'm assuming magnus goes
knight c6 here which he did
right now a big choice for fabi yeah for
sure we've actually had a surprisingly
low numbers of sicilians during this
event
yeah the crazy thing is i don't remember
i can't remember a single one at the top
of my head as fabi does indeed go for
his patented rosso limo bishop e5
and this essentially means that fabi is
in for a game because in the open
sicilian and the sebastian gov there are
lines that essentially lead to force
trust so fabi wants the game that much
is clear and that is fantastic news uh
for you for us as commentators but also
i think for
for just fans uh all around the world
yeah and this is known as the rosalina
who is it named after it's named after
nicholas rossolimo very interesting
character by the way originally from
france
uh immigrated to new york in i want to
say the 1940s or 50s he was a
grandmaster he worked as a cab driver he
owned a chess shop in greenwich village
a very colorful figure and among his
many achievements he pioneered this line
of the sicilian where you essentially
play this like a lopez
except white almost always captures this
knight on c6 at some point either here
or on the next move but recently
recently there's been the sideline c3
which has kind of taken the chess world
by storm everybody's playing c3 nowadays
myself included
uh i never take on c6 here bobby castle
so it remains to be seen what he chooses
at the moment where magnus played g6
there is a couple of uh lines of course
for black is j6 what you think what was
expected or
yeah g6 is i believe what magnus plays
most of the time of course there's also
e6
uh but this is considered the main line
this is the most popular system
i just think fabio is deciding between
c3 and bishop takes c6 because he's
played uh both of these systems i i
don't know if he necessarily expected
the sicilian to be honest i think he
probably mostly prepared for e5 and
there it is c3
so what are the the plans here you were
talking that the alternative was to take
on c6 and so going forward
when is the right moment how do you
decide when you want to to give up uh
the bishop and take on c6
that's a good question and this c3 line
is completely different in spirit from
the main line of bishop take c6 the main
line reaches these types of structures
usually black captures with a d-pawn
and you get this weird type of structure
where sometimes black drops the knight
back to d7 and plays e5
and you can think of this as kind of a
reverse marotzi bind but in
the line that they're currently playing
out after c3 knight f6 well white has
two main moves there's rookie one
and then there is the old line which is
e5 knight t5 d4 kind of playing this
like an allopin
with a bishop on b5 but my guess is
fabi's gonna go rookie one that's what
the
cool kids are playing these days and the
idea for white is just to play d4 while
it wants to occupy the center
and white doesn't usually take the
knight on c6 in this line unless
unless he's compelled to
buy the move a6 or by the move queen b6
uh so interesting stuff and good on on
fabi for playing as something here well
good on both players something that has
a lot of life to it but
um danya i'm hearing some bad news and
let's quickly bring up the bird's eye
view do we have you're hearing some
grumblings
i was hearing about a berlin but
i'm kind of yeah we have a berlin weird
empty berlin what is knight e7 let's
bring up here thank you again so effort
amazing i love that
this is the new report right he used to
play gf you would play g5 in this
position uh two years ago
but now he chooses lines that are a
little bit less offbeat but still very
colorful so 97 i am familiar with this
move
and uh there's you know probably over
100 games this is definitely not the
most common anti-berlin now
this seems like a blunder right what the
heck is black planning after knight
takes c5 well black plays c6 that
doesn't seem dangerous okay i'm
threatening checkmate no you're not
queen a5 check
and uh black wins the night so something
tells me andre is this
and white's main move here is to castle
which kind of leads to black secondary
idea the knight migrates over to g6 and
generally as far as i remember black
plays c6 in this line
white can go either to a4 or to c4
and yeah i see from the database that
knight g6 is the most popular line you
kind of get an italian type structure
here which is really weird but what do i
know this is
this is pretty unique stuff yeah it's a
very strange opening i wonder if he
himself i have a faint feeling in daniel
my memory is usually terrible for
openings but i have a feeling that i saw
some
top gm played this before i wonder if it
was richard report
himself i'll have a quick look later on
but interesting stuff and rapport uh
well he's already maybe
definitely sprung the first surprise
here and i think he's gonna go for the
the win with the black uh pieces today
especially given the tournament
situation
no question about it and you might say
well if he's going for a win why is he
playing the berlin well i think report
knows that yes panko is not going to go
for the force drop the berlin is not
necessarily
a drawing weapon i think people
misunderstand that and you can play the
berlin uh in order to get a fighting
game he probably expected yesterday to
play the anti-berlin and this is as good
a a combative
opening as any uh particularly after 97.
and danya actually i'm i'm just gonna
trust chat on this i'm sure not everyone
is a troll but there were a couple of
people confirming that it was he himself
who played and apparently played against
none other than a certain magnus carlsen
uh in in norway chess
oh wow so it's not the first time as
andre decides on knight's e3
so he plays the most straightforward
developing move
and i wonder if richard is going to go
c6 here or is he going to go
knight g6
i see from the database that both moves
are possible
and andre i'm sure this is not the first
time he's seeing 97 obviously he
probably took a minute and a half to
remember his preparation but
you know he's not pulling this out of
nowhere
for sure no i think he uh he knows and
richard report he has just played c6 the
bishop i guess drops back to
b4 a4
yeah well c4 looks more natural to me
and it might seem like this is walking
into d5 but i don't think it is because
well for one thing
i i think white can probably take and go
bishop b5 check
and the e5 pawn is hanging so i feel
like this is very problematic for black
uh in which case it it makes sense to
put the bishop on c4 it's obviously
aiming at f7 and if black plays d6
uh i see that the main line is is to
play d4 which leads to a
weird philidor type of star i mean this
does look very dubious for black
make no mistake but uh this is the
nature of modern chess these players
they analyze these positions so very
deeply
uh and a lot of lines which even 20
years ago would have been laughed off
stage are now a full-fledged part of uh
opening repertoires
yeah and uh richard report i think he's
really been one of the the main players
in the game to contribute to
offbeat openings being regarded more
highly and he employed them with so much
as success as we see
andre indeed dropping the bishop back
to c4 and
[Music]
now i guess black will continue with
knight
knight g6 if not d5 or what uh well i
think i think either d6 or knight g6 is
going to happen
and it's important to point out that
knight g5 is not an issue in this
position because now black plays d5 and
of course the tension has been taken off
of the
e5 pawn so this is fine as yeah richard
indeed goes d6
okay which one back here but uh shaping
up like a an interesting game this one
as well of course hugely important for
the tournament standings
for now uh let's go back to the bird's
eye view reminder daniel duboff won't be
playing i hit the last three games
unfortunately tested positive or coveted
we wish him all the best but plenty of
action elsewhere dania what catches your
eye
franklin catches my eye i feel like
they've already made 40 moves in the
first five minutes
uh let's figure out what's going on in
that game no they've made 15 moves
uh but that's a lot of moves and some up
to an hour 45 on the clock
yeah and not and sergey not a slouch
either he's over a one hour 40. uh now
this is really interesting because we
saw jordan yesterday playing the uh
samish variation
sam plays its close uh cousin which is
also i think known as the same iteration
i mean both of these lines in fact they
can transpose into each other in many
many cases i mean if black plays d5 here
which is the most popular move then
after a3 bishop c3 bc
you have a potential transposition to
uh a3 bishop takes e3 bc d5 and here i
can play up three
uh but sergey going for a much sharper
continuation he plays c5 striking at the
center immediately
this leads to a kind of benoni style
position and b5 which is among the most
reputable weapons against
uh sam's
line of choice e4 d6 bishop d2 a6 of sam
not taking this pawn on b5 which gives
black pretty significant compensation
instead going for a4
trying to get sergey to take on c4 to
help sam develop his bishop which he
does
knight bd7
which is upon sacrifice sam accepts it
takes takes takes and the knight comes
out to e5 i guess sergey's point is that
the king uh is quite weak in the center
and sam has violated the
you know the fine gold rule by playing
f3
uh very early
i'm sure this is still
uh yeah i'm seeing that they're
following a game c4
creating the threat of knight d3
essentially forcing the trade and sam
has just gone knight h3 so he's still up
upon
they're still following a game fiona i
don't want to click on it because it'll
take me away from the board but perhaps
our producer
uh you know big doesn't do anything
anyway perhaps he could uh he could help
me out here they're they're following
some high-level game here and sergey is
the first to take a significant think in
this position that game continued queen
c5
let me have a look right i think big is
on the on the case and
dania let me just ask you because
you mentioned that sam and kariakin had
a
a big matchup in the last world cup was
at the quarterfinals or this semi's
quarter
i want to say the quarterfinals yeah
and uh that match i mean
one of the most exciting matches i can
remember from the world cup with so many
decisive results and i think the player
didn't play with the white pieces they
just kept winning so surely sam is gonna
walk into this match quite hopeful
yeah i mean if the trends continue then
he's got every chance now
i talked to him about that match
it was an incredibly painful experience
for him because he was really was on the
cost i mean there were a couple of games
he had with black
uh where you know he was doing well out
of the opening
and to beat karjakin as many times as he
did in classical and rapid
is is an incredible accomplishment
really puts sam on the radar i think for
a lot of chess fans who before you know
they knew him as a 2700 former us
champion
but weren't really aware that he is more
than capable of playing on an even field
on an even keel with
you know the top of the top
yeah and dania i actually i had a look i
can't find any top level games that
they're following maybe
maybe mr bigfoot will be more successful
than i i see one game
uh where alina kashlinskaya had the
black pieces against marina guseva
okay that's the game i met i mean i
didn't i didn't know what the ratings of
the players were yeah i just saw that
there was one game and this is
definitely a game that sam is aware of
now kashlinskaya
is interesting she is actually very very
powerful in the opening
uh and we had the same coach for a long
time left cyclists who
is a big uh nimzo indian specialist
so it's no coincidence i think that she
went down this line for for this long
and there is another game actually as
well that was played between pierre
luigi basso with the white pieces
against danielle
alcina leal that was um played in may
last year at the catolica open in in
italy wow
another interesting piece of trivia i
played both of those players in the same
tournament i'll see all in pierre luigi
basso uh years ago in a tournament in
italy
that's funny a lot of isn't that funny
and what are the odds of that i know i
mean that there would be two games one
of them you shared a coach with
the other two one of them i played the
same people in the same tournament i
lost all cena and i beat baso but since
then basso has become a
2600 plus grandmaster
so
what do we make of the the position on
the board now where is black's
compensation
yeah well you got to find it and queen
c5 makes a lot of sense this is what i
think uh gusava or kashlinsky played
was was black in that game
okay that's what i thought
um
why does queen c5 make sense because it
prevents white from castling obviously
white wants to castle on the next move
and queen c5 exploits the weakness
created by the move f3
um so that game continued queenie two
castles long
and white played knight f2 again
reinforcing the threat of castling short
which at this point black cannot prevent
but here it looks like koscienska
switched her base of operations from the
diagonal to the d file and you can kind
of see how active black's pieces are
here
even though i just succeeded in castling
it's quite clear to me that black has
phenomenal compensation
for the pawn my guess is that sam has
found an improvement
somewhere along the line i'm not sure
exactly where maybe it was here
uh but there's no question that he's not
just stumbling into this position
uh and he's just gonna keep falling
because kashlinska did end up winning
that game yeah but i'm expecting queen
c5 i think that's a very natural move
quincy 5s sergey yarning away at the
board i mean we're really entering now
the final final stages of this
tournament we led him to figure it out
some hundred percent still following his
prep
and we're back in the overview
uh what else dania catches your
attention
what else catches my attention well
we'll keep an eye by the way on as a
panko report that game is really heating
up
uh perhaps we can have a look at um
the the vivid game is
is pretty interesting this is not just a
normal italian
let's let's
swing on over check it out indeed
shakira mamidarov one of the players
also with the black pieces he might be
looking
well he has to win actually he's one of
the players who does still stand
a potential chance in case magnus
i loses today so we'll see how much risk
he is willing to to take
indeed and it started off as a
completely standard italian
um i feel like i'm i'm narrating those
crime shows it started off as a totally
normal evening in long island
you know jane doe was walking in her
garden yeah so h3 97
and now d4 and here's the interesting
bit knight g6 is is of course the normal
continuation of the maneuver
but in this position chakra goes back to
c6
and i see that they are following a
couple of games and i guess the point of
this move is to put more direct pressure
on the d4 pawn
and now that it going a4
to which sakurai replies e takes d4 this
is a novelty
and vinit takes back on d4 with a pawn
now this might seem
very confusing at first sight isn't this
just a blunder
well it's not because if white plays
knight if black plays knight takes d4
after takes takes white has this
incredibly nasty move knight b3 and all
of a sudden the bishop is experiencing
tremendous problems if you go to e5 you
get it trapped
if you go to b6 white's gonna chase it
to c5 once it lands on c5 white captures
it
and okay there's probably multiple good
moves here but queen b3 looks really
nice just look at the pressure that
white has on the position there's d-file
e5 is coming this is incredibly bad for
black despite the extra pawn
so it's more feasible to capture on d4
with the bishop rather than the knight
but in this case after knight takes d4
knight takes d4 my guess is that vidit
is just aiming for long-term
compensation he might play the move b4
here in order to prepare a fiance look
at how strong those bishops are going to
be both of them aiming at black's king
and you know there's queen side pressure
as well and the engine definitely
approves of its play here what an
interesting pawn sacrifice
uh although it seems like he didn't
invent it
uh i love the fact that he's going down
this line and is black uh forced to
accept upon sacrifice or not
black is not and well the funny thing is
if black didn't want to accept it then
i'm not sure why shakira took on d4
because all three people who had this
position went a5
and it puzzles me fiona that chakriar
took this pawn and now he's starting to
think now i guess there's the move d5
here which which makes some sense as
well
and this position looks very good for
black because black has this blockade on
the d5 square but in reality uh in my
experience with these types of positions
it's there's a lot of tactics that black
can fall into and as a case in point for
instance let's say you play a6
bishop takes h6 out of nowhere g takes
h6 bishop takes d5 and guess what you
get forked at the end so
even though you have a positional trump
card in the form of
blockade on the d5 square white has
tremendous potential energy
uh in his position so i'm not sure that
this would uh solve all of black's
problems the knight by the way can come
to c5 uh so i think
vidit might be better here if shakur
doesn't come up with something
convincing i'm with you i mean i'm so
surprised that he took on d4 once and
then started thinking um
we'll come back here see
what he decides on but for now let's go
back to the
overview very interesting stuff from
uh visited there
and um
well both the top games we are focusing
on have changed quite a bit do you want
to start with fabiano against magnus or
with andre against
richard
let's start with a world champion let's
let's go to fabi's game
and they i believe yeah they're still
following pretty well known uh a
well-known line
okay
so c3 knight f6 rookie one castle's d4
and magnus immediately counter striking
in the center with d5
to which fabio responds e5 getting this
kind of uh you know typical structure
with the pawn chain which black is
trying to pressure i think a lot of
people might be familiar with this from
the french advance
you know it's one of several variations
where
white controls the saturn black tries to
chip away at it with his pawns and
pieces
bishop e3 cd4 cd4 and speaking of the
french this is of course a very typical
move
in all of these structures
and now if fabby were to take on c6
after
b takes c6 black has the potential to go
c5 and the b2 pawn is hanging so fabby
delaying the move queen takes a bishop
takes e6 and playing queen e2 to which
magnus has responded by developing his
final piece bishop d7 and fiona this
creates a threat
uh i believe let's make a
neutral move for fabi knight take c5
is an easy uh tactical idea to miss
because if bishop takes d7 the knight
recaptures it and if you take the knight
uh the queen
takes the bishop and black is simply
upon us so fabi has to address that
and it's not the easiest thing to
address i mean if you play knight c3
that does not actually help uh because
after knight c3 bc once again there's
knight takes in five
so i wonder how fab he's going to
address this also i guess now that black
has played bishop d7 it is a lot less
tempting to to capture on on c6
yeah it really is not very appetizing
black and recapture in a variety of ways
there is the move bishop a4 here
which has been played once and the point
is that you can't
take on e5 now because if d takes e5
and you used to be able to take on b5
with the queen now you can't do that
anymore bobby has just
done that by the way bishop a4 is on the
board yep he's got bishop a4 and the one
game i see in this position has
continued
rook ac8 which is a very
natural move
and white responded with h3 stopping
bishop g4
rook fd8 and white played the move
knight a3 he lost the game though
after a night before i'm not sure again
who was flank
but this is a tremendously complex
position black has a lot of peace
activity but in the long run black has a
bad bishop and white has more space so
it's really a battle of
white's long-term advantages and black's
short-term initiative that magnus is
going to try to convert into something
more concrete
so far who who of the two players do you
think uh is more satisfied with what
they've gotten out of the opening
yeah it's hard to say i mean
fabi has played pretty quickly he's
definitely still in his preparation and
probably so is magnus although
if you judge by his thinking pose
you know bishop a4 might be a new move
to him
i think fabie is very fabby is well
known for his uh rosalina mastery he's
been playing this for many many years
and i'm sure that he's analyzed you know
he's analyzed this very very deeply as
has his team i think fabi's pretty happy
to get this kind of ursulimo structure i
honestly think he's he's comfortable in
these positions and i also i really
think that
it was so important for him to to get
that win against prague yesterday
apologies to lift his um
spirits we saw him in some interviews in
the middle of the tournament it was
clear he was having a tough time his
second was in isolation vik is a long
place to to be on your own for for a
couple of weeks uh and i'm so happy to
see
uh that i was wrong i thought we would
get something way more peaceful here
today
um so i'm delighted with the outcome of
the the opening and i think we're in for
a big fight
yeah we are this is going to be a
positionally rich game and you know it
might end in a draw obviously
uh but we know it's not going to be
symmetrical and it's going to be
full of nuance and complexity which is
what we're looking for in a battle
between these two greats
yeah i mean fabi you know i i second
that idea that he's he was clearly
dejected and to play a smooth game a
nice game
uh toward the end of the tournament
that's exactly what one needs to lift
one spirits
and also i mean for today it for him he
might feel like okay for magnus there is
some pressure if magnus loses today
uh
well it's not just
bad for his christ the 2900 but also for
the tournament situation so fabio
fabiano might sense that
today is a good day to to play and put
some pressure on magnus he's doing uh
that uh just now i see daniel you're
addressing a couple of questions uh in
the chat you want to quickly show that
on the board or do you want to move on
to
yeah
maybe i'll quickly show it and then we
can move on the question was how does
bishop a4 actually address the problem
of knight t65 so if you compare this
comparison is always a very good way to
uh to answer a question in chess so look
at this position after d takes e5 yeah
the queen is hanging but the queen
simultaneously moves away from the
attack and captures the bishop but
reposition the bishop on a4
and after knight e5 d5 the queen is
hanging that part is true once again the
part that's not true is that the queen
can no longer take the bishop and so
black ends up losing a piece
very nicely explained uh shall we
move on from here and check in uh maybe
with the other important game yes panko
against richard report where a lot has
happened as well
yes
panko
let's check in on it
what did i
say no i i was trying to make a pun out
of his name oh
i was in like yes do you want to check
in on the game yes panko
let's check in on epenco's game
oh my god see i i just kept going with
it and it was getting worse and worse
but i couldn't stop because i had
already started
i know the feeling well but i like your
kind of i like your commitment to the
calls
right thank you thank you i'm sure the
chat is going to roast me alive for that
one okay so
what has happened since we left well
report played d6
and andre did indeed go d4 to which
report responded queen c7 this is kind
of a philidor structure
uh which is incredibly solid for black
of course black black space
uh but this can this can be hard to play
against uh from white's perspective yes
think of going knight h4
probably preparing the move f4 and
typical report g5 boom
de5 d5 so they trade in the center and
the intermezzo queen f3 yes benko
attacking the knight and securing the f5
square
as a uh launching pad for the knight so
bishop g7
he does indeed go knight f5 we have a
trade on f5
and reheard going rogue d8
bishop back to d3 in order to reinforce
the f5 pawn and knight e to d5 this is
the position on the board right now
this is a good position on the more
danya
okay let's take a moment to to stop and
you explain to all of us what is
happening here because it's a proper
mess
very strange position and
it's hard to make heads or tails of it
you know
for me as well now
from a positional standpoint white's got
more advantages than black first of all
look at this bishop that's not a very
good bishop it's staring at the pawn
white has a lot of squares at his
disposal so for instance why i could
play knight oh as i say that he plays
knight e4
and you know white has a kind of a
positional blockade what does that mean
well it means that after 94 bishop
before
okay let's say black castles white's got
you know these light squares under full
control there's the possibility of going
f6 at some point and opening up the
diagonal and look at this g5 plumb that
pawn sticks out like a sore thumb and
white could hit that pawn where it hurts
with a move like h4 so black definitely
shouldn't castle here black should
probably come back to f6 first and put
more pressure on this bishop but why i
could reinforce it with rookie one so i
just think that
you know white's biggest downside is
probably this f5 pawn which is blocking
the bishop and
giving black kingside shelter with that
being said i like jessie pence's
position i think his position is
preferable but report is very very solid
here the only thing he's got to be very
careful about
is not to allow h4 under a wrong set of
circumstances when he castles king side
yeah i'm a little bit concerned about
richard's king
i've fought that line and where you
showed where in casey castle's king side
looks
very dangerous with the bishop pair
suddenly coming to life but
i also can't picture the the king
staying in the center is there any
chance we could see something like king
d7 king c8 at some point with the king
trying to hide on the queen side
yeah that's not a dumb idea at all i
mean king d7 is a viable candidate move
here the problem might be your we might
go from the frying pan into the fire
uh because even if you park your king on
the queen side well i'm going to start
attacking you there you know a4 a5 a6
etc and i feel like if black does play
knight f6 then castling kingside is
a more feasible option because
h4 can now be met with g4 that is the
point and after queen g3
okay this is not the safest construction
in human history
but it's not the easiest to attack if
only white had a knight you know to put
on h2 or to put on e3 that would really
help but yeah black can play rook d4
here so it's it's a double-sided uh
double-sided situation um but no it's
possible for black to castle queen side
as well and i think uh i mean this
double-edged situation is exactly what
richard report uh
was hoping for here today with the black
pieces he is taking some risks he could
easily find himself in a worse position
but
the position is very messy a couple of
wrong steps for jesse panko and it's not
hard at all to imagine richard uh taking
over
yeah and he's he's following the geary
model if you remember his yes panko's
loss is that his only loss of the
tournament
i i seem to have a hard time i feel like
it's not but it's his only loss of the
white pieces i mean to be as a banker
with black you need to take a
significant amount of risk and you need
to get an unbalanced position like the
one that giri got with three pawns for a
piece i think this is the sort of
situation that richard is aiming for not
literally three pawns for a piece but
something where you know both sides have
their own distinct plans
and and something that's not quite
familiar to andre as
yes he's gone 94
and richard contemplates and you're all
right by the way panko only lost that
one game to giri
yeah no he's i mean he's incredibly hard
to beat
okay knight takes c4 i'm anticipating
bishop takes you for knight f6 i think
that's going to happen
you could take with the queen but
okay with the queen
i think yeah but it walks into knight f6
we're going to oh we have another move
actually they he took what
sorry
and uh okay i think we're going to leave
this game for now we'll take our first
quick break of the day
um and then we'll be back here with all
the games from round 12 so don't go
anywhere and we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round 12 here
at the tata steel chess tournament
we are into round 12 uh the penultimate
round dania and only four players still
have a theoretical chance for first but
these dancing
standings are a little bit deceiving
because tomorrow magnus will receive a
walk-over point as unfortunately daniel
lubov tested a positive for covet
that's right and again it's it's crucial
to emphasize that so much hinges on the
result of today's uh affair between
caruana and carlson if magnus so much as
manages a draw
then those four theoretical players
become one theoretical person and that
person is richard report he needs to win
today and tomorrow if he used to have
any chance of catching magnus carlsen
it's unlikely but
crazier things have happened and that's
why we watch these tournaments because
anything can happen in the final couple
of games players are fatigued and when
players are tired you know there's more
uncertainty and there's more craziness
that could occur and if anybody can win
two in a row uh you know richard report
is
he's got the tools that that he needs he
has the uncompromising style so for sure
we're super excited for that
yeah and today well we have two very
exciting matchups uh
involving those two players of course
the first one on the top left side there
magnus he's playing black against
fabiano
i don't know if you want to update that
now if you want to have a quick look at
one of the games we haven't seen yet
i'll let you decide
yeah i want to take a very quick uh peek
at the two two games we haven't looked
at yet and then perhaps we can return to
um
also there's shankling karjakin is
having some developments so
uh let's start with the uh gary
grindelius game
it's not a particularly
uh interesting position but i think
anish is jumping out to a pretty solid
edge out of the opening so this was a
this started off as a king's indian
fianchetto which made me excited but
neil's uh transposing it into a grunfeld
which made me not excited
and queen b3 which is one of a million
ways that white can handle this position
neil's capturing on c4 and this is
transposed even further to kind of a
slav
type of setup with this pawn on c6
i don't know much about
these positions and he's playing a4
expanding on the queen side
neil's
going rook c8 and ish continues to
expand
we have b5 and our first on passant of
the day so that's
the coolest part about this game so far
a takes b6a takes b6 and yeah i feel
like white is slightly better in these
positions white's got more control of
the center
um you know i'm expecting a niche maybe
to develop his bishop to f4
and for niels uh generally i feel like
black tries to expand on the queen side
i mean he could consider playing b5
and then perhaps uh guiding the knight
from b6 over to d5
yeah you know why does i still think
yeah white white is a very pleasant
position um this is right up on yesh's
alley
for sure and i was wondering so
we made the move b5 is trying to go for
the pawn break with c5 also an option or
is b5 the main idea
it definitely is but i i guess uh
in response to c5 white could play d5
and if black is not careful i mean he
could also just get crushed here this e
pawn rumbles up the board
white can uh situate a knight on b5 also
white has control of the a file which is
bothering
bothering me on niels behalf just a
little bit i mean rook a7 could come
at at the least uh convenient moment for
black so
neil's also with an hour 14 so he's
definitely out of his prep
and this is only the first moment where
anish is taking
any amount of of time so he's gotten a
good position
and we'll see how he manages whether he
manages to convert it into something
real
indeed for now we'll move on to the last
game we haven't checked in with yet that
is young
against you then when first
and this time duda once again has the
white pieces
uh and of course he's not taking any
quick draws today he is
playing his usual brand of combative on
compromising chess this is a slav
uh it starts out as a sloth semi-slav
bishop g5 h6
and this is called i think the moscow
variation bishop takes f6 or no this is
the anti-moscow the moscow is bishop h4d
takes c4 so duda takes on f6 which is a
very reputable and popular line and now
he goes g3 which is less common
than the main lines and the main lines
here are e3
and queen b3 but playing this in kind of
a catalan flavor
knight d7 bishop g2 jordan takes on c4
due to castles and as we've discussed
in these catalan structures
white is not really in a big hurry to
recover the spawn uh this pawn is going
to be a very hard pawn to defend from
black's perspective and oftentimes white
actually sacrifices it and says i'm not
recovering that pawn at all and instead
white goes for kind of a central
strategy with e4
so castles bishop b4
queen comes out to c2 and
jordan drops his queen back to e7 this
move is aimed against
knight e4 which was being threatened
as a way to win back
the c4 pawn this is the position on the
board right now
and here so you you talked about white
trying to take control of the center
could we see
e4 immediately are there other moves to
consider before trying to take the
center
yeah i actually think jordan's last move
is also aimed against d4
because here black responds with e5
and well if white is not careful the
movie iv has the obvious drawback of
weakening and blunting the bishop so
let's say we have a trade in the center
well this is not a very desirable
position for white because
black has everything under control black
is the two bishops so i think e4 is less
likely
i i do think that 94 could still be
seriously considered by white
and now if jordan
stubbornly clings to the pawn well one
thing that could happen here is the move
b3
uh the point being after c takes b3 you
play queen takes c6 attacking the rook
and then you recapture the pawn on b3
what's interesting is that the engine
actually proposes a modified version of
that a3 is an important move to throw in
because after bishop a5 b3 c takes b3
queen takes c6 this is a lot more
devastating for black because after rook
b8 guess what now there's the move
knight d6 check when the bishop was on
b4 it was controlling that square so
this these kinds of subtleties is what
this position is all about both players
have to factor those in so after 94 my
guess is that jordan is not going to try
to cling to the pawn instead he might
try to counter strike in the center with
e5 and we will get a very complex
positional struggle
so many complex positional struggles all
over
the place today but do you feel overall
that
maybe once again this is a position with
both players at the moment are happy
with what they got
yeah i mean i think this is what duda
was aiming for when he played g3 he
understood that
uh the black is very likely to take on
c4 and jordan
i mean he's just comfortable in most
openings in general i mean he's a very
hard player to shake uh given his
expansive opening knowledge and his
preparation and he's going to be feeling
good after yesterday's win against anish
that of course uh give would give anyone
a lot of confidence for sure what a game
that was
for now and let's leave them to it let's
go back to the bird's eye view
and maybe we can update
one of our top two matches karana
carlson and yes the panko report
or let's do it well yes banker report
they're actually going s over on uh top
left is magnus's game and to the right
of that yes the banker report are
following the line that we outlined
where richard went knight f6
um and then he castled short so we might
see h4 from andre and then richard is
planning to meet that with the move g4
but let's start with uh caruana's game
because
they have had a very significant trade
which has kind of changed the the tenor
of the game
uh and
we saw bishop a4 magnus went rook aca
now the game that had reached this
position previously continued h3 and it
appears that this move knight c3 is a
novelty
magnus responds by taking on c3 caruana
has taken back
and magnus has played this very
interesting move queen d8
what's the idea
well the idea i think i'm gonna try to
answer this question i think he wants to
first of all reinforce the threat of
knight takes c5 which now that the queen
is no longer under the x-ray of the
bishop is again a threat and why is that
significant because if white drops the
bishop back to b3
now i i can consider this move knight a5
generally in this type of structure
black wants to surround the c4 square
and if black can get a knight to c4 and
then support it with pawns and pieces
well positionally speaking black is
going to be happy but in this particular
situation bishop takes d5 as possible
and there's this very interesting idea
to go bishop f5 here looks very strange
but this bishop is in some trouble i
mean if you go back to b3
then black can recover the pawn and hit
the bishop
one more time
the new britney spears special
and if white doesn't play bishop b3
flight plays c4 then obviously black
plays e6 and this is still very
complicated the bishop isn't actually
trapped white can play bishop g5
queen d7 and extricate the bishop with
bishop e4 but that would mean giving up
the c4 pawn with just an incredibly
complex position probably about equal it
is equal according to the engine
but i wonder what pabi is going to come
up with here is he going to play bishop
b3 i don't see too many other ways to
defend against uh the dual threats of
knight takes d4 and i take c5
yeah what could be
let's maybe start by actually showing
the threat one more time for people who
were just joining us now uh let's start
by by going through that
yeah knight takes e5 this is a very uh
common uh tactic that is missed at
really at all levels
uh because
you might think well bishop takes d7 and
then i'm gonna take the knight but
that's not true for two reasons actually
the main reason is that the knight which
was attacked can itself recapture the
bishop but in this specific position
black can also play knight takes f3
check and queen takes d7 black is up
upon but to add insult to injury black
is also threatening knight takes d4
uh and this hits the queen so white has
to respond to that and then black
recaptures on a4 this is not as
significant of a threat as knight takes
c5 but it's also something that has to
be reckoned with now the question for
fabio on a large scale is okay well does
he move the bishop away from a4 or does
he try to leave the bishop on a4 and
support it with a move like queen d1 for
example right
or does he make a difference he play
rook b1 and create a threat of his own
in order to counteract uh the threat of
knight takes e5 a lot of possibilities
here and a big decision to make from a
positional standpoint yeah fabi who's
been playing quite quickly
thus far do you think there's any chance
he could have seen this position
before do you think queen d8 might be
the first move that potentially comes as
a surprise
yeah they're probably i would argue i
would probably say that that he's at the
edge of his preparation it's possible
that this that this position was is
still you know on one of his
in one of his files
but my guess is that he either doesn't
fully remember it
uh or maybe and i think fabi himself or
somebody uh at the top described this in
an interview and i found this to be a
very very good point uh what i think
people have to understand is that
preparation essentially occurs on two
levels yes there is the preparation that
people think about they memorize moves
they have files and they look at
positions concretely but they also
consider typical structures and ideas
within those structures at an incredibly
extensive level so i can guarantee you
that maybe phabby isn't familiar with
this specific position but he has seen
similar positions with these three pawns
arranging exactly this way and so he is
aware
as is magnus from the black side
of the typical plans he knows that this
is a threat uh he knows that black wants
to blockade the c4 square so
he's familiar with the position i guess
now with the type of position but not
with this exact specific position on the
board
i'm very curious uh how he will react as
you showed a couple of choices maybe
bishop b3 is that the move you'd be
expecting most
yes if i had to predict a move i would
predict bishop b3 so we'll see if that
is the move that fabiano is going to
make for now let's go back once again to
our overview
and it looks like it looked like he was
about to make a move but no he's not
he's pulling ao teasing us once again
um where would you like to to go next
maybe shankland karyakin we could check
in there
absolutely and
wait a minute it looks like
it looks like
sam is in charge here now
we joined the game fiona when
uh sam had gone knight h3 and here's the
interesting thing sergey did not go
queen c5
he went bishop c5 and he also took a
very long time on this move so perhaps
he was indeed out of his preparation
before sam
sam responds with queen e2 which is a
familiar move preparing knight f2 and
castles rook b8
pressuring the b2 pawn sam does indeed
go knight f2 and
sergey has just gone queen b7 and this
appears to be the first position where
sam is taking his time
now you see that the bar did not like
queen b7 at all
uh and well there is a pawn hanging on
c2 i see our engine wants to take it but
that all looks like it's going to lead
to to a big mess
our engine wants to take it this move
looks like it loses and that's why
sergey played queen b7 it looks like
blackface queen takes b2 and guess what
boom
boom and if you castle here well that
loses a piece to bishop takes f2 check
and that's the end of the story but wait
a second it's not the end of the story
and apparently white has to continue
playing here and go king h1
and the point i think that the evo bar
is trying to make is that yes currently
black is up a piece but black's two main
defenders are nowhere to be found
black cannot castle which is an
interesting mirror image of what sergey
could have done to sam by putting his
queen on c5 isn't that amazing and sam
is has a devastating threat of
infiltrating to e6 with with tremendous
effect so for example let's say sergey
drops his bishop back to d4 well now
there's another threat of rook ab1 81
that's actually even a bigger threat
than queen e6 that essentially
necessitates uh sergey to move his queen
back but that releases the bishop and
after takes takes rook f2 white is
simply a healthy pawn up so you just
lose the piece i guess the only way of
moving the bishop and defending against
rook be one fiona is bishop b6 but now
there's rookie oh my god the bishop
blocks the queen's evacuation route and
the queen is strapped this is amazing so
certainly literally cannot keep
uh the extra piece bishop a7 i guess
clings to the piece for a couple more
moves but this is very clearly not a
sustainable defense because white just
vacuums up all of black's pieces after
queen c8 check
this is
extraordinary and
sam could be
if sam does this he'll be very much in
charge they're going to get that end
game where sam is just a full pot up
that is incredible stuff how you can
just give up the piece i think what's
happening in the position right now i
think some up until this moment was in
prep and queen b7
uh very likely not in his files because
it's just not a good move so i think
what's happening right now is sam knows
okay if i didn't look at queen b7
it means it's probably not very good
that probably means that i can take the
pawn on c4 but he is now trying to make
all of those lines work
and you make a great point which is that
sam believes in his files as he should
and he's so thorough that as you said
when a move is not in his file he knows
it's bad he knows for a fact that queen
b7 is a mistake
um and he also knows that it's not the
product of deep preparation because
sergey has just taken
uh 30 minutes on you know in the last
couple of moves
now what helps yeah and i was just going
to say that i don't sam doesn't have too
many other alternatives so he's going to
look at queen takes before the only
question is will he find and correctly
evaluate king h1 sorry go ahead yeah no
i i think that's what more or less what
i was going to say as well i think
um
what is going to help him make the
decision is he knows that if something
leads to an advantage here from here
queen c4 is more or less the only move
that can can do that really
and he's going to start by looking at
queen take c4 because it's the easiest
move to calculate why is that well
because this line is extremely forced
other than queen takes b2 there isn't
much black can do but i can take the
knight first and then play queen takes
b2 and here there's an an even more
amazing line apparently a white can
cover the check with 92
and this gives white an advantage but
now black can deliver a nasty check to
b6 and try to force the king back to f1
apparently the best uh option here is
king g3
knight h5 check king h4
and the king is as safe as it is
anywhere on the board i mean there's
just nothing on the king's side
uh and
white is about to take his turn
attacking black's king but that is also
something sam has to factor in
uh but of course the harder the harder
part is to
not rule this out because what's so easy
to do is say bishop takes f2 and i lose
a piece it doesn't work sam has to
resist that temptation and simply
continue calculating and once he sees
that king h1 is an option i can
guarantee you that he's going to
evaluate it correctly the question is
will he
be able to force himself to continue
calculating after bishop takes f2 check
my guess is that he will i think sam is
going to go down this line yeah and i
also think there is a chance even if
queen b7 isn't
in the files i'm sure some there's a
chance at least that sam will have had
some
variation of this
uh
giving up the night um in one of the
lines he might have been looking at of
course a lot of speculation on my end
but i am with you i think some will take
on on c4 after probably investing quite
a bit of time
right and and i guess he could play
rogue b1 here i mean that is
a possible alternative and you know the
engine thinks that white is still
slightly better i think sergey
sergey's idea is to park the queen on b3
which is a very very safe square it
cannot really be attacked by anything
okay castles castles
and i guess sam would move his king away
from h1 to one pin the knight but after
bishop d4 this is the similar type of
situation to the kashlinskaya game where
black just has
a wonderful piece activity a bishop on
an outpost and this is not very
impressive so sam
he has to play for maximum you're asked
to realize that this is not the way to
punish
queen b7 a very exciting moment will sam
find this uh incredible
uh move queen takes c4 fearless move
queen takes c4 i'm super curious i think
we're gonna go to the back to the bird's
eye view but we'll keep a very close eye
on whether some does take on c4 or not
um
dania what's happening elsewhere
oh so interesting top left caruana carls
and they are going down that line bishop
b3 was played and carlson indeed
responded
with knight a5 so
uh that line with bishop takes d5 bishop
f5
is quite likely to to occur on the board
which is
very interesting we don't have to go to
that game since we just talked about
that line but once they start going down
that line we'll return to that game and
keep you posted shall we have a brief
look in
uh to see what what is happening in the
esopanga report let's do it sure
so they've only made just a couple of
moves uh from the moment
uh where we last looked so knight takes
d5
so this position we saw night back to f6
c3 by andre just controlling the d4
square this move makes a lot of sense
castles
uh yes it tango deciding on h3 you know
stopping g4 and creating some luft
uh report
improves the position of his queen and
ties down the bishop because
uh the bishop for now has to keep
defending v2 and queen e2 that's a nice
move
uh that's a nice move which prepares the
development of the bishop to e3 it
defends it reinforces the b2 pawn no i
still think white is slightly better
here i think andre has a very pleasant
position
and do you think black will at some
point take the bishop on e4 or not
yeah i mean it's got its pros and cons i
don't think he's gonna take just yet
because this is going to be a clear case
of good bishop against bad bishop and
now the threat of h4 becomes
particularly annoying i mean if you
think about it this is not exactly my
image of an appetizing
uh position although of course black is
very solid here i mean even though the
bishop is horrible it's not like white
has an easy way to infiltrate black's
position but still this is not richard's
style at all so i don't think he's gonna
take just yet
i think that he's probably likely to
maybe even move the queen back to c7 or
play a a neutral positional move such as
rook d7 in order to double rooks on the
d file you know you might get some queen
side action andre might play a4a5 uh and
try to expand or he might stick to his
idea and play bishop e3
so i think that white's got a small but
stable advantage that's what i would say
yeah i think i'm liking ese panko's
position as well
with those bishops can we also imagine
at some point some kind of kingside
attack i'm dreaming of you know dropping
back the bishop for me for making sure
that's not gonna be captured and somehow
trying to
to yeah nag away at that
h6 g5 confirmation
yeah that's a very interesting idea and
again i just want to emphasize that h4
is a candidate move even in this
position
previously we were worried about g4 but
there's an insane idea that was put
forward by the engine so white can play
g3
and freeze the pawn in place and after
rook fd8 there's this
for some reason i saw this with bishop
g5 i guess it's in a different position
it doesn't work here but it's a very
interesting idea the point is to create
this massive pawn phalanx and to go for
the long-term attack it doesn't work in
this position because of the move
rook d2 but
there's stuff going on on the king side
no question about it and your proposal
is to play a move like bishop f3 in
order to cover the g4 square
preemptively the problem here
logistically is that black is going to
push the e4 pawn
epon forward
and you can't really take it because of
rookie and look at how well this queen
is placed it is preventing the f-pawn
from advancing and reinforcing the
bishop so white loses a piece here
actually
yeah so that's not the way to go uh but
we'll see we'll see what uh first of all
what witcher it does and then how yes
panko follows up but
in a comfortable position i think
a comfortable position for the young
russian i think let's update maybe one
more game before we go on a short break
how about
it against mamedyarov see
how shaq decided to capture well he
didn't he decided not to capture at all
let's go back a couple of moves
yeah so he did indeed go for d5 which we
had mentioned
and it's interesting that it takes on d5
and right now he's been thinking for i
want to say over 20 minutes
on on his next move and
to me
knight e4 looks very very natural right
centralizing the knight and creating
that threat of
of bishop takes h6
i guess that vinid is kind of thinking
about this position and asking himself
well what do i do now what exactly is
the follow-up is it knight c5 is it
something else and there must be another
candidate move
that is enticing him and if i had to
guess that candidate move is probably
knight b3
which also aims for the c5 square but
also has the additional bonus
of threatening to trap the bishop with
a5 and this essentially forces black to
play a6 or a5 himself which earns white
another tempo
which white could use to complete his
development with a move like bishop b2
the downside of course is that the
knight on e4 is centralized whereas here
it's a little bit off to the side
although it can still aim for c5 so it's
it's a very difficult decision to make
and vidit is now down to 55 minutes i'm
anticipating a move pretty soon
and uh today we've seen him show up
every day in you know a shirt and a suit
but today he is representing uh wrapping
that with its merch very nice always
love to see
always love to see that and he must be
feeling really relieved after
yesterday's game
for sure a hundred percent and well
we'll see where does that night go does
it go forward to the center doesn't go
to b3 we'll come back here and we'll
come back to all the remaining games of
this 12th round after a short break so
don't go anywhere and we'll see you then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think the first time
i heard about
the tournament here was um probably
sometime in 1999
but the first tournament that i actually
followed was the one in in 2000
so i would say that's my like first firm
memory of the tournament here
probably my best memory from the village
here uh
was the year that i
i won and uh people of baikon say song
sang a nice little song for for me i i
really appreciated that
i think there are people in
my team who are better than me at
working with
with engines so i would say
i'm not so
good at finding ideas with it so i
generally prefer thinking on my own
solving chess is way way out there and
frankly i hope that it won't be
in a very very long time
my goal for this tournament uh is to
have 13 days of good preparation uh and
um
a good mindset when coming to the board
hopefully i'll i'll i can get back to to
my best after a couple of uh
um let's say frustrating performances
the last couple of years
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round 12 here
at the tata sealed chess tournament
and dania we are going to jump back into
our main game of the day the clash
between fabiano carrana and magnus
carlson
indeed we shall in there currently on
this position now interestingly fabi
decided against taking on d5 which we
had been discussing
bishop d5 bishop f5 and i think this
discouraged him from doing so which is
understandable
instead fabi going rook ac one defending
the pawn on c3 and of course allowing
magnus to eliminate this bishop but
that's
bittersweet because yes on the one hand
that was an important bishop on the
other hand white's pawn structure is now
fully intact so i'm not actually sure
that magnus wants to rush to move knight
takes b3
and we might actually see him defending
the d5 pawn instead with
a move like bishop f5 or even perhaps
bishop g4 although i think that he wants
to keep his light squared bishop
uh alive
i don't know we'll see it's an
interesting decision to be made here for
magnus
yeah very very interesting stuff magnus
still
thinking what is the move you expect
um
[Music]
i feel like well knight takes b3 is very
concrete
it seems to be more in magnus's style to
keep the tension my guess would be
bishop f5 if i had to make a prediction
but i could see i could see both uh i
wouldn't be too surprised if he took
either
we will uh come back we'll leave the
world champion to make his decision and
we'll bring back the overview to see uh
what is happening elsewhere and uh
uh dania look at sam against karjakin
it's not the order we fought but it is
on the board let's go back there
amazing and they actually yeah as you
said they did this in a different order
sam he he decided to castle first now my
the reason why i think fiona is probably
because he was discouraged
by this line and can you really blame
him i mean understanding that king g3 is
good for white and then just calculating
this is incredibly difficult and sam
deciding to castle first which did give
sergey
an extra option
of not taking on b2 but instead going
queen b4 or queen b3 in which case he's
still worse but i think i definitely
think sergey should have gone for this
instead he goes head first into this
line and sam to his credit he takes on
c4 he instantly goes king h1 and now
sergey has
gone into the tank and he is in huge
trouble in fact sergey has to go queen
before he has no other choice it's the
only move
he hasn't
he's gone queen
queen bee free
i guess he's made me eat my words um
oh that was his idea
i guess queen takes between rook takes
me three hits tonight but now sam has
the move queen c7
now sam has to move queen c7
and he's hitting the pawn on e5 he's
hitting g7
i guess sergey can go queen b6 that's
the engine line
queen takes e5 check
king f7 and now 95 essentially trying to
eliminate the king's only defender
i mean this is incredibly scary for
black because the bishop
is you know only held by the tenuous of
links the queen is not a good defender
and if knight takes d5 happens that
after queen takes d5 black is losing why
is black losing
because of the line queen e5 check king
f7 and now fiona a very cold-blooded
move rook ac1
activating the rook
and rook c7 is completely unstoppable
here because if black goes rook c8 he's
going to lose the rook at the end of the
line queen f5 check with the fork this
is not the easiest line to calculate
but what makes this easier for sam is
the fact that his moves are basically
forced he has to go queen c7 there's no
really there's no other feasible move i
guess queen c6 check may look very
tempting but this is a trap
it may seem like white recovers the
bishop but after rook hca
white loses the knight in the end and
white loses the game so sam is obviously
not going to fall for that i think we're
going to see queen c7 on the board
and sergey is in mortal danger of losing
this game let me be very clear here 20
moves in yeah
queen c7 and that is objectively of
course as we've just seen the lines are
not easy but objectively a winning
position for for what
it should be and you know really the key
i think this is i think we're going to
see queen c7 queen b6
on the board and really the question is
in this position can samphin knight t5
again there isn't anything else that
even remotely appeals to me 95 makes
sense
from the perspective of eliminating the
king's main defender and what really
kills sergey here is this the placement
of the bishop on f2 is terrible i mean
it totally saddles the queen and if the
queen moves otherwise if the bishop was
anywhere but f2 black would simply have
the move queen e6
now of course this is out of the
question because black will be two pawns
down in the rook end game
and once again i mean this tremendous
opening preparation by uh sam shankland
and indeed in this infamous matchup for
now the momentum
seems to to continue to be on white side
even
six months later
this is classic classic sam i mean he
does this against anybody and he finds a
way to drag people
into his neck of the woods as mikhail
tall said you have to drag your opponent
into a forest where two plus two equals
five and there's only a path back for
one and this is exactly what sam has
done here all he needs now is to finish
the job with a couple more accurate
moves
very very impressive stuff we'll come
back here see if we do indeed go down
this line for now let's bring back the
overview as karjakin and he is already
looking
uh very very concerned probably
realizing that he is in a world of hurt
um where would you like to go next
okay well let's uh let me maybe bring
everyone up to speed on what's happened
in all of the games so far and then we
can decide sure so over on the top left
we have a rosso limo sicilian and
carolina carlson magnus has taken on b3
and followed up with a move queen b6
attacking the b3 pawn
in yesipanko report was that very weird
anti berlin we think that andre is
slightly better and by the way rook d7
and a4 both of those moves we considered
and that has happened
um he's got a very pleasant position bit
it after a tremendously long thing has
decided on
uh the move pawn b3 which is not
something that we thought about
uh and moving to the right top right we
have gary grandelius a solid advantage
out of the opening for anish and i want
to go to the game after i finish the
uh the summary just because there's a
really interesting tactical possibility
there bottom left we just looked at sam
against sergey if sam finds queen c7 he
will be in tremendous shape with great
chances to win the game
and duda van forest is that anti-moscow
where it appears that jan
is on his way to winning the c4 pawn
i think white's position is quite
pleasant there but jordan is very
comfortable in these kinds of sloth
positions so
uh perhaps he he will equalize with
accurate play but if you don't mind
let's hit the giri grendelius game for
just a couple moments absolutely
now
we
have had seen niels play b5 understood
on passant
which is of course the best part of the
game bishop f4
and neil's chasing the queen around the
board bishop b6 and bishop f5 obviously
uh news did not even think about
repeating i just wanted to show a really
cool tactical idea
um if white plays e4 which is incredibly
tempting right i mean
just uh asks to be played you just
attack the bishop grab control of the
center well the movie for
the pawn on e2 was defending the queen
and that turns out to be important if
you notice this x-ray that x-ray enables
black to play knight c5 all of a sudden
and white simply loses the e4 pawn
so it just shows that even in these
ostensibly quiet positions
uh you can always miss a tactic and
that's what makes chess so magical of
course gary did not miss this he played
queen a6 instead the queen is a pest
it's hard to kick away black is in
trouble here i i really don't like
nielsen's position i don't like his time
situation
and and i mean anish just has a dream a
dream slob set up here
i mean black's position looks so crammed
is there any way do we have any breaks
at our disposal or anything to sort of
bring the position to life because looks
pretty depressing right now
yeah i mean maybe you can try b5 you
know advance the pawn to b4 but gary is
almost definitely going to go 95 in
response to most of black's moves
and you well you have to take because
otherwise white's going to take c6 and
you know either bishop takes e5 or
knight d takes e5 both of those look
good uh the email bar didn't like this
move because of knight d5 that's weird
bishop g7
king g7 knight d5
cd queen b5 and i guess uh the point is
that white is gonna have a very hard
time
keeping the b2 pawn alive because this
bishop on f5 is defending the b1 square
so it's never possible to defend that
pawn with rook b1 that's one possibility
but it turns out that white can play d
takes e5 with a really really big
initiative i mean the rook is coming to
d1 uh the knight doesn't have any good
squares no this is uh
this does not solve any of black's
problems and if niels tries knight t5 in
this position
then after knight takes d5 cd it looks
deceptively symmetrical fiona
uh but it's very clear that white is in
the driver's seat the rook coming to a7
and the the structure might be
symmetrical but the piece placement is
very far from symmetrical and is much
better yeah and neil's not having any
fun here today at all he
uh for now just it looks like has to sit
passively which he won't be enjoying
anish could barely have wished for more
out of the opening an extra half hour on
the clock and a
very pleasant position so
let's come back here a bit later bring
back the overview for one second we can
see if
if sam has made a move some is still
thinking
um he's going to play queen c7 there's
no doubt about that
yeah which looks to be the logical move
we just came from there so where would
you like to to go back to
yeah it's a bit of a lull in the action
i mean a lot of these games are going
down the path that we had
uh we had anticipated uh you see us
banker going bishop e3 chasing reports
queen
richard probably gonna go queen c7
um i suppose we can have a look at the
vidit mamidyarov game because vivid has
made a very interesting decision
to play the move b3 which
i'll be honest with you fiona wasn't
even on my radar i mean not just that
but he also spent around
40 let me get the exact time 37 minutes
on b3 whoa
that is crazy i mean
that you enter legendary
a funny story i remember i had this old
book uh by grandmaster andy soltis who
as a gm and a long time chess reporter
uh it was a book of chess stories and
some of them were real some of them were
a little bit embellished but there's
this one story about uh soviet
tournament you know back in those days
the time controls
in the in in the games was you know
twice what it is here
and the tata steel time control is
already very expensive for
modern chess but back then it was like
two hours for 20 moves then you got
another hour
or you started with two and a half hours
the story goes the tall
uh i think it involves michael tall
he was playing somebody
i think he was gibsless or some soviet
master
and he took an hour and a half on one
move and tall went to see an opera
performance and by the time he came back
his opponent was still thinking i think
that's how the story goes i don't know
if i believe that uh but 37 minutes
fiona is a crazy amount of time
and the product of it is the move b
three which is really interesting and of
course i think vinit is preparing to get
this bishop hyper fianchettoed on a3 and
i still think that he's going to put his
knight on a4 uh knight on e4 and he just
has he's played knight e4
and uh this is the position currently on
the board and how does black continue
i'm still a little bit concerned about
the bishop on b6 i also like that bishop
it's putting pressure of course on d4 do
i have to make a move like a6 to
guarantee the safety of that bishop or
are there no threats in that regard at
the moment no not yet you don't have to
play it i think until it becomes
necessary and i think a move like rookie
8 makes a lot of sense here for shock
not only does this bring the work into
the game
but it takes a lot of the sting out of
the move bishop a3 and this uh kind of i
think i'm i'm beginning to understand
why but it played b3 and it's not just
to get this bishop to a3 in fact he
might even leave the bishop on c1
to aim at the h6 pawn he wants to
reinforce the c4 bishop
why is that important well it's
important because black has all of these
annoying
tactical ideas
that are connected with the knight
coming to c3 or e3 let's imagine what
would happen if the pawn was on b2 well
for instance 94 bishop e6
let's make a random move for white for
the sake of illustration black has the
possibility of playing knight c3
essentially forcing a very desirable
trade getting the light squared bishop
and subsequently getting control of the
light squares so vidit puts an end to
all of those concerns although
yeah he does weaken the actual c3 square
so it's a very double-sided move but
he's put a tremendous amount of thought
into it so i have no doubt that he's
very carefully factored in all of the
pros and cons yeah he will have to make
sure that this time investment doesn't
come back to bite him shakia is still an
hour and a half almost on the clock we
only on move 15 will come back here i'm
sure
my media if he will have been happy to
at least to this time investment and
that's maybe something where he can put
some some pressure on the clock going
forward uh for now let's bring back the
the bird's eye view one more time and
see
or if we've had
development some is still thinking
um
maybe we can go back to fabiano and
magnus so
yeah we've had a couple of moves there
let's have a look at this new structure
the structure keeps changing
um as carlson did indeed play knight
takes b3 going for the more concrete
approach
and following that move up with queen b6
this makes a lot of sense attacking b3
fabi defending uh that pawn with a very
sleek looking move queen e2
simultaneously defending upon fiona and
also aiming at
the a7 plan
so now that magnus has taken on be true
on b3 black has uh the bishop pair
in this case i guess this isn't such a
big advantage for black
yeah well the bishop on g7 of course is
quite lame it's staring at the pawn
biting on granite
um and really the question for me is
whether and i think white does want to
play the move c4 here and start
expanding in the center if magnus is not
careful
if magnus plays this in nonchalant
fashion
he could end up just being clearly worse
because again the bishop is bad
and black certainly does not want to
take i mean just look at white's pawns
white's ready to play d5 this is out of
the question so in response to c4 magnus
is most likely to defend the pawn with
bishop c6
but now there's the very interesting
idea of pushing the pawn through to c5
locking up the queen side and then
starting to attack on the king side and
basically saying hey you've got a
terrible bishop now your other bishop is
bad
the position is closed up and i'm the
only one who's having any degree of fun
on the king side so magnus has just gone
a5 and i think this is a very very good
move and i think that the reason is
because c4
is going to be met with a4 a very
important tactical idea
okay so let's see what are the different
options now for for white to meet a
forward
so if b takes a four then d takes c4 and
the point is that rook takes c rook c4
is possible and now not bishop e6 looks
like it wins the game but it actually
loses the game to d5
uh but that's not really the point the
point is that black can kind of go for
the positional sacrifice takes takes
rook c8 look that gets the c file the
queen can reposition to a5 putting
pressure on the rook and this a4 pawn is
probably not going to be
sustainable in the long run white's
going to lose it and then black's going
to have an outside passer on b7 so i
don't like this option
for white
now c5
is also not very possible because of
queen takes v3 the likeliest option here
is probably the move rook b1 to keep the
tension
uh as much as possible a takes b3 the
point is you play rook takes p3 and you
hit the queen can we just and perhaps
magnus will move the queen uh-huh
can we have a quick look at that line
after c5 queen takes b3
uh what if uh fabiano wins the pawn
boxer rook b1 maybe followed by knight
d2
yeah you're right actually that i didn't
notice the move knight d2 and he does
win the pawn back i guess magnus can
take this opportunity
uh to to try to open up his his dark
squirt bishop which fabi could try to
deny with the move f4
yeah i mean
maybe magnus moves his rook to a8 and
drops his bishop back to c6 this is the
the engine recommendation
and white might still be slightly better
in this end game i don't rule that out i
mean the knight coming to a5 that's a
great idea fiona it looks bad but if you
recover that pawn again you can claim
black is a terrible bishop it's
imprisoned really for the rest of the
game potentially
and white can start creating shenanigans
down the b file you know hitting that
pawn on b7 eventually
so yes man man plenty plenty of things
to consider for fabiano
if he does he have alternatives to to
not going
alternate sorry alternatives to to c4
here
i mean he can play it slow he can play a
move like h3 improving his position
uh he could even consider playing h4
which i had previously mentioned and try
to run the spot up the board
and and create the uh preconditions on
the king side for a potential later
attack
and this is a move right up fabiana's
alley he likes moves like h4 which keeps
the tension on the board but
i feel like he's you can see the wheels
turning in his brain he's definitely
sitting there and calculating c4 right
now and if he determines
that c4a4 is
in his favor and if he can find a way to
get a risk-free position he's definitely
going for that and fiona your suggestion
of c5
i think is one of the likelier options
we might see this on the board
i think either he's going to go for this
or he's going to make a move like h4 or
maybe bring the knight back to d2 for
defensive purposes
we'll see but
this is right up fabiano's alley he
likes these types of positions um i like
what he's been doing so far yeah and i
think it's funny actually if we i don't
know if we can maximize the the camera
on fabi but
i think it's clear indeed that he is not
considering h4 because at least earlier
when we were watching him his eyes his
gaze was really focused uh on the queen
side and you could you could sort of
tell that
indeed and i mean
fabi he has his chamomile tea
next to him and when i played him in
in 2017 in the u.s championship a game
in which he crushed me in 25 moves he
managed to down three or four cups of
tea and it's always chamomile
uh during the game like move five or six
you would always hear the hot water
boiler
uh you know boiling in uh the
in in the st louis chess club
uh and you know after the round you know
you would look at all the tea bags and
there was black tea and there was herbal
tea but there were only one or two bags
of chamomile tea left
it is impressive i mean i we never come
to fabiano's game and
to see him without tea so he he does
love
his
he knows the close-up
enjoy
and yeah well plenty of things for
fabiano to consider we expect c4 but we
will come back here
uh let's have another look at the
overview see if we've had developments
elsewhere
let's do it we take a look at our bird's
eye view uh my major i was going to say
magnus
magnussarov
oh by the way
danya i see a question in the chat
from uh
from juho but has dania played fabi
recently
i remember it's been it's been a while
since i've played him
rumor has it i played with the us chain
but you don't remember how that game
went it was a very forgettable
experience
um
[Laughter]
yeah it was not memorable at all
so sorry you were saying uh
what were you saying rappers
no mr shankland also has gone queen c7
as we expected
and
well what else do we see we have rapport
thinking in the position after bishop e3
maybe we can go to his game and see what
he's thinking about it's been fasting
for a long time now
where to put the queen yeah big dilemma
uh he has decision to make queen a5
versus queen c7 i mean to me it's quite
clear that those are the only two
feasible candidate moves you might ask
well what about c5 here well you know i
feel like c5 is possible but it creates
a lot of weaknesses it opens up the
bishop's diagonal
it walks into a pin
it allows white to expand with tempo i
really don't see richard playing c5
now
let's try to weigh the pros and cons of
these two moves so queen a5 is the more
active move and what queen a5 does is it
provokes white into playing b4 which i
think andre will play and then the queen
has to go back to c7 now who does this
favor well that's a hard question to
answer because on the one hand the move
b4 creates a backward pawn on c3 on the
other hand it's part of white's general
strategy of queen side expansion so does
this walk uh does this play into white's
hands or not
very hard to say uh it's a complex
question to to answer
my guess is that richard i would be
leaning toward queen c7 here i feel like
allowing allowing white to play before
probably does more harm than good
and here on draken return to f3 with his
queen reinforcing the bishop and as we
were discussing
he's got a pretty risky position right
now they're kind of playing for two
results um
yeah and i i keep looking at richard's
position wondering how he is going to
get even in that line that we were just
showing after
uh the queen goes back to c7 and queen
f3
how does richard continue there
yeah well i mean
he might have to take the tempo yep
there he goes queen c7
he might have to play a5 you know just
try to slow down white's queen side
expansion because you don't want to get
you know rolled off the board with a5 a6
i mean if you allow that pawn to go
forward
if you fall asleep let's just make a
couple random moves what happens if you
fall asleep well first of all now i can
take on a7 earlier of course you could
play b6 and trap the bishop but now you
can't
and the second problem is that white can
throw an a6
and again i want to keep reminding
everybody that taking on e4 comes with a
tremendous risk because now you're
allowing the incredibly nasty move h4
when you know black has to bury his
bishop with with f6 this is the least
desirable outcome for
mr report so if i had to anticipate a
course of action i think andre is likely
to keep his bishop on e4
now you might ask well why doesn't he
move his bishop back well this allows
black to go e4 and open up his position
it also kind of allows knight d5 knight
f4 so if i had to guess i think queen
queen f3 a5 is a likely course of events
here and richard just has to sit tight i
mean he could go bishop f8 and and try
to improve his bishop but by and large
black just needs to be very careful and
watch for h4
and and keep making small improvements
to his position and maybe maintain the
fortress as long as he can but for now
andreas panko the one having all the fun
uh in this game
he's very focused right there but
he is clearly the one in charge and
richard is going to have to to dig deep
to make
something happen here
um let's bring back
the overview once again
as andre ponders his next move
and
uh yeah we see as you mentioned already
in the shankland game that the queen has
gone to c7
maybe we can update duda against van
furist
let's
do it let's switch over to that game
yeah it's been a while since we took a
look here and once again
things don't seem to be proceeding very
impressively for jkd fiona
oh and uh
not at all just before we have news i
think
sorry to sorry just before we go to this
game uh breaking news archer and eric
guys he has drawn his game against
nguyen and he is with one round to spare
their winner of the challenger section
was such an incredible performance by
the young indian player he has nine and
a half out of twelve he's wanted with
one run to spare and he's qualified to
next year's master group congratulations
to arjun
big round of applause what an impressive
performance by the indian grand master
and
he is by now kind of a household name
among chess enthusiasts everybody should
be familiar with his incredible blitz
skill he's been a participant in many of
the scc tournaments
including the junior scc
uh he is such a an amazing universal
player he earned words of praise from
magnus carlson during one of the
interviews and let me just say magnus
doesn't go around praising just anyone
uh arjun is a very bright career ahead
of him a sparkling performance and a
very well deserved ticket to next year's
master section he's already over 2600
and my guess is that by next year's
status steel he might even be closer to
2700 than he is to 2 600. absolutely
agreed i think uh when magnus has those
kind of words to say about you big
things are very likely
uh to
to be happening for you in the future
and yeah just what a stellar uh
performance i'm sure
maybe at some point we'll have an
interview with arjun as well but for now
let's update uh this game here between
duda and van forest
absolutely so at first i thought that
white was slightly better i thought okay
knight c4 and then white's gonna take on
e4 and you know white's gonna get a
clamp on the position but now you know
jordan played this very concretely he
played e5 very important move
freeing everything in the center and
leading to a series of mass exchanges
after which i think the position
essentially
uh becomes quite symmetrical and dry
knight takes c4 knight c4 queen c40d
jan taking the bishop out of the picture
and going rook after you want i mean the
problem for white is not that he won't
reclaim white is going to reclaim the
pawn
um and and jordan correctly did not try
to cling to the point i mean c5 is a
terrible move because after rooks ac1
you can't play b6
and you're going to end up losing both
the c5 and the d4 pawn
so jordan going bishop e6 and in this
position jan
kristoff is thinking
i mean after queen takes d4 you could
basically offer a draw and if anything i
think if i were to prefer either color i
would prefer black
because i always like to talk about
who's got the smaller pawn majority
numerically not literally because both
sides have upon majority of one pawn
but black has a three versus two
majority on the queen side whereas white
has a four versus three majority
on on the king side sorry i might have
spoken uh and when you have a smaller
pawn majority it's easier to create a
past pawn so
black is
having no problems here my prediction is
that this game might be our first result
and i think there might be a draw for
uh impending from one of the players
yeah and what if uh
if after bishop e6 can why somehow delay
entering the end game
yeah i probably he should quinn a4 is
maybe the best move
uh because you rook d8 would give up the
a7 pawn and hero jordan will castle
and yeah jan can take on d4 with the
rook he has successfully avoided the
queen trade but
you know a position like this is just so
incredibly equal the bishop on g2 is no
no longer any good
and one thing uh well the computer is
giving an interesting repetition queen
b6 threatening bishop b3
and getting the rook on to an awkward
square and then dropping the queen back
to c7
unless uh white wants to allow rook ft8
he has to keep going back to d4 i think
we're gonna see some maybe not this
exact repetition but something of this
nature and i think once again jordan has
just been quite impressive with the
black pieces
with duda never really
getting much
here today so we'll come back but i
agree with you very likely
this will fizzle out what's happening
we need to switch back to sam's game
because they are going down the exact
line that we outlined sam is completely
winning if he finds two moves he is
going to win this game in three moves he
can beat sergey koryakin in under 20
moves in under 30 moves that is
unbelievable now uh what am i talking
about well he's gone 95 and fiona he saw
this move
uh
with you know plenty of time he's got
over an hour on the clock
uh which is so important he's got all of
the time in the world to find the
subsequent two or three moves that he
needs in order to win this game 95 by
shanklin takes takes
sergey has gone queen king e7 and now
this is a very obvious move queen e5
check okay you're you're taking
everything under control if the black
king goes to the eighth ring
rook takes f2
and you lose the game because the b8
rook is going to be lost if you go king
d8 same thing rook takes f2
that leads uh leaves black with three
other moves queen e6 king d7 and king f7
well queen e6 is bad for
many different reasons uh the simplest
is queen takes g7 check and remember
that bishop on f2 is now without a
defender white is gonna be three pawns
up and black and red
king d7 accelerates black's defeat even
further and among the many many things
that white can do white can simply play
rook takes f2 and this is checkmate in
five moves rook d1 check
queen f5 check creating a diagonal check
rook d7 check and wherever the king goes
he's going to be pursued king aide queen
d5 check
king b6 a5 check all hands on deck and
queen d5 is checkmate this is far from
the only win but it's the nicest one you
could also give a check on d1 and win
the game in simpler fashion as well
fiona that forces the move king f7 and
now the absolute crucial move we're
gonna see this on the board will sam
find the move rook ac-1 now why is this
move so overwhelming and sergey will
resign the game if sam plays this move
the reason this is so overwhelming is
that the rook is coming to c7 with
devastating effect and if black defends
from b7 then rook takes f2 happens white
picks up the rook and wins the game if
black defends from c8 which we've
already talked about this is even easier
take stakes queen f5 check for king the
king and the rook sam is one move away
let's say two moves away from defending
sergey koryak amazing about he was about
to make a move the hand was coming out
and i think we're about to see it
i think we're about to see queen e5
be played and i mean
really you don't see
and there it is queen e5 is on the board
wow what a game by sam shankland and
uh karjakin immediately going down the
king f7 line
rook ac1 is extremely natural too this
is what kills sergey here it's it's
really not a difficult move fiona i mean
it's really the only move that you might
even think of because there's one piece
that is not currently in the attack
that's the rook sam might be misled by
rook 81 i'm saying somebody might be
misled by rook 81 but sam is not just
somebody first of all he's got an hour
he can take as long as he needs and he
will rook ad1 is not as good
okay this is probably inaccurate but
rookie d1 uh the d7 square is much
easier to defend for black than the c7
square sam is going to go work ac one
it's only a question of when and it's
entirely possible that sergey will
simply resign when he does that
i mean this is a
really really tremendously
impressive by some who funnily enough
sam he took to twitter as well yesterday
after the draw against duda
more or less apologizing to the fans but
there isn't really anything i think when
you're on the block i don't have
anything to apologize yeah exactly
sam sam did what he what he had to do i
mean when duda offers you a draw with
the white pieces uh in the opening you
take it
and duda is yeah
for sure
and well the chat is asking um
maybe we can try and figure out why
exactly rook a to d1 isn't as powerful
as rook
a2c1 yeah well um let's see rook 81
apparently there is a rook hd8 okay so i
was essentially right rook hd8 happens
the king now has an escape to ga now
imagine if the rook was on c1 here you
would go rook c7 check and that would be
made here white
has no tactics and the problem is after
rook takes state rook takes it again
compare this to the black rook on c8 you
would have the fork on f5 this is what's
lacking in this position the queen
actually simply defends the rook there
is no way sam goes for this this is not
even
i mean the only sam could sam could play
queen f5 check but he's also not gonna
go for this because this gives black the
extra option of tucking the king away on
on g8 and you might wonder well why
hasn't sam gone with kc1 yet well he
knows that this is his chance to be
sergey koryakin to score the first win
of the tournament and uh none of these
players are impatient all of them are
disciplined
and sam will triple quadruple check it
but he will play rook ac one guaranteed
and he is going to win this game amazing
to beat karjakin like this
wow i mean it's almost unheard of sergey
one of the strongest defensive players
in the world it's so seldom to see him
being crushed like that i mean straight
out of the opening and once again you
can only applaud sam's uh preparation
and and
he's about to make a move sorry danya
but uh go ahead
no no no yeah we're watching we're
keeping an eye on him let's wait until
he makes a move beautiful camera work
there and for sergey uncharacteristic
opening laps the fact that he
apparently was not familiar with the
position after the 15th move
is is very uncharacteristic i mean he is
no slouch either in the realm of opening
preparation the guy has played a world
championship match and he goes for one
of the sharpest lines of the of the
samish variation
and he ran out of his prep a lot earlier
than a lot earlier than sam
and this is not a position where where
you can afford to be out of prep it's as
simple as that
and sam
punished him
ruthlessly and this is about to be a a
crushing
crashing win we were saying sam of
course there was absolutely no need for
him to apologize for the quick draw with
the black pieces but if he feels that
way well today he's certainly uh
redeemed himself
there he goes rokay c1 the killer move
has been played i believe
yes it has it has rook a2c1 is on the
board
and now we're looking at karjakin who i
think he already knew for a couple of
moves this one was gone but uh
we've just gone through every single
move there's absolutely nothing he can
do here
there is only i think one if he doesn't
respond he resigns dania you called it
you called it wow
you're resigning and this is not a
premature resignation the game is over
there isn't even a way to force an end
game
white is just winning the queen here so
this is an insane result
and if we if you told me fiona that
there would be a game over in an hour
and 48 minutes i would have never
predicted it to be a decisive result and
i would have never predicted it'd be to
be a decisive result involving sergey
this is unheard of it's an amazing
result by sam
i mean 26 moves and an hour 48
absolutely
as stunning stuff
dania we are gonna go on a quick break
uh but don't go anywhere also if sam
shows up we'll go straight to his
interview which i'm sure you don't want
to miss so don't go anywhere and we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome again in vikings a shrek stands
for
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round 12 here
at the tata steel chess tournament where
daniel we just had our first with
decisive result of the game in under two
hours of play only 26 moves sam
shankland winning his game against
sergey karjakin and what a performance
that was
it was i mean sergey walking into sam's
unbelievable preparation but it wasn't
just the preparation after sergey made
that critical mistake
sam had to figure out this idea of
sacrificing a piece uh and understanding
that the position is winning nonetheless
he played it perfectly he played it
confidently he played it quickly
and uh he defeats sergey koryakin in
under two hours i don't know the last
time this has been done probably
many many years ago and that's not an
exaggeration incredible stuff indeed we
are back in the bird's eye view
and uh well i see that fabiano has just
come see for shall we start
there and the game karana against
carlson indeed let's start with our most
important game that game is heating up
and uh this has the potential to be very
very spicy indeed so
after queen a2a5 fabio didn't go c4
immediately he decided to begin
by improving the position of his queen
and pressuring the e7 pawn magnus
defended it and now we have the move c4
now
previously we were considering the move
a4 in response to to c4 on the previous
move but i i think this is still very
much possible
and all of the options that were
available to fabi
uh with the queen on a2 are still
available i mean he can still play c5
uh he can still play the move rook b1 to
keep all of the tension on the board
and he can still play c takes d5
although this
strikes me as quite dangerous on account
of queen takes b3 and if you end up
losing the d5 pawn well you're gonna be
in quite a bit of trouble so all of this
is possible
but for magnus magnus can circumvent
some of this by taking on c4
and then pushing his pawn to a4 where
yes he gives away a massive pawn center
but on the other hand he gets this
protected passer on a4
uh which is which is a major
uh major boon in black's position but
still it looks a little bit suspicious
after d5
this is what magnus is deciding between
i think
yeah i mean as black i wonder how you
would feel it just feels like visually
if you show me this position i would
think that's not something i ever want
to allow is black
yeah i mean i would be leaning toward a4
here
uh just again visually intuitively
but this is why magnus is magnus i mean
he doesn't really you know he's so deep
in his approach to these positions
that i could see him taking on c4 and
putting a lot of stock into that
past pawn
he seemed to be on the verge of making a
move now he's withdrawn his hand
continues to ponder his options
and we see both players very similar
amount of time left both around the
50-minute mark we on move 20
so nothing pressing there but a big
decision here for magnus
indeed and he really hasn't been getting
into any time pressure throughout the
tournament
that just isn't a problem for him
something that is by the way taken for
granted but magnus has maybe the best
time management of anybody
uh at the highest level you one can't
say that he plays quickly
but you almost never see him you know
making the 40th move with 30 seconds
left on the clock so he's
amazing in that regard for sure and he's
been a big proponent of uh getting rid
of
increment but
dania before
i'm so sorry
before we move on uh we have an
interview ready with uh argenti the
winner of the challengers group with one
round to spare so let's hear it from
arjun
[Music]
arjun irigase you just played a quick
draw and you skirt yourself as the
winner of the challengers group
congratulations thank you i'm very glad
how
um like you had like an amazing run in
the first nine rounds eight out of nine
um
so close to the finish line
how um
how were like the last three rounds
where you were so close already to to
win the tournament well i think i got
slightly lucky in the start
i was completely lost against lucas in
the very first room
and then with with verma them it was
fortunate that he then into my prep
and
after that i just picked up face and
everything started going well
then i thought in the end twice then i
think being solid is fun and i was just
trying to
be solid and only if i get chances i was
trying to go for that you didn't want to
take any risks yeah basically
um
did you already like think about like
wow next year masters
oh not really i'm just trying to
give it all in this tournament and i'll
think about it later
um
how would you rate this in your not only
your chess career but like in your life
like like this amazing thing of just
like winning the challenger yeah surely
this is probably the best classical
tournament i have ever played so i'm
very glad
and tata steel has always been good my
best rapid event is statistical india
that happened and
so yeah
um yeah you already told me you don't
have any big plans for for tournaments
in the in the future and
um
how how would you like to to see your
progress in chess like like will you
work hard
uh to prepare for next year's tournament
yeah i would like to keep it going play
play some tournaments and work hard and
become better as a chess player in
general and get more opportunities and
do it
um
magnus carlsen he thinks that you will
be rated 2700 very soon
yeah i'm glad to have this heard such
words from the world champion himself
it's it's a very nice feeling and it's
surely a confidence booster for me
um
tomorrow one more one more game
um we would take some some risks or
just yeah i can just play freely and
whatever comes i can happily take
okay well congratulations and i wish you
all the best thank you
[Music]
great to hear from arjun arigaisi once
again hearty congratulations to him
what a performance and what a humble
winner he is dania
very humble indeed congratulations to
arch in an amazing uh results and
yeah you know he was talking about uh
his first round setting the tone he was
losing against fenforce and it's funny
how these how this happens like that you
know the first round determines so much
you you survive a bad position
uh and that gives you so much momentum
but obviously uh this wasn't luck this
this was skill and i'm very excited
already to to see how arjun is going to
fare next year in the master section
absolutely speaking of which let's
return to the master section and i think
we're going to dive into david
mamedyarov game with pieces all over the
place and the things heating up
yeah and the first thing to mention is
vivid is now down to 27 minutes
as he has just made a move
and uh we last saw the position after b3
bishop b6 okay so knight e4
centralizing the knight all right rookie
eight
uh vivid actually deciding on bishop b2
i wasn't really expecting this
but he i think is essentially
reinforcing the d4 pawn
and potentially when he plays knight c5
if there's a trade on c5 that bishop is
going to come alive so yeah the bishop
is staring at the pawn at the moment but
it's also doing a lot to solidify
white's position chakra are playing
an interesting but dubious move knight
a5
vivid immediately seizes the opportunity
to centralize his own knight chakriar
reinforces the d5 knight with c6 navid
starting to accumulate pieces on the
king's side this looks very scary for
black and chakra going with a fearless
f6 f6
what would ben say and would ben be
correct dania
well ben was wrong in shanghan's game
you know so
apparently anybody who plays f6 wins in
under two hours uh so maybe chakra are
taking some inspiration from sam's game
and reversing the colors now it's
interesting because there was an option
to play knight g4
which looks like it blunders a piece but
there's an incredible tactic in this
position
that gives white a devastating attack
now what's important to notice here is
the fact that the bishop on e6 is
actually tremendously vulnerable it's
being x-rayed from two different sources
right the bishop and the rook
white has the move knight e to f6 check
and if knight takes f6 boom you take on
e6 now this might still not look
convincing right okay black plays rook
takes e6
and when you play rook takes c6 black
plays f takes g4 and guess what black
has two pieces for the rook but no
instead of rook takes c6 white has the
brilliant inter mezzo knight takes h6
check and this makes all the difference
this destroys
the king's cover this causes the knight
on f6 to be undefended and white is
going to lap up the other pawns on the
king's side with a crushing attack
whereas if black plays g takes f6 once
again the king side is destroyed and
here white goes knight takes stage six
and after king ji sat with another
sacrifice rooked oh my goodness
absolutely insane but look at the knight
and the queen i mean they're just going
to eat the king alive you can also
involve the bishop via a3 then the queen
via h5 and this is total and absolute
devastation after queen f7 check but can
you blame vidid for not spotting the
move knight ef6 check absolutely not and
for that reason he went back to d3 which
is not as good as knight g4 but i still
think that white has a great position
here i mean this knight is going to c5
black's king is now permanently weak the
only thing that concerns me about venice
position is his time situation
i mean i was just gonna ask you about
that that black king on g8 looks
so vulnerable with all the the holes uh
on the the light squares
and if you're white while you've
highlighted tonight uh wanting to to
jump to c5 how else do we proceed to
maybe make use of those light square
weaknesses yeah i mean knight c5 is
probably going to be the next move well
first of all shocker er a lot depends on
what mamidyarov does here
i don't think that he's going to take
this bishop i mean that was vidit's idea
when he played b3 now b takes d4 happens
dislodging
the knight from its blockading square no
this is completely unthinkable and the
knight is nowhere good to go
um now chakra what occurs to me is the
move bishop f7 just dropping the bishop
back and you know eliminating any of the
tactics associated with knight takes f6
check and after knight dc5
well
it's not easy for black to find a move
black is cramped black is weak
and uh if you play a move like rookie 7
to reinforce the b7 pawn this bishop
could always move from b2 to a3 and and
add further pressure to the position
vinid is an amazing position here
and uh this is very uncomfortable for
chakriar he's made the decision to play
quickly this game and maybe that'll pay
off as he has gone bishop f7 and i'm
anticipating
vidit to play knight c5 pretty quickly
he can also by the way go knight g3 and
swing this knight around to f5 going for
the direct attack against the king
that's another enticing candidate move
we'll see as you're saying a lot of
tempting options for vidit uh who has to
watch out for his clock time 27 minutes
he's still got to make 21 moves we'll
come back here but his position looks
very very promising let's go back to the
overview dania
let's do it um okay well uh by the way
magnus is still thinking after c4 it's
very clear that it's a critical moment
he's deciding between d take c4 and a4
that's over on your top
left side of your screen but a lot of
transformations in the yes panko report
game let's go to that one
uh and let's see who these
transformations have benefited
so a lot has happened let's go back a
few moves
so it's interesting after queen c7 andre
i was sort of uh anticipating queen f3
but he decided to defend the bishop from
from the other side he plays queen c4
which i guess also makes sense it's a
very active move
report going rook d6 kind of a neutral
move and here comes b4 andre expanding
on the queen side b6 and b5 and at this
point
uh richard decides to finally pull the
trigger on the exchange and the reason
he does that now is because this c3 pawn
has ended up being a serious weakness
and richard has captured it after the
trade on b5 now rook takes a 7
is probably going to happen restoring
material equality now there's no
question in my mind that andre is still
better the question is how much better
richard could try to go queen b3 here
and hunt for that b5 pawn white has
positional domination but he might end
up losing this d5 pawn and you know
white has to show something concretely i
mean the move h4 comes to mind
lots of uh you know promising options
for white you can't really go rook b1
here though i mean you can but that
allows simplification queen takes b1 and
rook d1 check and if the queens go off
the board fiona i feel like the
significance
of white's uh positional domination
diminishes very significantly
particularly because uh black can play
e4 and finally activate
this this bishop and if you take on b6
here uh black wins the b5 pawn back rook
b1 rook b5 rook a5 and now bishop c3 get
out of there rook a3 and now at the very
least rook takes b5
again that's a very long line i don't
think they're gonna go down that line
exactly
but uh it's somewhere between a big
advantage and
uh you know i don't think white is
winning or anything of that sort but it
feels like jesse panko's advantage has
really not diminished in the last uh
five ten moves yeah it feels like he
needs to find a very precise
continuation to keep yes and the
pressure up because
otherwise it could fizzle out very
quickly if he doesn't find the most
accurate moves
for sure um i think if i had to predict
right at the moment what the likeliest
result is i feel like a draw is probably
likelier than a yes bank a win
but
this is not what report was looking for
when he played that 97 move in the
opening indeed definitely not and yes
panko has handled that opening surprise
uh very well uh before we move on well
let's have a quick look at the standings
what would that mean if richard report
only draws then magnus carlsen
would
be
assured at least the playoff in case he
draws in case he wins he would be
winning it outright basically
if rapper georgia that's correct
i don't know why do i keep getting it so
as long as magnus goes into tomorrow
with a helpful point uh but you're right
if magnus loses uh and report draws then
report can win tomorrow
and catch them but who's report playing
tomorrow that's the question i have
report is tomorrow playing let us see
very quickly
i think a lot depends on depends on his
opponent and vic is getting that
information he's playing with white
against aneesh giri oh that's not a
great pairing i mean anish is so hard to
beat i mean jordan crushed him yesterday
but
uh a report would much prefer uh
somebody somebody other than than anish
in the last round of the tournament so
even with a loss uh magnus is
most likely going to uh claim first
place in this tournament not to suggest
that he has any plans to lose and not to
suggest that
andre yessipanko cannot physically lose
this position but it's incredibly
unlikely
absolutely
how are the ties handled well this year
i'm seeing the question in the chat this
year we have playoffs last year it was
just between the top two finishes with
the best tiebreak this year all players
um theoretically would have been
involved but we already know if we have
a playoff it can uh
only although even that's not no let's
wait for magnus's game today if magnus
doesn't lose then it can be two players
maximum in the in the playoff and before
we return to magnus's game dania we have
the interview with sam shankland already
so let's hear what sam had to say
[Music]
sam shankland yeah you just beat sergey
karjakin in well in a record time like
one hour 40 or something
yeah no i mean i i got some nice
preparation i think he mishandled it
later on but uh i think white should be
slightly better the way i played but
queen b7
it's messy and of course but unless i
miss something i think it just works for
whites uh i know the computer doesn't
give queen b7 but you know there's lots
of variations to calculate so i'm not
sure if i played it right but it i think
it worked out okay yeah like i also just
spoke briefly with with uh sergey off
camera like he missed queen bee queen c7
right or queen b7
yeah i mean i can play queen c6 instead
of queen c7 and then it's
it's probably okay for black i
calculated some line king f7 rook a b1
and he goes i think queen a3 is best and
at the end of it he will get i'll have a
rook and a pawn for two pieces that
don't coordinate well it's probably
basically balanced but um
but no queen c7 is is very strong and
there's a lot of details but i think it
works very nicely
um
yesterday you get like this this quick
game with duda you were black and do
that over the draw and you made this
apology on
on twitter
today i saw like a tweet by janne
where he said that like you were playing
a line that's known to be drawish or
drawn very soon and he asked if you
would make an apology for that um
i had some ideas uh of course it's
difficult to find just i mean you play
against cardiac and just go prove an
advantage with white it's not easy i
mean there's definitely some drawish
lines in the f3 nimzo i did not come
blank i had ideas in them to put him
under pressure so
but you know my attitude towards this
game was i have some new ideas and if he
finds all the moves he can equalize and
otherwise know so
uh but no i felt
i i really sort of felt lousy after what
happened yesterday i mean i don't really
think i did anything wrong playing black
and you know i'm lower rated and he's
white and if anybody's better at sam i
would have continued the game if i had
white but
uh well i guess it motivated me to play
a bit flashier today
um
i think it's your first win in this
tournament this year yeah like it must
be big really for you it's been a rough
event for sure very frustrating i mean
this game with
the game with anish was really bad and
so now still on minus one is not great
but it's funny actually and um the last
time i played the only other time i
played the masters was uh
and i had a lousy event overall but i
beat napalm michigan kramnik in the last
two rounds to finish with a
a good score so with a fine score so you
know it's a long tournament and just
because it hasn't gone well in the
beginning it doesn't mean it has to
continue along that trend and i'm just
glad i was able to play a good game in
the penultimate round yeah um
so you said okay like
you want to do the last two games of the
previous tournament you played here in
vacancy um so does it is it good for you
that the tournament is so long like are
you doing yeah i mean i'm not in as good
physical condition as i used to be i
think i'm still very fit certainly not
like i was when i was younger or right
when the pandemic was ending and i had
been at home working out for a year and
a half but uh i do think fitness helps a
lot in these in these long events and
yeah so i'm just sort of happy that i
got to play a good game in the
penultimate round and you know
ultimately i think i've played really
really badly this tournament and it says
a lot about how far i've come that when
i'm playing really badly my performance
ratings you know 27 something so i'm i'm
happy with that
um well you're known for someone who
knows a lot of theory and like explores
a lot of new openings um which game for
you stands out as like a brilliant uh
new opening idea in this tournament well
i think this one probably was the most
notable in terms of uh
in terms of what i played because this
line was supposed to just be fine for
black but i i thought i had found some
ideas to put them under oppression as
you saw it took was one mistake and the
position really fell apart
um other you mean other games of mine
that were interesting or
tournament in general i mean okay magnus
is killing everybody in the catalan with
uh
with various pawn sacrifice various
bishop e3's that no one has seen before
and you know he's
certainly making the catalan look really
really good uh so
does it inspire you because you you play
catalan yourself i play everything so
you know
i mean the way he crushed mama jarov i
thought maybe i can just do the same
thing to him with the white pieces the
next game and let's just say i'm not
magnus and and shock it well prepared
really well and i didn't get very far
but um
no i mean there's certainly been a lot
of ideas floating around uh i sort of
grabbed the blow by the horns against
escapanko i remember and you know played
into this very sharp time and of and you
know basically
claimed that black was okay in these
complications which he may or may not be
but yeah
okay well thank you so much and wish all
of us thank you
never a dull interview with sam
congratulations once again to him on his
first win and what a win it was
against sergey karyake and dania he is
uh as always still critical very quickly
critical on himself
sam is and i've known him now for
and i'm very i don't like to say my age
anymore
uh but i've known him for well over 15
years at this point and
from the very first time that we played
together at the mechanics institute
chess club
san francisco he he's always been
incredibly hard on himself i mean like
he can
even when he won the us championship i
mean the next day he was busy analyzing
his mistakes and uh
you know excoriating himself for for
various opening inaccuracies and sam is
a consummate professional this is what a
professional does a professional strive
for perfection
and you know when i think of a
professional i think of sam partially
because by his own admission sam
believes that he's not among the most
talented players over 2700 and yet he
probably is the hardest worker he works
very diligently he wrote his excellent
book
about pawn structures in about two
months and i can attest to the fact that
he did not sacrifice on quality one that
that's just who who sam is and it's good
to see him succeeding at the highest
level that's insane and we see that with
his win over karjakin he's almost caught
psyche
understanding sam now on five and half
out of 12 while for sergey he is back
on 50 surely a disappointing
result for him but back to the bird's
eye view and dania where shall we jump
to
where shall we jump to well
uh let's go to the magnus game and let's
uh check in on the developments in that
game as both players taking a good
amount of time to work through the
complications in this early middle game
now um what did magnus decide after c4
magnus uh fiona did indeed decide to
take on c4 very combative move i think
magnus wants to win this game and just
and then to send the tournament straight
away he is playing very uncompromising
chess right now and he goes queen a6
which i think is a lovely move
now what is the idea of this move well
on a basic level he attacks the pawn on
c4
why is that a problem for white because
if fabiano defends it with the move
knight d2 i think magnus is planning the
move b5 essentially forcing the trade of
pawns because if white goes c5 oh that
gives black connected passers on the a
and b files and after c takes b5 queen
takes b5
uh something interesting happens so fabi
can take on c8
and it appears that magnus has to take
on c8 with the bishop in order to keep
e7 protected but that's a little bit
awkward right i mean that keeps the e8
rook out of the game and after rook a1
you're going to have a hard time
defending the a5 pawn in fact you can't
defend that pawn but
i think and uh during the same interview
i was exploring this line rook takes c8
is a very interesting long-term pawn
sacrifice i mean you just give up the
pawn on e7 you say congratulations i'm
giving you that pawn but look at how
active uh these three of my pieces are
that other bishop can come out into the
game via f8 and uh i i always hate
playing against uh coronerize corner
passers even in the middle game that
pawn especially in conjunction with
bishop f8 which is gonna take a3 under
control
is uh just rumbling down the board so
very quickly and uh the engine also
likes black's position so
i'm a little bit concerned here for fabi
who might have to go for c5 but that
gives up this incredibly juicy outpost
on the d5 square i think magnus from a
practical standpoint
is maybe even for choice here
i mean very interesting uh
approach by magnus and he is really it
seems danny at every turn gone for the
most
combative line uh shying away from any
any simplifications here and i think i'm
with you i think magnus and we've been
talking about the different scenarios
who can catch him in which case what is
clear if he wins today nobody can catch
him and that's exactly i think uh what
we think he's after he wants the full
point
against fabi here
and go home to his hotel as the
tournament winner
yeah and once again to clarify if he
draws the game today and richard report
wins today and tomorrow which would be
obviously crazy but possible that is
reports path to catching magnus at the
top as we reviewed the standings
one more time but
magnus has just proven once again why he
is
um
why there is so much hype around him
he's not just the world champion he is
the slayer of these top tournaments and
he has been in phenomenal form
really ever since the world championship
yeah and we also will uh we can maybe uh
bring back the bird's eye view because
at the moment we don't think that
rapport
is a favorite to to win his game as
we've seen a couple of developments
there
yeah well we can go to that game one
more time
because this game is absolutely crucial
for the tournament standings and indeed
uh richard report has gone fiona queen
b3 which we did anticipate this hits the
pawn on b5 and now a very big decision
for yes at fanco this is a critical
moment now we reviewed the move rook b1
suggesting that this essentially leads
to a quick draw uh because it allows
black to liquidate into an end game and
then pick up the b5 font okay black is
nominally worse
because of black's bad bishop but uh
this is not you know the secret sauce
you know this is this is not how how
mountains are moved uh but if y doesn't
go rook c1 then that probably means uh
yes the pangos should just sacrifice the
pawn on b5 and go for activity
what does it mean to go for activity
here well i like the move rook c1 aiming
for c7 with my rook the move h3 is so
important here the fact that yasipanko
has luft means that he's essentially
unafraid of a check on d1 which report
could deliver in this position but what
happens here fiona is if blaccos rook
takes d1 and queen takes b5 uh white is
the one who delivers checkmate not black
rookie a check is completely devastating
king h7 gets checkmated oh what a
beautiful checkmate f6 m8
and if bishop f8 there is a beautiful
beautiful tactical idea guess what the
rook on d1 is lpdo loose pieces drop off
that rook is completely undefended white
sets up the combination with bishop
takes g5 after h takes g5 the calm and
cold-blooded fork queen g4 ends the game
simply because black has to defend the
rook or move it and whatever black does
queen takes g5 check followed by rook
takes f8 is unstoppable checkmate black
can deliver a couple of spike checks but
not more than that after f3 black
comfortably defend white comfortably
defense and mate is inevitable i think
rook c1 is the most testing continuation
and one that puts report in very serious
danger that's such an incredible line i
really hope for yesterpango's sake that
rook c1 is played also for our sake
we'll get more action while rook b1
seems to in indeed
we could see if things fizzle out we'll
see what he goes for
um
is it going to be rook c1 is it going to
be rock b1 is it going to be going to be
something else entirely we'll find out
but for now let's bring back
the bird's eye view um
and update maybe one of the other three
games as nils he is trying to free
himself with a
a g5 push
and where would you like to go dania
let's look at nils's game uh because he
has taken action here trying to change
the course of the game
that's he is in a very uncomfortable
situation against mr geary
okay
well uh we
we were watching we were uh saw this
happen bishop b6 bishop f5 we saw anish
putting his queen on a6 very aggressive
continuation and niels did indeed go for
knight d5 uh creating a more symmetrical
pawn structure now the incredibly nasty
move queen b7 by anish notice how the
queen very nicely cooperates with the
bishop the bishop on f4 defends ba
making it
virtually impossible for black to chase
that queen out of b7 and i think fiona
this is why meals played g5 he said i'm
sick and tired of this bishop on f4
controlling all of these important dark
squares now it goes without saying that
the move g5 comes with uh tremendous
positional and tactical risk i mean
you're you're permanently weak and
you're a king
uh you're leaving the f5 bishop totally
unprotected but the big question for
anisha is where does he want to put his
dark squared bishop there is the move
bishop e5 this might be the most
principled continuation offering a trade
or you could play bishop e3 or bishop d2
and i think these two moves are both
enticing in their own way bishop d2
might be the best move because the
bishop can reroute to b4 and potentially
later pressure the pawn on
e7 course
yeah yeah he's gone bishop d2 now it's
important to point out that uh niels
can't play rook c7 immediately because
he drops the pawn on d5 so i'm expecting
the move knight f6 by niels and finally
he will be ready to get the queen to
smoke it out of b7 either by offering a
queen trade or by playing rook b8
because rook c7 is still going to be
impossible now you're going to lose the
b6 one no question that white is better
but i actually like the move g5 i feel
like this uh this changes the you know
the course of the game just a little bit
this gives neil's a little bit more
breathing room uh but with the time
situation as it is i'm still a little
bit pessimistic
yeah well we'll see neil is definitely
trying his best to hold on here uh
and we'll see we'll see if his
efforts are rewarded dania we're gonna
go on a very quick break before we come
back with all the action here from round
12 so don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fastest
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to round 12 here
at the tata steel chess tournament two
results uh so far sam shankland with an
incredible and incredibly fast victory
over sergey karjakin daniel dubose same
story as yesterday unfortunately
losing by forfeit
because he tested positive so we're
wishing him all the very best but dania
we still have uh five interesting games
going on
uh elsewhere let's bring up the bird's
eye view maybe you can give us a very
brief overview of what's happening in
each game and then we can take a deeper
deeper dive
first starting in the top left garwana
carlson fabi deciding on c5
uh which weakens the d5 square but i i
totally think that it's better than the
alternative knight d2 we'll uh delve
into that uh at some point but magnus
creating exactly the kind of position i
think that offers him
at least some winning chances it's a
double-edged position unclear who's
better we'll keep an eye on it uh moving
to the right yessipenko going queen b7
not going for rooksy one he's in the
driver's seat um and report in a lot of
danger as he's got weaknesses all over
the board he has to tread very carefully
uh we will delve further into the vidiq
game in just a couple of moments but
vidit seems to be in the driver's seat
as well the only concern for him really
is his time situation
and uh anish geary continues the
pressure against niels grandelius who's
in a very uncomfortable situation and
he's in time pressure of course sam has
defeated sergey karjakin in exceptional
fashion
duda van forest uh fiona i think is
extremely balanced this that game has
been heading for a draw really for the
past 10 15 moves
but we'll keep you updated on that one
as well but shall we have a look-see at
the vivid game absolutely let's take a
deeper dive
uh there as you mentioned the first
thing to note with it under 19 minutes
on the clock we're on move 24
so 16 moves still to make but we have
been liking his position for a while
dania
we have and yeah 18 minutes wow but uh
mamadiarov has decided on something
interesting he's lost his patience and
he's taken on c4s and i'm tired of of
this bishop exerting this much pressure
on my position the downside of this is
that the d5 night has essentially met
its demise and has to drop back to e7
but the reason he does this i think
first of all vidit has to adapt to a
completely new type of position
uh with very little time on the clock
and of course the d4 pawn is now hanging
it appears that white has the very
strong move bishop f4 here
the point is that the trade is out of
the question because the rook is simply
trapped and obviously well black can't
take on d4 because he drops the bishop i
think that it is going to do this
and man oh man is shakira's position
unpleasant here
yeah i mean how do you even meet uh
bishop f4 what's the best
none of what we saw they looked too
convincing
well they're they're stockfish uh likes
the move f5 i mean it doesn't like the
move f5 but this may be forced
and after bishop takes c7 queen takes c7
oh man white has a very interesting idea
95 which is a straightforward move right
i mean you can't take on e4 because if
queen takes f7 but the reason this looks
like a blunder is rook takes e5 right
and okay de5 fb4 black's got two pieces
for a rope but no
this game is so full of intermezzos and
here once again white gives up the other
night on his own terms he said i'll let
you take it but you've got to completely
destroy your own king position and after
d takes e5
that king position is
massively concerning i think plaque is
close to being lost in this position
and witted what a for him the tournament
has had plenty of ups and downs he was
one of the early tournament leaders he
got off to a fantastic start then
unfortunately uh the last few rounds
haven't gone his way
so much although yesterday he did a
great job to hold on against magnus
carlsen and the wind today uh he's out
of contention pretty much for for first
but still a win today would be huge
and
with the last game tomorrow that could
still see him finish at the
top near the top of the standings
has a lot of fans and for very good
reason he's such an enterprising style
uh he plays to win every game and he's
one of the nicest people you'll ever
meet just period but definitely at
2700 plus level he's very modest uh he
lets his moves speak for themselves and
uh
yeah he's uh he's very easy to root for
uh as is chakra of course but fit it now
down to 15 and a half minutes fiona he
has to make a move pretty soon he's
basically has a minute per move which is
not a lot in the middle game of this
complexity yeah that probably is the
main problem he is facing today the
position as we just uh went through uh
looks very promising bishop f4 is the
move we're expecting but he's gonna have
to make up his mind very soon indeed for
now let's go back to the overview
um and maybe we can take a a closer dive
at fabiano's uh decision to go c5 or
where would you like to to start
i like that idea let's do it well and uh
just to remind everybody of
what fabiano was deciding between the
the main alternative was to defend the
c4 pawn but allowing b5 and giving black
this outside pass pawn with the c file
wide open
wasn't appealing to fabiano
understandably so as he goes c5 now
another decision for magnus i think
fiona the obvious move is bishop d5 that
is bishop c6 and bishop d5
but the funny thing is optically it
looks like black has total positional
domination but white has his share of
assets as well and after rook b1 fabi
could try to park this rook on b6 that's
a very unpleasant square and uh if
you're magnus you want to be very
careful
uh to preserve this a5 pawn if you end
up losing that pawn let's not forget
that black's dark squared bishop is
completely out of the game and even if
it were to move to f8 it would still
bite on granite and so for that reason
uh a very serious option here is to play
b6 essentially the same type of idea as
b5 against knight d2 offering a trait of
pawns
fabi though could play d5 advancing in
the center even further
and this position is wild i have no idea
what's going on here it's incredibly
double-sided i'll let the players figure
this out that's why they're entitled
steel and i'm not
d5 is incredible what if instead fabiano
simply trades uh pawns
yeah well this is very similar to uh
to to the position after 92 b5 in fact
magnus could throw in rook takes c1
first if he doesn't want to give away e7
and i feel like magnus would be very
happy with a position like this again
he's gonna play a4 anchor the pawn to
the bishop and in the long run i feel
like practically speaking this is quite
unpleasant for fabi i think that if
magnus goes b6 we will see
uh d5 on the board i'm quite confident
of it because yeah even here magnus
could go a4 but at least white's got
a very serious asset in the form of
these incredibly intimidating central
pawns
for sure still so much life in this
position and also here we have to keep
an eye on the clock it's not too
dramatic yet but both players around the
half hour mark the position is so
complex and we only move
22 so
another thing to keep an eye on
yeah i mean all it would take is really
just one more long think by one of them
and poof there in big time pressure
so for sure for now let's bring back the
overview as magnus is still debating his
next move
and um
yeah it seems like on the bottom right
perhaps we could check into duda's game
against jordan which sure i will full
disclosure is the least interesting game
of the round
uh perhaps with the exception of do bob
against
prague but i think it is it is the game
likeliest to end within the next 15-20
minutes but why do i say that well we
have another we have a trade of brooks
on deck here this trade is going to
happen i think duda is going to take on
d8
and uh as i mentioned previously
generally speaking in such positions the
three-on-two pawn majority is superior
to the four on three pawn majority
because it's easier to create a pass
pawn and duda certainly does not want to
trade queens for that reason but perhaps
he can play the move e5
and this does lead to a queen trade but
with one caveat after e takes f6 queen
takes f4 duda can throw an f takes g7
check and uh he gets himself actually
two pass pawns on the f file but fiona i
still think this position is a dead draw
because white simply cannot make
progress white cannot push the pawn past
that five and uh one way or another i
think this game is hurtling toward a
peaceful conclusion i'm with you i feel
like the players entering territory
where they will both you know there will
be these looks at each other and
i think at some point we will see
a simplification here and a
peaceful outcome
which will be a great result for jordan
with the black pieces um
he's only made three draws so far in
this event but it looks like a fourth
could be on the cards uh today and
danya anything else about this game or
shall we move on
we have a breaking news alert uh vinid
has just made an incredible move let's
fly on over to that game he has just
sacrificed a bishop wow he now has 12
minutes on the clock let's analyze what
that's all about
bishop takes age seven the h6 the last
time we came from here we had just seen
some of the potential of all the tactics
that that are in the position but this
one had escaped our attention
bishop takes h6 and the only other
instance where i thought this move was
likely if we rewind all the way back
remember when vinnie played b3 the move
knight e4 created the threat of bishop
takes h6 so this pawn is always a hook
in these types of positions but i was
not expecting it here now what is this
all about what happens if my maduro
takes well
i'll be taking is out of the question
for chakra because after knight takes f6
black loses on the spot if you move the
king then white
uh recovers the piece with a devastating
attack and if you take the knight well
here the attack is still completely
devastating so shakuya will not take
this bishop what will he do well one
move that comes to mind is queen takes
d4
and here i think vinit probably should
drop his bishop back maybe to f4
uh and you know much like the immediate
bishop f4 this puts black
uh in a very uncomfortable dilemma fiona
because if you take you allow the the d3
knight to jump into f4
and well if you don't take your bishop
is hanging so what what the heck do you
do
um the engine is suggesting the
ridiculously cold-blooded knight g6
and the main line actually goes bishop
takes g7
takes g7 and now knight drops back to g3
now what is this well the point is that
you want this knight either on f5 or on
h5 and if black takes on g3 then white
doesn't take back on g3 no no no white
takes on e6
and white has very clear and massive
compensation for the piece white's
already got two pawns he's going to take
a third one and black's king is in the
long run very very weak i think this is
a very interesting decision by minute
it's double edged but this is the kind
of chat we all love i mean kudos to him
uh it takes a lot of guts to go for a
move like bishop h6 with only 12 minutes
on the clock
and
well shakia he is thinking but this one
12 minutes danya
yeah i mean 12 minutes for for 15 moves
or whatever i mean that is
i would be terrified here and you know
vinit has
made that time investment so presumably
he's going to play quite quickly
in the next couple of moves and and the
encouraging thing forbidden is that one
way or another
the smoke is going to clear i mean
whether it sacrifices on g7 or whether
he drops the bishop back to f4 i think
he is going to have the potential of
making a couple of moves quickly and
building up a little bit more time
getting himself a little closer to
uh move 40. which of the two lines we
looked at did you prefer for for black
would you be more attempted by knight g6
or taking on d4
i would be more tempted by knight two
six and i should just add that if if
white drops the bishop back to e3 white
loses
uh suddenly the knight jumps out to h4
this doesn't seem dangerous white just
plays queen g4 but
in comes f5 and white's queen is
actually basically trapped on top of
that white loses
the knight on e4 so that's out of the
question
and unfortunately and this is the
secondary point of knight g6 bishop f4
doesn't come with the same effect
because here black actually just can't
take both pieces on f4 and then
take uh the pawn on d4 and knight takes
f6 check as enticing as this looks it
just doesn't do anything on account of
queen takes f6
some crazy lines here knight g6 the move
you're expecting shakia he still has
plenty of time 47 minutes on the clock
and i'm just seeing about the sound
effects the whoops
i'm very good at detecting
distinguishing between dogs and
boars
you know i know exactly what a dog
sounds like sorry go ahead
very constructive comment by me it's a
it's a weird dog sound but yeah we we
know your definition of a dog so we'll
allow it
um let's go
let's move on for here from here for now
but we'll keep a very close eye
especially with
at the time situation and we'll keep you
posted about any developments
um
magnus's pawn
magnus's
pawn has
has moved it's moved to a4
and
you know who's not a big fan of that
the pawn moved to a4 i think fabiano
shall we very quickly uh yeah see what
that's about
yeah so the pawn is moved to a4 where
it's completely anchored by the bishop
so
let's rewind just a second
uh backward
magnus not not going b6 but instead
going for that first option we analyzed
bishop c6 which i think is the more
natural move and after rook b1
notice that fabi is he's not afraid of
bishop takes f3
and nor should he be bishop takes f3
looks tempting
but it's not worth giving up that
incredibly valuable light squad bishop
for a superficial weakening of white's
king which black can't even exploit
because black's uh way too cramped to
exploit it
so magnus going a4
and fabi contemplating uh his course of
action i mean he could go knight d2
potentially aiming to swing the knight
to c4
the the tempting move here is probably
rook v6 and my guess is that magnus has
prepared the move queen c4 when the
queen
could actually swing to this amazing
square on d5 that actually is the main
idea of knight d2 you're preventing the
black queen from migrating to the center
i actually think that queen c4
is a positional threat what does that
term mean that means something that
doesn't win material but but something
that greatly improves uh the position
of one's pieces so i think fabie
shouldn't allow that i have a quick
question in that line where the queen
went to
so if we go with b6 queen and queen c4 i
was wondering is there any way
we can somehow give up uh the exchange
for the bishop and take the pawn on a4
yeah well that's definitely an idea and
okay knight d2 let's say queen d5
unfortunately rook takes c6 here doesn't
really work because of queen takes c6
but if black had been forced to take
with a pawn
uh i still don't think this is great for
right but let me tell you under what
circumstance i would consider i would
consider this if the white knight had
already been on c4 here because then the
knight is aiming for b6
and i understand where you're coming
from because uh black is now left with
just a very very lame bishop the big
issue for me here is the placement of
black screen which is just divine so i
feel like this would be risky but
definitely something that that is on
fabu's
radar no question about it
and
sorry i thought something was happening
apparently we had a blundering finish oh
my god did you just miss that five did
he just miss a five oh what am i crazy
god
oh my goodness he's just blundered a
piece in the game he just blundered a
fork he completely forgot he completely
forgot the black queen will defend g7
after this all my lands
what a devastating moment this is the
time pressure got to him fiona the time
pressure got to him tragic forbidded as
we see the head disappear into the hands
i wonder if he's already seeing it
and chakri are
in disbelief shakur is probably thinking
what am i missing here is this too good
to be true vinnit can simply resign
after f5 the game ends immediately white
loses
all of his pieces
i mean not just the bishop neither the
knight is hanging white has to go for
the queen train because after queen g5
simply rook takes h6 queen takes e7 f
takes e4 and black takes more pieces
than white the knight on d3 also falls
this is unbelievable
and uh an absolutely tragic moment for
forbidden chucker it's going to go at
five yeah and did you see the look that
shahir was throwing he was looking
straight outfitted like
like what what is this what are you
doing what am i missing and he's going
to con the conclusion he's not missing
anything f5 accompanied by the stare and
that is game over
what
what an unfortunate moment forbidden and
let me guarantee you fiona that it's not
f5 that bit it missed i think vidiq
completely hallucinated
and forgot that now the queen defends g7
it's one of those things right right now
g7 is undefended and you think well i'm
threatening checkmate my opponent has to
go knight g6 but that queen that
diagonal defense of a pawn can be easy
to miss
in time pressure of course this is
tremendously uncharacteristic for
someone of its caliber and we've had a
couple of these types of blunders
in this tournament but let's also not
forget this is round 12. a vedic had a
tremendously difficult game against
magnus but all of that aside he is going
to be absolutely furious with himself
because had he played bishop f4 i
believe that white has a huge advantage
here and excellent chances to win the
game yeah a tragic moment for village we
see him in disbelief shaking his head
maybe you just didn't see it coming i
thought he might have seen it
before shaq played this sometimes
happens and i think dania we've all been
there sometimes we make a move and we
immediately understand that move was a
blunder but in this case it seemed like
vidit hadn't hadn't seen it until it
appeared on the board and we see him
there
sort of knocking his head and thinking
what
was i doing how did
i miss this and
tough to watch
but uh danny as we said chef is a cruel
cruel game unforgiving especially with
someone like shakir mahmedyarov sitting
up with it
and uh it's one of these blunders as
well that there is not even any fight
left it's just too big a blunder and
yeah
it's it's one of the most related by the
way i just want to show one
idea that someone in the chat proposed
which is the move knight f6 check
uh attempts to intercept the queen and
the g7 pawn but it doesn't work because
black simply takes on f6 with the queen
and after rook takes c6 you take back
and if white tries rook takes c6 well
obviously you don't take the rook
instead you take the queen and then you
take the rook and the game is over but
this is one of the most relate
universally relatable sensations it
doesn't matter if you're 27 30
or 22 50 or 600 the feeling of just
having blundered and then realizing it
as it dawns on you that you do not even
have a single way to complicate the game
it's one of the most devastating
feelings
in all of chess and uh you can just see
it all over bit it's faces he grabs his
head this way and that way
and
you know you feel forbidden it's a
tremendously painful moment
but for chakriar i mean he played in a
very practical way he he played quickly
and once he realized that his position
was bad
i think the fact that he that he kept
the pace going
really
was disorienting forbidden and caused
bitter to burn probably more time than
he should have yeah
and i've really never seen vidit i think
be so shook
uh of course for players of his level
it's tremendously rare to make a one
move blunder of that of that caliber and
unfortunately for him he also only has
less than 10 minutes to to come to terms
with uh what's happened here
well he's very likely going to resign
simply in this position
there's
nothing that he can do it's completely
lost and
and that's a little bit unlucky because
of course black has all these undefended
pieces white's got the pressure down the
e file
in normal circumstances white could have
tried to move like queen takes g7 check
and bishop to hg7 but after king takes
g7 knight g5 this is a paper tiger i
mean white doesn't even have any threats
and black can simply move the knight
aside he has a full extra piece
uh in the end game there's nothing to
play for
and i think that's exactly when you when
we look at fit it now uh what's
happening in his mind first is the shock
of how did i miss this and then
yeah then the realization i don't even
have
any way to to fight to fight on without
being completely
lost
yeah he's he's
i mean this you've phrased it in exactly
the right way
the question you're always asking
yourself is how is it possible
how could i have possibly overlooked
this move now how could my brain how
could my neurons have misfired in this
way
um and it just shows that it can happen
to anybody
at any moment i mean no matter how
experienced they are no matter how good
you are
once in a while once every hundred games
you're going to have a moment like this
and it's always shocking when it happens
but it does happen
and
well it looks like he's going to get the
full point here uh reminder he was one
point behind magnus carlsen going into
the round so he will be needing uh
he will be needing magnus to lose to
have a chance to tie with him uh in case
of another win but either way uh for
shahia with this uh
gift from vidit
he's had really a tremendous tournament
not over just yet but the way he he
played i think from a practical point of
view as you were saying daniel quite
impressive he never he kept maximum
pressure despite being on the back foot
and um well it's paid off now as you see
with it down to six minutes
and uh
yeah yeah just a tough touch
this clock continues uh to tick and
again the only real question now is
whether he will resign here
or whether he will make a couple more
spite moves
but it's uh devastating absolutely
devastating nothing else to be said it's
just painful yeah for sure and well
we'll i will see if this game goes on
for now let's bring back the bird's eye
view
um i see fabiano did not play knight d2
if there is nothing more pressing maybe
we can check in
with them again or what else sure we can
review that because magnus has also
responded to that
um there's a couple of other interesting
developments in particular duda when
forces sharpened up but first our top
priority of course is to keep tabs on
on the biggest game of the tournament
and you know fiona i think rookie c1 has
the exact same idea as knight t2 it
prevents the queen from maneuvering to
d5 and once again
white is never afraid of bishop takes f3
magnus responds by improving the
position of his own rook brick c to d8
and now the move rook b6 is very very
tempting and i think quite likely
the rook b6 okay let's have a look where
does the black queen go um
well there's a couple of choices if you
go queenie two
you could end up getting your queen
trapped here although i don't
exactly see a way to do that and in fact
a repetition would not be unlikely here
i would give about a 10 chance that the
game ends in exactly this way that would
be funny wouldn't it uh but if magnus
wants to hilarious uh playing a more
conservative style he can play queen a8
and yeah the queen looks very bad here
but let's not forget the queen can
re-enter society through c8 and then
potentially to g4 so fabiano can't
exactly fall asleep on that queen either
and here there's a very interesting
maneuver 91 with the idea of going
knight d3 and then knight before trying
to get rid of this
uh gnarly bishop on c6 which looks
pretty tempting maybe magnus will try f6
at some point to finally free up his
bishop it's hard to say here fabiano
could go f4 but f4 always is an
incredibly committal move i mean it
weakens the king tremendously and the
question is well how badly does white
want to keep this bishop out of the game
yeah i think i'm with you it's very
likely fabiano maybe these other lines
as some of them are really quite crazy
and hard to evaluate who is better but i
think if fabiano doesn't feel like any
of these other lines give him any
serious chances we could be very likely
to see a repetition the other question
is after rook b6 might magnus play on
and not go to e2
yeah well i guess there's two questions
the first is you know does white have
anything more dangerous than repeating
there is a very i mean h3 is the engine
move but it really is an engine move
um and fiona you kind of called it the
engine line is h3 now f6 and here comes
the exchange sacrifice rook takes c6 and
queen takes a4
and this is the best version of it
because c6 is hanging and the queen on
e2 is suspended
all of a sudden on a very disquieting
square it can't really go back without
allowing oh now there's queen a2 check
and rook b1 and the queen keeps dangling
around and stumbling around the board
and keeps walking into
uh various attacks so
that's one possibility but h3 man
playing a move like h3 is particularly
when there's a repetition and you can
just end the game and go home
uh is is a difficult thing to do and by
the way look at the clocks 20 minutes
now for fabi they are very very quickly
entering
serious time pressure
uh a time pressure phase
for sure and well it is pretty much a
rapid
apologies it's getting colder here and
like
it's pretty much a rapid game uh now
between these two as we see
uh fabiano i thought he was gonna make a
move but no let's bring back the
overview uh our chat they are cruel they
want to see uh david come let's see has
with it made a move no he's probably
very low let me quickly have him yeah he
must be down under two
under
minutes
minutes he's got a minute 40 and
yeah i mean resignation is essentially
impending
um and also i mean
16 moves in a minute and a half to mommy
the rs 45 there's just not a single
chance here yeah we'll just have to
update here there we go the clock times
are updated and um
and yeah
with it coming coming to terms that just
is really
when i watch this sometimes i think it's
a good thing i don't play as much as i
used to because it's just tough to to
even
watch it but to experience it in the
flashlights and no fun
yeah you just have this incredibly
disgusted sensation especially toward
the end of a tournament you never want
to end
uh and of course there's one more chance
for vinit tomorrow to redeem himself
but nonetheless you end a tournament
with one of these games and that's just
what sticks in your head it's like man
i blew such such a good position
and 45 seconds out forbidden let's see
he is about to make a decision i think
that maybe he'll play
um
i don't even know what what it is he'll
do maybe he'll play bishop takes g7 or
queen takes g7
30 seconds now and i mean you see the
devastation of vidic just not being able
to find anything because there isn't
he's been spending the last 10 minutes
trying to find anything even if it's bad
that will at least keep him in the game
but now danny have 15 seconds
right and i i just there's a comment on
the chat that i'm
you know i assume you know what the evol
eval is well they do know what the eval
is in this case vidit uh probably
established that within the first
two milliseconds of looking at the
position
and he's taken on g7
he has a
yeah probably one of the best try so uh
queen takes
is what we're uh what we're expecting
yeah and i mean knight f6 check
is possible here rook takes f6
unfortunately white has to trade queens
now this is completely lost as well but
the interesting thing is that black even
can play the move queen takes d3
and uh okay so the queen is still
attacked so you you don't have a
discovery after queen g5 the fearless f
takes c4 simply wins the second piece i
don't think shakur is going to go for
this this is a
a very gutsy decision
because if the bishop gives a check on
f6 then the knight covers if the bishop
gives a check on e5 then the then the
row covers after queen takes c7 the
game-winning move is queen takes h3
but i don't see the point in going for
something this concrete when you can
just
uh sorry when you could just take on g7
and literally just immediately force a
queen trade well shakia has plenty of
time on the clock so he might be
considering it we're gonna go on a very
no actually he's made a move and he has
you're absolutely correct and you had
simply taken on g7 why complicate his
life
yeah and let's just uh see if it resides
here will he play no he'll play another
move he'll take the queen
and then he'll probably go knight g5 and
you know make a couple more moves do his
best he does have a three on one on the
king's side unfortunately that pales in
comparison to the extra piece of course
oh yeah knight g4 is uh on the board and
well we might fit at c we might see him
play until
move 40 sometimes you often i think when
you're under a minute you just play on
uh up until you've made the time control
and you reconsider then
right
no that's that that's pretty likely and
inertia kind of keeps you going in these
situations you're still
partially in disbelief with what's
happened and shaq has just traded rooks
only two i think he's gonna be playing
uh
relatively fast not too fast
to miss anything but
um i think he
he now knows this one is in the bag and
a few more precise moves will will lead
to resignation
absolutely
um i think dania we are going after all
to go on a quick break but then we'll be
back with all the action here from round
12 very very soon don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
magnus carlsen will he take his revenge
well he is certainly out for it a win
today would guarantee him outright first
with around his bear since tomorrow he
has a walk-over win against duboff and
danya
things are happening so let's dive
straight back in
things are indeed happening a big turn
of events as magnus was the one who
sacrificed the exchange how did this
happen well rookie c1 rook cd8 happened
knight d2
in this position we considered this on
the previous move magnus did in fact
play queen e2 infiltrating with his
queen
now the engine was proposing actually to
move knight back to f3 but fabi playing
pawn f3 trying to blunt the bishop but
this move came with a very serious
drawback
this bishop on e3 turns out to be
overloaded and boom rook takes d4
immediately played by magnus he
sacrifices the exchange for a pawn why
is the sacrifice good and this seems to
have been
made majorly underestimated by fabi if
not outright missed the problem is that
white's position well it doesn't fully
collapse but the combination of the bad
bishop on d4 the weak pawn on e5 and the
fact that black has this eternal pawn on
a4 which is now completely impossible uh
to ever dislodge gives black tremendous
compensation for the exchange black is
simply better here now how does this how
is this likely to unfold well if white
plays queen c3 which
uh to me looks very very natural black
could even consider
trading queens
and the funny thing is that in this kind
of end game fiona black goes bishop h6
the bishop is infiltrating to e3 after
rookie one he can park the rook behind
the pawn and just start pushing this
pawn all the way to a2 so in return for
the exchange black is a pawn and just
massive positional domination blacks
bishops are worth their weight in gold
and if fabi instead of queen c3 goes
rook d1 to chase black's going away the
queen will happily jump on over to f4
and increase the pressure on the e5 one
white
uh has should not have allowed this and
magnus carlsen is now firmly in the
driver's seat i wouldn't call this a
blunder by fabi it's not nearly serious
enough to call it a blunder but what it
is is a serious mistake and quite
possibly it stems from a mis-evaluation
of this position what alternative events
and a big chance for magnus to end the
tournament right here and right now
dania a little bit of
funny trivia well funny
quote-unquote brackets and today's
shankland's game ended on move 26. with
its blunder came on move 26 and 26 was
also the move on which fabiano played f3
which led to rook takes d4 so today that
seems to be
uh the move where everything happens
that's
actually pretty crazy three separate
games with the turning points all
happening on move 26 my goodness that's
that's awesome incredible stuff and it's
also how it's also my age so a lot of
bad things happen it's 26.
and fabiano yeah well we see him what do
you think do you think he just missed it
or
i don't think he missed it i'm in fact
i'm not i mean maybe one day he will
tell us i'm 99 sure he said it is a
really simple idea
i just think he didn't take it too
seriously right because okay he's up in
exchange it's not like black has
anything super concrete here the reason
black is better and let me be very clear
about this is not because of some oh
this specific tactic it's just that
again it's the combination of black's
incredibly active bishops and the fact
that without the d4 pawn
white's position is
you know slowly kind of falling apart
black short can come to d8 the bishop
can come to h6 so all of this piece
activity gives black tremendous
composition i think fabiano just didn't
evaluate it properly rook d1 has been
played by the way and now a decision for
magnus instantly quinn up for and magnus
he's also so good at this he doesn't
waste
any time it's not so easy a move like
rook takes before magnus made it
within seconds
uh so he had already probably seen this
from a distance but also he really trust
uh trusts i think his instincts in such
situations a lot dania
he does and this is the time management
we talked about right magnus rarely gets
into time pressure and this is the
reason why even people uh at the very
top they tend to take uh you know a
couple of minutes just to double check
everything but magnus as you said he
trusts his instincts for very good
reason and and these are the moments
when he gets his opponents into massive
time pressure now he is attacking the e5
pawn and he is threatening to take it uh
at which point he'll have two pawns for
the exchange and he'll actually be up
material can fabby defend that pawn well
he can with queen a1 but that's an
incredibly awkward move
yeah a tough challenge now ahead of
fabiano also with the clock situation 13
moves remaining only still needs to make
12 moves so it's roughly
one minute
per move which is not a lot and i think
magnus has just made another big step uh
towards winning this event we had a
result actually in the game between
andre yassepenko and richard report
which is huge for the tournament
standings uh dania that game ended in a
draw
that game ended in a draw which means
that with a draw magnus carlsen secures
the win in the tournament that doesn't
necessarily mean that he will offer one
straight away
uh we know that magnus plays to win but
andre not able to convert a very
promising position
due to
uh reports uh wonderful defense and
fiona i think this was the turning point
yeah let's just wait until we bring
let's pull up the big board yeah so here
we are so this was the turning point we
talked about the move rook c1 and i
think that would have put black in very
serious danger
andre playing a similar move in spirit
he gets the queen to b7 but i think he
forgot
that that move allows richard to open up
his bishop e4 is a fantastic defensive
resource
and if you go back to take this pawn
then black has the time to take b5 and
this is a very significant improvement
with the bishop uh finally getting
opened up andre going king h2 richard
with another accurate move rook fade
over protecting the f7 pawn and now we
have a bailout takes takes rook b1 and
now a queen trade and once the queens
get off the board and the bishop is
activated uh black really has absolutely
no problems here and we have a trait of
bishops and a draw is agreed in a
completely level rook end game a a solid
game by both players and richard i mean
he'll be unhappy from the perspective
that he didn't get to win but man
beating andre on demand with black is
all but impossible a good defensive
effort by richard and a solid result for
sure and as you said well now all eyes
even more so than before it's always
been our main game on magnus carlsen
shall we very quickly we have it on the
camera
um yeah so we can very quickly see
uh that his game um
is nearing the end
it's nearing the end now vinita has done
a very good job actually of of
you know challenging mamadiara forcing
him to continue playing accurately right
now vidit has two pawns for the piece
uh but yeah my mdrf has just captured
one of them
uh they've liquidated it into that end
game this is completely losing and yes
white has a past pawn uh
technically speaking but just look at
its pieces the knight is trapped on e1
if he goes king e2
uh mamedyarov sends him back with rook
d2 and then potentially goes after the
apon i think that it might resign right
here actually i think this is the moment
he might extend his hand
and he still looks in in disbelief and
it it tells you
something about just how
rough a moment this is for him this
could very well be the worst blunder
he's made
in a in a really long time and
i'm not easy to get over that hopefully
he can bounce back for for tomorrow uh
but
really tough tough thing with it like
this
it really is and rook h4 allows a
beautiful win actually uh fiona oh my
goodness mom and darf can win the game
with the move knight e3 check
and he's gonna see this after king e2
you take on e1 and then you win a second
piece and if f takes e3 happens then the
bishop swoops into g3 hitting the
rotating the knight threatening
checkmate rook h7 checking g6 and the
game is is over king e2 is forced and
now black takes the knight and then the
rook that would be a very pretty way uh
to cap off a nice effort i think shakur
is going to see this he is a tactical
wizard
and uh this is beautiful but not
terribly difficult i agree with you i
think he's going for it 93 it's on the
board already there was this there that
was premonitious of knight e3 coming and
now well
uh resignation really is probably the
only option because yeah this is just
the final nail in the coffin and kudos
to shah i mean the speed at which he
played this 93 but this is his bread and
butter really these uh
tactics and um
he's been he's had a brilliant
tournament
he really has and he plays with
tremendous confidence
uh really at all times and that's what
makes him such a difficult opponent
practically speaking he chooses
practical continuations he gets people
in time pressure it's not really a
coincidence
that vinid was in such a cute time for
susha
makes the kinds of decisions and steers
the game uh
usually into very complex territory so
he's a tough opponent to face and he's
so experienced a phenomenal performance
by him as vidit looks around yeah and
there was the resignation
um
forfeited a very very tough game he was
in the driver's seat but uh one
oversight and uh shacha of course sized
his chance immediately never looked back
and we'll come back we'll also i'm sure
hear from shakia but i think we should
go back to magnus carlsen as a vidit um
he is clearly
in shock and
just ran out of the playing hall but i
think we we understand um
oh we completely understand yeah
and uh that's yeah
and uh a big result of course and that
leaves us with three remaining games one
of them of course is caruana's game
against carlson by the way fabiano is
still thinking after queen for he is
down to seven minutes oh my god for well
over ten moves oh my lance
so as you say seven minutes and um
what do we do as white um
wait uh fiona if i may
i feel like there's a massive moment in
duda against van forest if i'm not
mistaken can we just go to that one
really fast because we haven't updated
you in a while and the position has
uh has heated up tremendously we might
have a result here soon
now objectively it's still a draw but
jan uh kristoff has to be really really
careful
so just in the interest of time we won't
go through what happened earlier we'll
just get to the present position
jordan has just played g4 intercepting
the bishop and uh hitting the rook with
the queen now the rook has two squares
it's got e3 and e1 if duda goes to e3
then he loses the game on the spot and
the reason is queen f1
you got to go back with your queen and
now the rook actually queen takes h3 is
checkmate followed by rook d one so jana
kristoff has to go rookie one that is
crucial
and after queen d2
he has to go rook f1 the queen can keep
pursuing the rook with queen each
now fiona it appears that only one move
saves the game for white and that is
queen e8 essentially setting up a
perpetual check with binge six not the
easiest move to find but judah has
plenty of time on his plug so he should
be able to uncover this and the king is
unable to escape the perpetual queen
takes f6 rook g7 queen takes h6 and the
likeliest draw
is uh rook h7 queen f6 jack if you go to
ga you give up your bishop with check so
we'll see if duda can find all of this
but he's dania let's quickly go to an
interview with shakira media
shakira mama jarov which is beat fitted
with the black pieces um sex sack and no
mate
okay it was uh good great game and
i think
i played very strange move d5 in the
opening it looks okay but
uh it was maybe some
it was surprised for my opening
and after we played good game and he'll
um he sing too much after my move d5
about 45 meals 50 minutes
and after the middle games
it looks so
very strange i think it was better for
me but i start to play very long i mean
it's ideal knight a5 c6 bishop c7 b6
i played very
strange moves
uh
okay i mean
finally he misses just f5
i don't know inside queen g4 is looks
bishop f4 maybe
i think still black is okay maybe it's
better i don't know i was happy with my
position
um
he just missed queen g4 f5 it's very sad
but he just missed
um so phil was playing his feathered
shirt it says
did you notice that no no i think it was
his own merch merchandise
um
i think you play a very good tournament
here but it's a long small game no
more games yeah yeah it is
it can change everything i mean when
you play
you know every time you remember it's
last game last
game and for this reason tomorrow is one
more important game and against caruana
okay we will see i think till now till
after the move after round 12 i am happy
with my results
and
i am in group leaders i think i am
shared second place we will see you
i wish you all the best
he got a big win against vidit but he is
not ready to rate his tournament
performance just yet as there is one
last round coming up he said himself he
is playing fabi so that will be a big
game but he is currently indeed
tied at the top
in the live standings even tied for
first but magnus
looking to get a head start and here um
dania we could be seeing the straw after
work f1 do you think we're gonna go down
this line
well jordan could also repeat moves by
the way uh black could go queen up back
to d3
which essentially forces white to go
back to e1 because if rook g1 happens
jordan can simply take the pawn on e4
and he stabilizes the situation with an
extra pawn so this game could end in a
draw in several ways i think this is
going to be our next result um i have a
feeling that one way or another we're
gonna see a draw in this game
i agree um let's go back to magnus
carlsen uh he is playing on the black
side against fabiano remember if he wins
that's it he wraps up the tournament no
not if he went sorry if he draws he only
needs a draw to
to win the tournament with a round to
spare but daniel he is going for the win
he is and fabi is down to three and a
half minutes and he has played the move
queen before
now
magnus with a big choice now he can take
on e5 here and it's clear that black is
better here but there is an alternative
and magnus doesn't have to rush with
that move he can also play rook a8 and
try to send this apon down the board
before fabi can even blink
uh both of these moves are enticing i
feel like magnus is going to take on e5
that seems to be the less risky option
but in considering fabby's time pressure
i think rook a8 also makes a great deal
of sense this is
extremely concerning for fabiano who's
got three minutes for over 10 moves and
a bad position where he has to watch all
areas of the board because the
the problems could come
really in the center they could come on
the queen side if magnus keeps pushing
his pawn and the king's side is none too
safe for white either
absolutely dania and
fabiano trouble is brewing as magnus he
is thinking which move to go for we're
going to take a very final quick
break before the first time control
which is coming up in just half an hour
so don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round 12 here
at the tata steel chess tournament where
results have started coming in i will go
there in a second and see how it
happened but anisha's gear and your
scariest game against nils gwendeluz has
ended in a draw we had two decisive
results elsewhere sam beating karjakin
in an impressive fashion and mama bier
of punishing a blunder by
vidit
dania before or maybe we can update uh
what happened in the anish game
when there's a lull or is
i think let's start with magnus maybe
or okay let's start well magnus is still
thinking in the position we okay we
checked so so very very quickly without
any uh
we'll just take 30 seconds so anish lost
control of the game
uh after he dropped the bishop back
neil's going g4 a very interesting idea
very risky 91 e6
uh anish uh occupying the f4 square and
after knight f6
uh rook a7 neil's going rook c4
activating his rook
bishop f1 rook before this is a critical
moment and here niels made our gary made
a big mistake to play queen c6
apparently he had to go rook d to a1
fiona and threaten to go rook a very
very dangerous
very dangerous situation here for for
black
however
uh
geary going queen back to c6 and after
94 all of a sudden it turns out the
plaque has all this piece activity and
anish occup
accompanied the move93 with a draw offer
which was accepted it looks like after
rook c4 queen b5 bishop takes d4 black
is better but the position is
tremendously complex and with seven
minutes on the clock you can't really
blame niels for declining uh for not
declining that draw yeah for sure this
position it is easy to be sitting at
home see the engine evaluation in the
end there was some bishop h6
possibilities so it makes sense for
niels who had such a rough start to his
event and then he recuperated to accept
a draw here he was under pressure for
most of
of the game so that ended peacefully
leaving us with only two games and uh
well one of them of course is where the
tournament might be decided uh right
here right now let's go back to fabiano
carrana against magnus magnus indeed um
still thinking still thinking still
thinking he's down to 13 minutes himself
and we might see a pretty scintillating
time scramble uh in this game if magnus
takes another five six minutes on this
move he is of course again deciding does
he want to take the pawn on e5 and get
two pawns for the exchange or
does he want to keep the tension in one
of several ways we mentioned rook a8
there is also the move h5
trying to run the h pawn down the board
and create
further massive weaknesses on white's
king side so a lot of enticing options
and fabi senses that if he plays
accurately here
uh he's going to have tremendous winning
chances without question
for sure i wouldn't be surprised i
wouldn't be surprised if he doesn't take
on e5 and tries to to keep
uh the pressure on in some way they i
saw a question in the chat what if
magnus loses even in case he loses they
will be tied at the top himself uh
rapport and mamedyarov and that would
mean that both mahmoud and
shah would still have to win tomorrow to
to tie with magnus since he's going to
get a free point
so
even if he loses he is guaranteed at
least a place in the player
yeah and the way that this game is
looking he's got more time he's
completely in control of the game look
at that monster i mean the bishop on c6
is a total monster
uh defending everything a4 b7 is totally
unassailable
and i just i don't see him losing this
game at all although of course as we
know by now everything is possible
yeah he really has been spending a lot
of time here this must be a crucial
decision in his book he hasn't taken on
e5 it's also not been h5 what was it f
e6
okay
that's uh
you know one of the possible ways to
essentially keep the tension and i think
it's a very good practical decision
because with three and a half minutes
fabby
you know fabi has to be careful because
it is possible to make to do further
damage to the position per white so i'm
curious to see
uh how fabi is going to handle this the
point of v6 is that it prevents white
from going e6 in certain positions and
essentially opening up the bishop it it
entombs the bishop on d4 and i think it
signals that magnus is not interested in
taking this pawn he wants to keep his
dark square bishop and i think his main
idea is to go rook a8 and push that a
pawn as far as it will go
and now well now the ball is in
fabiano's court and danya how do you
decide here on do you just have to stay
passive is there anything active you can
do
very little i mean
i don't even see a a attempting move for
white it's just nothing everything is
stuck in molasses i mean you can try to
bring your bishop back to c3 maybe
but but then magnus is going to trade
queens now we already talked about this
these end games although white is up in
exchange uh that doesn't matter white's
position collapses completely i mean if
you go rook c4 this is a case in point
you lose another pawn and if you lose
this pawn you essentially lose the game
so now fabi he's taking already another
minute fiona he's down to two and a half
minutes
oh my goodness and as you are saying
it's just it's such a tough spot for
only one move 29 11 moves still to go
but yeah every turn fabiano is going to
have to think what next and he has gone
bishop c3 offering this queen trade
yeah well i think magnus is taking it
and going bishop fan he's running with
that now the issue of course is fabi
can't really take on before with the
bishop because he drops e5 and again
he'll take on before with the rook
bishop by f8 will happen
and it looks like bishop d4 is forced
but look at how tied down light is every
piece is doing nothing and now magnus
swings his rook to a8 closes his eyes
and just sends this pawn all the way
down a2 where it can be anchored uh by a
bishop on d5 black is completely not
risking in this end game um and this is
right up magnus's alley i think we're
going to see a queen trade and i have a
feeling that fabi won't be able to hold
this together
with this amount of time in such a dire
position
and what a statement that would be from
the world champion he came to the
tournament and we see he there him there
returning to the board he mentioned in
an interview not long ago his next big
goal is 2900 rating in classical chess
this tournament here he's
had a very solid showing but i think in
the books of magnus carlsen he would
have wanted even more but today with
that win against uh fabiano if he can
get it it's still a
a while away that would really be be
setting um
setting the tone and making a statement
for sure and i'll just mention that in
this position yeah magnus has a second
option which is to give a check on e3
and then to revert back to bishop takes
c5 which he could have done before but i
feel like since magnus played e6 he's
kind of signaled that this is not the
type of position he's too interested in
and i think he's taken the queen he has
indeed he has and we will see rook takes
before bishop f8 i'm almost certain of
it
and this is big big trouble here for
fabi who
is contemplating to take with the bishop
and maybe
he's saying that it's worth giving up
the e5 at least he'll prevent the apon
from moving forward but i don't think it
is i feel like if you give up another
pawn then black is going to be ahead in
material and
it's all ugly it's all bad
you just got to choose the lesser evil
here if you're fabby yeah and fabiano we
can see that there is trouble
from his body language he has
quite a good poker face but i think
dania well you know him quite well we
can tell that he's under tremendous
pressure here
yep yep and now he's down below
two minutes still 10 moves left to play
in this incredibly difficult end game
and this is just a model positional game
so far this shows
uh how powerful these exchange
sacrifices can be and that's part of the
magic of chess that in any given
position a minor piece could and often
is
stronger than an entire rook
and fabiano is still thinking i'd be
really shocked if he ends up taking with
the bishop but the longer he thinks do
you think the more likely it becomes
yeah it becomes more likely and he's
definitely contemplating it very very
seriously but he's having a hard time
deciding as he hits a minute on the
clock there he goes yeah he's taken with
the bishop i believe yes he has
and magnus now probably not gonna spend
too much time he has already captured
on e5
and we i think you just said it a minute
ago this position is really um absolute
magnus dreamland
it really is i mean this is you cannot
think of a worse position to have
against the world champion
bishop a3 another question uh how do we
make progress here as black
well there's a couple of things first of
all magnus could push that h pawn and i
at some point would play h5 h4 maybe
even here
why because if you can get white to play
h3 then presumably white would have to
do that because you can't really allow
black spawn to get to h3 then f3 topples
over then look at that g3 square that
could be occupied by black's bishop
and not only is the bishop very well
placed but
anytime in the future that black's rook
gets active you're gonna have to uh
contend with possibilities of background
checkmate so i'm anticipating h5 here
magnus could also bring his king up to
g7 he can play rook a8 so he's got a lot
of small ways to improve his position
he's not going to win this game in the
next five moves
but uh he might win it in the next 20.
for sure and we see there magnus and
behind him you're inventories those are
the only two games that remaining here
sits at quite early doors you can see
the the local time there in the
background 17 40s so we're not even
haven't even reached the first
time control uh you're then shall we
bring up the bird's eye view for one
second maybe we don't have to go to his
game we were expecting a repetition and
are we going down
not exactly this but the white queen has
found a way to yate
yeah well i think it's a very similar
line after bishop takes f1 i think we
are going to see a repetition of moves
with queen g6 and queen back to e8
jordan is thinking but he's got no
choice
uh but to take white stroke and that is
essentially a draw for that game is
going to end probably within the next
two three minutes whenever jordan
decides to take on f1 very considerate
as we can go back to fabiano against
magnus very considerate of the other
players
to all end their games and just leave
the stage to to fabiano and magnus
absolutely and uh
i'll confirm here with the engine but
yes bishop takes f1
in jordan's game leads to an immediate
drop by repetition i'm just showing that
on the small board king h8 and if you're
you know white can do this in a bunch of
different ways you could take the pawn
and then go queen e64
for the sake of simplicity dude is
probably just going to go queen eight
check
yes so we'll probably see a handshake
there momentarily
for now let's go back to fabiano and
magnus and where magnus is still
thinking after bishop a3
and magnus is another idea if you notice
he can push the f and e pawns forward
and try to create another pass pawn
along the e file
and he can do that by dropping this
bishop away from e5 or playing the
immediate f5 so a lot of enticing
options
i think bishop f6
kind of a flexible move for now it's
hard to say what it is exactly he's
planning
but again it's so important to emphasize
that in these positions there is no big
hurry and the engine recommendation
should be taken with a grain of salt
because black isn't again black is not
trying to win this game in two moves
black is trying to make a series of
improvements
uh eventually aimed at kind of crushing
the life out of white's pieces one way
or another
and fabiano
he's also got to make some moves
i think the main concern on his mind
right now will
be to make the time control without
giving up too much ground uh so bringing
the king makes
sense and magnus what do you think
bishop f6 was a weird move not really
showing us his intentions
how will he continue from here
well for it's possible that he wants to
push that e pun down the board e5 e4
uh but i my guess is that magnus is
eventually going to play h5h4 he's going
to throw this in or even just h5
um i think part of the reason he played
bishop f6 is actually to cover the d8
square why is that important because
white did have the idea of doubling
rooks on the d-file and potentially
initiating a trait of rook so magnus
eliminating that possibility
uh and putting himself in a position
where now he can decide on a further
course of action but i'm also a little
puzzled bishop f6 is a slightly weird
move for sure
and we see magnus there looking very
calm and collected he senses
uh that if he
can play at his level if he can play
enormous normal magnus level this
should probably be a winning position so
he'll be looking to keep his cool for
those of you wondering which move are we
at we'll move 33 so magnus just bringing
the bishop brown further to e7 so seven
moves to make for each player
yeah and uh this keeps i mean this opens
up his options truly i mean now he can
go e5 and f5
uh he's x-raying the bishop on a3
immobilizing him the bishop on a3 is now
kind of tied down
uh to that square and uh this is typical
magnus i mean he's not in any kind of
rush
uh he's perhaps even going to make seven
more moves just to kind of test fabi a
little bit then once mu 40 is reached
and he has that extra time
perhaps only then will he actually
embark on
a substantive plan
as we see fabiano play the move rook to
b6
but i guess there are never
really any threats i was wondering is
there any moment where we can give back
the exchange and try and win the pawn on
a4
yeah i mean rook d4 as a follow-up could
be an option but at a moment's notice
black can play rook a8 and eliminate
that possibility so um and i think this
is part of the reason magnus has
positioned his bishop where he did
this pressure on c5 is so powerful that
it essentially eliminates the
possibility of white uh
counter-sacrificing and there's rook c8
magnus sort of moving around poking and
prodding
let's see what fabby does will he play
king e3
not even easy for white to make a move
here yeah pretty funny but it's not i
mean maybe bishop d5
is a serious idea it's possible that
magnus is aiming at the c5 pawn or maybe
he just wants to take it maybe he wants
to win that pawn
which which makes a lot of sense i mean
if you i've heard of dumber ideas
exactly
and i mean now that you've highlighted
this there's nothing wright can really
do about that or is there
well i can put the rook on c1 so it's
you know in response to bishop d5 but
that's incredibly passive and magnus
could combine that
with uh sort of the march of the
kingside pawns with the ultimate aim of
course of creating either a past pawn or
inducing further weaknesses in white's
territory fabio with six more moves to
play wow he's got a minute on the clock
oh my goodness one minute for fabiano
still six moves to make
the position might just be objectively
lost but
uh what a tough spot for him as you were
saying not even not easy to even find a
move and in the background they are
still playing but i think we're about to
see a handshake there between duda and
van for race as we see the queen come to
to g6
from d6 to e8 it goes black's king
toggling between h g7 and h8 we will see
a handshake right about now and that
will set the stage for just one more
game remaining what
this couldn't have the cards couldn't
have fallen
uh in any way more fitting than the way
they have
really who scripted this
right so well probably bigfoot's doing
oh it always is you know he's always
behind it he's the master he's the
nefarious mastermind of this he's the
villain
and well
we see that magnus is the one thinking
now after fabiano's move rook d2 while
in the background we're still waiting
for the handshake shouldn't be too far
off
and then this is where the tournament
very likely will be decided soon thank
you
yeah and rook d2 is kind of a neutral
waiting move fabby waiting for magnus to
demonstrate
uh what his approach is i keep thinking
that magnus is going to push a kingside
pawn i feel like that's so enticing h5
g5 maybe
but maybe magnus views this as a little
bit too committal uh he doesn't have a
ton of time himself of course
and due to going queen e8 check
and a handshake
with a draw in judah's game against van
forest dude definitely not the kind of
event that he had envisioned in jordan
when forest holding duda like this i
mean effortlessly or so it seemed out of
the opening
great stuff by jordan ben forrest
absolutely and yeah we see dude i'm not
looking too pleased with himself not
been his event but his main focus of the
year of course will be at the candidates
tournament still run round to go for
these players but for now everything is
finished dania except for the little
matter of karana against carlson which
unless magnus loses
magnus will be the tournament winner at
the end of this game
i think if the position were a little
bit more double-edged magnus would
probably offer a draw
uh he is obviously aware of how the
rapport game finished i mean he's gotten
up uh since that game had finished but
i think his his logic here is that he's
completely risk-free i mean there's
really no way i can see black losing
this
um and you know magnus is not somebody
who shies away from trying to convert
winning end games he converts equal end
games so
uh he's gonna try to convert this one as
well he's down to five minutes himself
though yeah and well let's have a look
what if he removes the bishop from c6
and attacks the pawn uh on c5
well um
that wouldn't would entail the move
bishop d5 and i i think fabi can drop
the rook back to back to b5 and this is
a pretty safe defensive construction
because remember you can never move the
bishop away from the long diagonal you
don't want to give up that pawn
and there is no other way to chase the
rook away other than to go back to c6
and close down the file for the for the
c8 rook so i think fabian's
uh you know this is not one of the the
biggest most pressuring is pressing
issues that fabia has to worry about but
in the long run uh it's one of many
things that fabia has to keep track of
magnus finally pushing a king side pawn
going f6 this is a clear indication that
he's going to bring the king up to f7
and he's going to push that e pawn and
start expanding in the center and on the
king side with the ultimate aim of
creating a second pass pawn
can white somehow try and use his own
kingside pawns to at least
try and create some weaknesses in black
cam in black's campbell does white just
have to wait passively in f4 there he
goes well f4 yeah he he goes for it and
fabi will not go gentle into that good
night
the problem fiona is that this actually
helps black create a past pawn now i'm
not sure whether magnus wants to play e5
here a very magnus move here would be to
play king f7 maybe even h6 and g5 just
to chip further away at white's king
side structure i feel like magnus is
going to go king f7 here that's just
a move in his style maximally uh
torturing fabi here forcing him to
continually find uh these semi waiting
moves
yeah and reminder of the the move number
this was move 36 for so for fabiano four
moves to make four magnets
five moves and just under five minutes
on the clock
yeah uh king f7 h6 or the immediate e5
are all options that fabi uh that magnus
can consider here the plus of going e5
is that fabi still hasn't made the time
control and this poses very concrete
problems and forces white into a
specific decision you know does white
take on e5 does white support the pawn
with g3
so i think both options make sense black
can stay flexible or
uh he can go for e5 straight away let's
see what magnus decides what do you
think it's gonna be
i think it's gonna be king f7 but
probably he's going to hear me say that
and then go e5
and then if i had said e5 he would have
changed his mind and gunking f7 yeah i
think if magnus had very little time on
the clock if it was a bullet game i
think king f7 would already have been
played
but yeah as you mentioned with fabiano
under a minute e5 wow
oh i i see i actually predicted it i
said he would hear me saying f7 and then
he would play e5
so that's exactly what i said actually
i'm correct i think you're correct
technically yes
so e5 is on the board
how is fabiano going to react
rookie 2 is an interesting move for
pinning the bishop and then potentially
after bishop d8 white could actually
leave the rook on b6
uh and trade on e5 getting an opposite
colored bishop position where black is
only up one pawn so
that's one possible defense the other
question for fabian is does he take on
e5 as he gets down to 20 seconds taking
on e5 fiona opens up the app file and
it's not out of the question that the
king gets subjected to an endgame attack
i think he's taking the pawn captured
magnus immediately recapturing
and that white king as you're just
saying as suddenly with the black
bishops both coming to life
bishop can come to g5 rookie two by fabi
and i guess e4 will be played just
throwing a chuck on f8 first
yeah if you throw in a check on f8 where
do you think the white king should go
towards the center
well before i talk about that if magnus
plays e4 here fabi has a really
interesting possibility and again you
call the sacking back the exchange
and this time
you're going to collect the pawn on a4
so you're going to get this end game
which is probably like a 50 50 mm i
really don't know how to evaluate it but
magnus might not want to allow this
amount of simplification
and if he doesn't want to allow it then
he has to find a different way of
defending that pawn and there is a
different way you could go rook f8 check
and then rook f5
you could also throw in bishop h4 check
on top of that in order to induce the
weakening move g3 let's see what magnus
chooses here he has so many uh enticing
options for him to choose from he still
has three minutes 40 and three moves to
go and he has just thrown in that check
on f8
yes he has
showing the ball back to into fabiano's
court
indeed
baby
has to decide where to go with this king
king e1 i think is what we're going to
see king g1
would kind of enter a self-made prison
the king wants to stay toward the center
and i think he has gone king e1 indeed
one more move to be made for fabi two
more for magnus until time control is
reached
and then we have yeah rook f5 defending
the pawn on e5
and this is now fabiano's last move so
this was move 39 one move to make for
each player fabiano has one minute to
consider
what his last move will be
indeed and magnus's next last move is
probably going to be e4 fiona and that's
why the rook on f5 is so well placed it
may seem like it's just tied down to the
pawn but no after e4 the rook is going
to pressure that c5 pawn from the side
which is the perfect spot to do it from
i i mean this is just such a difficult
position to defend for move after move
30 seconds for fabi to make the last
time control move here and from the
moment magnus sacrificed the exchange he
has just been
playing some clinically clean chess and
i think yeah whether it was overlooked
by fabiano are underestimated
but as soon as magnus was presented with
this chance he pounds and he is very
very close here and not just to winning
this game but also the 2022 tata steel
chess tournament
indeed and baby just in time three
seconds on the clock
playing rook back to b1
okay and that's the time control move
now i'm anticipating e4 here by magnus
e4 attacking the pawn on c5 how would
white defend
well i mean i would imagine rook c1
this isn't exactly the image of
perfection
or uh pleasure that anybody had
when fabi started this game and magnus
could casually walk his king up toward
the center and you know fiona the
problem here is just look at the amount
of past pawns they're both perfectly
protected by this bishop
i just don't see fabi surviving this for
more than another 10 moves i mean one
way or another black is going to keep
expanding magnus is going to find a way
to push this pawn to e3 and ultimately
white's resources are going to be
exhausted white is too tied down he's
too passive and he has absolutely no
counter play and no targets
i think we're going to see e4 within 30
seconds from magnus
yeah i this time i'll take the other
side of the bat i think magnus has three
and a half minutes on the clock for the
last move i think he'll invest a little
bit
a little bit more than that so i'll say
he'll take at least two minutes
15 more seconds
yeah you know you want to
you know you want that extra three
minutes because 53 minutes is completely
different than 50 minutes you're right
yeah
magnus taking his sweet time he doesn't
seem to be ready
just yet
uh i agree with you that i think ifo
will appear but i think he will be down
to around a minute when when it does
come
no that's completely reasonable take
yeah
and we see that magnus now is all alone
in the playing hall for him remember uh
this is his last game of the event since
tomorrow he'll get a walk over
a point
against daniel dubos so those are his
last
last moments or last hours i don't know
how long this will go in this playing
hall
yeah it really depends on you know how
how the game continues how long can fabi
withstand
this devastating
situation
and uh magnus just
so patient as always so accurate doesn't
matter what kind of position he's played
an excellent game and for fabiano fiona
he might be losing his third
game with the white pieces in the same
tournament and i don't know if he's
probably has not ever had that since he
became 2700 that would be my hypothesis
that's crazy that really is crazy i mean
fabiano not just one of the best players
in the world but also
one of the most solid like it's really
unheard of
that he loses so many games at all but
especially with with the white pieces
yeah and has he even lost the game of
the black pieces i don't think he's lost
any games with black
and you were right on the money he
played e4 with a minute and a half on
the clock
and uh 50 minutes have been added to
both players clocks
a deep breath can be can be taken but
not really by fabi he can't really
breathe here
and yeah fabiano he's ruins one he's
lost those two white games previously
and all his
wins uh have come with the black pieces
crazy and
dania now that the time control has been
reached i think we can take a quick
breather we'll go on a on a short break
and then i will return in a couple of
minutes with the conclusion of this
karana carlsen game so we'll see you
then
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i was watching this tournament when i
was a kid
when i wasn't a strong player and i was
just watching all the best players in
the world come here and
i remember the first time i played here
back then it was there were three groups
along with the open section and i was
playing in the c group that was in 2008
but i was already watching this
tournament many years before that
usually there's there's a huge amount of
people
who love to to play and to watch chess
here uh now it's of course a bit
different times have changed a bit
but hopefully uh someday we'll go back
to that
yeah i grew up analyzing with the board
but things are very different now most
of the analysis is done on on the
computer but still it's nice to go back
to that sometimes and i think it's also
useful to
analyze over the board because
um it helps your understanding of the
position
even if you have the best analysis in
the world it might not help you
over the board if you're not if you
don't fully understand exactly what's
going on and it also helps your
memorization
if you see it over the board rather than
seeing it on the computer so i think
it's still very helpful to
to work over the board so it's also up
to the
the guys who are you know who have been
there a bit longer to to adapt uh
because all the younger players are
improving so quickly
uh yeah my goal is to is to win the
tournament
hello and welcome back to round 12 here
at the tata steel jazz tournament as
the last remaining game of this masters
section dania is very likely to give us
our tournament winner
lots of weird stuff uh indeed elsewhere
yes a panko against report ended
peacefully if anything yesterpanko he
was the one in control
anish might also be
regretting some mischances but if
anything in the end it was nils who who
had the chance to play on and then uh
duda against uh van fer race is an
interesting battle between two very
fighting players but ending in a draw
eventually and for magnus if you're just
tuning in
and now
i can't hear danya is muted yeah well
i'm not muted on my end
vic
no you weren't otherwise i couldn't have
heard you it's all good it's all good
now you're good now
yeah i think they kind of right
yep i think i'm fine now apologies for
that
um but i was just saying that there were
two pretty incredible things that
happened today sam's win over karjakin
and viditz blunder against chakrayar
you can tell that the tournament is
daring its conclusion fatigue is playing
a role
and uh
really an incredible game today by
salmon and magnus actually responded
very very quickly
uh to fabiano's rook c1 with the check
on h4 fiona the idea is very simple he
wants fabi to go g3 which he is and the
move g3 creates a massive hole on the f3
square that can be occupied by the rook
it's very clear that magnus is making
very quick and efficient strides toward
pushing fabi off the board here
and you were just saying during the
break i mean we wouldn't be shocked if
fabiano just resigned soon he knows
magnus probably better
as a chess player than than anyone else
in this field
and he is not going to to need magnus to
show him how it's all done i don't think
he'll resign immediately but
magnus
very clearly uh he's taking very big
steps towards wrapping up his tournament
and style
yeah it really depends you know on how
he feels but he knows how this game is
going to end and just to show what could
happen in the event that fabie goes g3
magnus is going to swing the bishop all
the way back to d8 where it can reroute
to a5 that's going to be another
potentially devastating check and as i
mentioned the rook is coming into f3 the
pawn could then advance to e3 and it's
just one of those things where the
threats are coming from all different
sides of the board and we haven't even
talked about the role of the a pawn
which can also move forward in case the
bishop
uh moves on to b4 to cover the check on
a5 too many threats white is too passive
and uh
you know it's just difficult to hold out
for more than a couple of moves here for
sure and dania just before we come back
to this game very quickly
there has been some some news on around
circulating on social media with uh
daniel dubov
so here is the official statement from
the tata steel chess account daniel
duboff tested positive for covet 19 on
thursday a second test requested by
duboff himself showed a negative result
the dutch health authorities stipulated
in these circumstances the positive test
result stands and supersedes adding a
negative outcome
so i know there's been a lot of
speculation on social media but it uh
for sure daniel uh not daniel daniel
will not be returning uh today
by the way tomorrow huh he does go by
dania by the way that's that's just
basically like danny and russian so in
russian broadcast they call him danya
yeah so
dania well one dania will be returning
tomorrow at least so i hope the other
one
i hope so too
and magnus actually not going bishop d8
i was wrong
but going bishop g5
hitting the rook
so bishop g5 and uh well what what could
be the idea here and also first of all
where does the white rook go
i think i see a beautiful idea if if
fabby goes rook c3 the other bishop
comes out to b5 and if fabi covers this
with rook f2 the fastest win is a
brilliant check on d2 what a tactic wow
and after rook takes ctv you got
checkmated and if you take with the king
you drop the rook on f2 and everything
else collapses
oh there's a filigree precision now it
appears that fabian has to go rook c4
and that's the only way to stay
walk into the skewer voluntarily but if
if you get skewered then after rook c
takes c4 i don't actually think magnus
is going to go for this because
if you just you know kind of mindlessly
grab the material then you're going to
lose the pawn on a4 and all of a sudden
this is a draw
so
rook c4 is an excellent practical chance
i mean it has to be played by fab your
rook c3 loses on the spot to bishop b5 i
think fabi recognizes that and i think
he's going to find it
the rook c4 is that
uh i guess it's the only move we have to
stay on the c file
yeah and the thing is if uh black plays
e3 which my guess is that magnus will
play
um i thought that fabi's idea might be
to play h4 but the bishop could just
drop back to h6 and if you try to go g4
uh in order to shut the bishop out with
g5 the rook slides over to f3 just in
time
and takes the sting out of the move g5
now the bishop can just move back to g7
and the rook uh maneuvers to the first
rank decisively and let's not forget
that bishop b5 still is a devastating
threat so this doesn't save white but
it definitely prolongs the game the best
chance as fabiano now plenty of time
on the clock rook c4 not an easy move to
to make for starters especially not when
you understand that
it still probably isn't enough but
fabiano will try his best of course to
make all the moves uh that at least keep
keeper fighting a fighting chance
indeed
he is down to 40 minutes you can see how
dejected he is this is just not a game
that he
well there is no game that you are
planning to lose but
the third loss of the white pieces is
just a massive blow
as the tournament comes to an end a
forgettable event for sure
for fabiano and i'm curious when was
magnus's last
classical win these two have played so
many so many draws especially with the
black pieces i'd be very very curious
maybe i'll look it up we're hoping if
magnus doesn't lose which at this point
looks very unlikely uh we'll hopefully
have him here in the studio with us
so i'll look up some of these stats and
um
yeah we're looking forward to to having
magnus but he's not thinking about those
incoming interviews he is focused on one
thing and one thing only uh as fabiano
by the way has played rook b1 while i
was rambling
yeah rook b1 uh is well it's a possible
move you're stopping bishop b5 uh the
what this allows though is rook f3 and i
think rook f3 is going to be devastating
uh and okay this attacks the bishop
fabi will probably move the bishop back
to c1 now magnus can go e3 here that's
winning another winning move is to slide
the bishop back to e7 and hit it hit the
pawn on on uh c5 and after bishop e3
well there's many things that black can
do a3 is a possibility you could now
play bishop f6 in order to cover the a1
square so that a3 comes with even
greater effect just look at how tied
down white is i mean every single piece
is completely
you know tied down and for example after
king d2 a3 the pawn is simply
unstoppable white's probably going to
lose the bishop i i'm anticipating rook
f3 by magnus tightening the screws
as he inexorably moves closer and closer
to victory
and i i see a question in the chat
it's gone now but
the question was where did fabiano uh go
wrong in this game and what do you think
tanya
uh well clearly the i think the decisive
mistake was to allow that exchange
sacrifice maybe not totally decisive
it's entirely possible that he could
have defended more resiliently there but
from a practical standpoint
uh
that
you know put him in a position which was
incredibly difficult to defend
i feel like uh where he started to go
wrong was when he combined
the moves rook c1 and knight d2 i felt
like he should have done one or the
other either knight d2 or rook c1 and
magnus sorry danny i'll let you continue
but he's played rook f3
yeah indeed and and i i was almost done
i was just going to say that uh had
fabby gone rook c1 remember i showed
that repetition with queen e2 and then
queen back to a6 i think it's quite
likely that that's how the game would
have
would have concluded and you know fabi's
to be kicking himself for that as he
goes
bishop c1 indeed
yep and we're expecting bishop e7 or
even
bishop f6 is another possibility here
straight away
i mean it really doesn't matter
everything is winning yeah we see magnus
about to make a quick move bishop f6 is
what he's decided on
yep
hip-hop six and he is basically ready
to push one pawn maybe even both of
these pawns and this bishop from c6
could reposition to d5 and look at how
the bishops slice through white's
position covering both of the pawns
subsequent squares all three of them
actually the rook covering a3 and the
bishops team up to cover eight three uh
a2 and a1 never has a pawn gotten such
amazing treatment from all of the pieces
and this is all over
and i mean it's just when you watch
magnus at his best and i think today
really was a tremendous effort by by him
uh the way he uses his pieces uh i mean
it's just a sight to behold
it really is and you know just like a
legend on the soccer field such as messi
makes it seem that one team has more
than 11 players on the field it always
seems like magnus has
more pieces than his opponent even when
he's down in material technically even
after he sacked the exchange
and that's just a product of as you said
his confidence
and his wizardry with every piece on the
board and in every type of position
and fabiano he has that face of like i
don't know if it means resignation could
be close but
um
he knows yes
he's got the pre pre-resigned face
and yeah it's i mean as you said it's
really not been his tournament but
similarly to duda
his focus will be going towards later
this year when they will be playing in
the candidates tournament for fabi the
good news i don't know how superstitious
he is but uh that year he won the
candidate's tournament so convincingly
in 2018 he had actually come off a
a terrible performance in vikanze i
think he finished on 5 out of 13 or
something that year
so um for the superstitious ones aren't
they it might not be such a bad sign
yeah and i think fabi can definitely be
very very streaky
and you know in the last couple of
tournaments he's had i think a little
bit of trouble getting the kinds of
positions that he likes out of the
opening if you remember his sink field
cup performance an important component
of that was excellent opening
preparation and novelties and it just
seems like in this tournament in
particular
he was getting dragged into a lot of
unfamiliar territory and territory that
he doesn't necessarily
uh positions that he doesn't necessarily
prefer so
um as he continues to ponder
this position magnus you can see kind of
anticipating resignation
yeah not
going too far away from from the void
actually now you could almost like
you're sending a bit too close piling up
depression
well he's putting more pressure and he
is i think he is thinking just resign
already
um you know that's
kind of the vibe i'm getting but
you know fabi doing you got to admire
his patience fabi in a position where a
lot of people would just start playing
instantly doing his absolute best to dig
up resources unfortunately there are
none
yeah and it's really a situation where
maybe against other players even then
there wouldn't be much to hope for but
magnus in those spots he's so clinical
he knows it's over he's standing behind
the board he's ready
uh
to to call it the day remember he won't
be playing tomorrow
uh
where um he'll get a forfeit win against
duboff and he is about to be crowned the
2022 uh tata steel champion
a dominant wire to wire performance by
magnus who scored so many amazing games
i mean
you think about it he beat geary in that
cattle and that was the same tournament
he won so many sparkling games he beat
mamadiara if he won two catalan games as
sam shanklin uh referenced
uh and you know every one of his
tournaments is is
just exquisite i mean he plays
usually even players at this level they
might play one really masterful game per
tournament and magnus regularly plays
three or four games that could enter his
best games collection
and even here i'm not sure
it's been a long it's been a long
tournament daniel it has it has and even
magnus he's looking a little tight but
this is for him it really is the the
last moment he's not gonna have to show
up uh tomorrow all he'll have to do is
to show up in the evening and collect
what will be his eighth trophy
eight tata still chess trophy and uh
absolute murdering his record uh of most
wins here
that's crazy eight oh my goodness that
just tells you all you need to know and
someone wins stat of steel slash vicon
say eight times
you really don't need to share any other
statistics other than that one
absolutely true and as fabiano
uh he is still thinking but
there just isn't if we go back to the
game
um how do you even proceed as white how
do you try and fight against the apon
i mean i was contemplating briefly
bishop b2 but this loses on the spot to
rook b3 pinning b1 and then uh following
up with with a3
locking in the w there
and okay i mean bishop b3 is another
attempt to lock down the rook but
anything wins i mean a3 uh maybe a3 is
inaccurate due to rook b3 actually
uh and the one thing that black has to
be careful about in a position like this
is to allow
a an exchange sacrifice and an opposite
colored bishop end game
fabi going rook b6
that's a good move and he is eyeing the
possibility of taking on c6 and then
taking on e4 in certain situations that
could be
uh a very resilient attempt i like the
movement b6 i think that is definitely
the best move in the position
if you are black do you want to try and
avoid that and if so how do we defend
upon on
on iphone do we counter attack the the
pawn on c5 how do we meet uh how do we
meet this
yeah i mean there's there's multiple
possibilities here
uh the the
bishop d4 would be a mistake that's for
sure because then it walks right into
this idea and you basically have to give
up the a4 pawn
uh which is the worst thing that can
that black can do you could give a check
on c3
and after bishop d2
well the engine suggests the very
cold-blooded move king f7 just get the
king involved and white is so tied down
that he doesn't have any moves
uh the human approach i think is to go
a3 in this position and just keep
pushing and the problem is that white
will have to take on c3 in order for the
rook to
defend the a2 square and after rook
takes you through black collects yet
another pawn and once c5 falls it's
there's just too many pawns
so bishop c3 um
we're thinking likely the best move here
for magnus on the board
yeah likely bishop c3 check
um
what else can can we propose i mean
you could move the rook somewhere maybe
rook can slide on over to d3
and uh again i i wouldn't want to go for
i wouldn't even want to calculate this
option even though i'm sure in this
particular version black is winning
but and that's why i think i like bishop
c3 check because that essentially
disallows any rook 66 shenanigans
it seems to be funnily enough the only
move that disallows the the shenanigans
because what i had suggested of
defending the pawn on e4 is just not
possible there is no way
no way we can defend that
yeah um and i think magnus is going to
play it this is
you know what he does bishop c3 track of
course kane d1 is also a possibility
and now there's a really interesting
tactical idea e3
and if you play rook takes c3 it's
anticlimactic but very powerful black
just trades and goes a3 and promotes the
pawn total domination over the rook on
on v6
and
if white plays bishop takes c3
then here as well a3 is devastating
because there are made threats with
bishop a4 and rook f1 along with the
threat of promoting the pawn
so i'm anticipating bishop cchip c3 and
magnus
he looks like he's just double checking
it kind of looks like he's maybe made up
his mind already yes
he also doesn't have this intense
thinking person i think magnus knows
fabiano know both of them know the
position
is winning it's just a matter of uh
keeping your cool until the very end
especially here in this spot where there
could be
some tricks of giving the exchange back
on the horizon
but magnus i mean he has
so much experience so much time on the
clock
so i don't think he's gonna rush this
one
yeah the time control is massive in this
tournament 50 minutes is a huge addition
on move 40 and magnus has not spent
really almost any of it because of how
confident he is
in the technique and this is one of
those positions where
i mean it's easy to identify
all of the sources of counterplay
because there is just one
the only thing that could go wrong is
you allow rook take c6 and the only
other thing that could go wrong is you
can push this pawn prematurely so if you
go a3 here
uh that would be an example of the
second uh because you allow rook a2 and
all of a sudden you have a hard time
defending uh this pawn but obviously
magnus is just not going to do that
yeah and we see fabiano getting up for a
little stroll there's still i guess some
games going on in the challenger section
as magnus uh considering how he's going
to be putting the finishing touches on
this i expect bishop c3
quite soon
and
danya for him really i mean to beat
fabiano in a in a classical game with
the black pieces must be a an extra nice
feeling to to wrap up the tournament in
this way
yeah and don't quote me on this i mean
i'll look this up at some point but i
feel like after their world championship
match there was a
a swing in their results i i feel like
that fabian really had his number
you know around 2014 2015. fabi beat
magnus with black at the sink at that
famous sinkfield cup
um you know the immortal singfield cup
performance
and fabia has definitely defeated magnus
on other occasions as well but as of
late it just seems like magnus
he's absolutely unbeatable this
tournament you know it's you really do
see the difference between him and all
of the other players
i get asked this question a lot on my
stream you know what is it that really
separates magnus
uh from from other top players and that
question is impossible to answer in one
sentence obviously but i think that you
could just see it in his play you can
see it in his confidence and you can see
it in the way that he wins games he
makes it look easy he puts these people
to bed in 25 30 moves such as mamadiara
who else can do that nobody
nobody really and i mean also magnus's
pure will to win and his
determination and it's i think it's
something we talked about the other day
as well um i think he's been such a a
positive influence um in terms of
not just taking a draw when the position
looks uh equally and
do you also feel that way that he's
really had an effect not just on his
willingness to play on but on on other
top players
well i i i would be quoting vessel into
paulov i remember when i was
commentating
the world cup uh with with vessel and i
asked him this question i said well what
is your perspective
on how magnus has changed the game
and i asked this to vichy and i asked
this to vessel and they both said
exactly the same thing they said that
one of the
the clearest influences uh that magnus
has had is people have stopped offering
draws in
many different types of positions where
10 15 years ago
you know they would have shaken hands
and gone home a long time ago magnus has
shown that even in the driest looking
positions even situations that are equal
objectively there's plenty of life and
you can squeeze
uh many many points out of those
positions uh if you have the right skill
set and
now it's not just magnus who does that
even younger grand masters and even
players who are not at the very top i
think have uh
sort of inhabited that uh inherited
that spirit of resilience and and fight
in good positions and in bad positions
magnus has just proven what is possible
when you have this will to win as you
said yeah and magnus well many people
call him the goat already oh he's up
there for sure i think magnus himself
always a bit reluctant to
to talk about these topics is he the
greatest was it conspira was it fisher
was it someone else and i think
absolutely he's right in saying maybe we
can talk about that once my career is
over but it's very far from over with
magnus himself stating lately um stating
recently that his next goal is 2900 i'm
very quickly going to bring up what was
his rating so he was losing one rating
point
before today but uh if he can get the
win he will be walking away uh from what
vike with at least the small rating plus
which is saying a lot that he can
dominate a tournament like this and lube
is still essentially losing rating
uh but i just wanted to add that you
know every time magnus wins a tournament
like this he really silences
uh the the growing chorus of people who
seem to
to jump to conclusions every time he
doesn't win a tournament
uh and and he really shows that he's got
so much juice left in the tank he's got
many tournament victories ahead of him
and
anybody who claims that magnus is
somehow on the decline or experiencing a
slump of any kind
is uh is deluded uh magnus is in some
ways playing the best chess of his
career and he's proven that again this
tournament
absolutely and uh it's going to be
a stellar performance he went unbeaten
last year we all remembered he had that
one loss against ciazepanko
now i'm not sure that he had another but
that was the one that had stood out
but this year i mean in the early stages
he
was a bit slower than let's say vidit
who started with a few early wins uh
magnus had a quieter start but then he
turned up the turbo and then never
looked back
yeah and he is taking a pretty
significant think here
um
i was explaining i i thought he would
play bishop c3 a while ago
but
this is really the first moment in the
end game where he
he has to be precise and this is yet
another one of his infinitely many
uh great qualities he just senses
critical moments so well he knows when
to think and that's something that's not
often talked about it's not only what do
you think about you have to know when to
think and when to play quickly and we've
discussed it before he plays quickly
uh when he senses that the move is quite
obvious and that there is a good amount
of margin for error and then he has this
magical sense okay this critical moment
i need to take 20 minutes here and he
does and dania what would you say to the
viewers who are watching us
uh if they ask you for advice for how
can
uh how can we sense what is a critical
position when should we we invest more
clock time what would you say
a lot of it is being aware of of sources
of danger
and that doesn't just mean asking
yourself what the threat is because
technically in this position
white has no threat
now what do i mean by that well if you
play a move like king f7 which by the
way is the computer stop recommendation
rook takes c6 is not serious here
because after rook takes c4
uh there is this move rook b3 which is a
very powerful counter blur rook takes a4
rook b1 and the bishop is going to be
lost king b2 there's a special g5 check
but rook takes a6 a rook takes c6 is
nonetheless a source of danger and in a
different set of circumstances it's
actually a very strong defensive
resource so the moment magnus senses
that anything like that is on the
horizon he says okay i need to be very
precise i need to make sure that i'm
factoring this in
and uh you know he has that
very very acute sense of danger
where danger doesn't just mean danger of
being attacked or in danger of getting
checkmated but danger of in any way
losing the threat of the game or losing
the advantage
for sure and we see him there really
buckled down i had
his magnus is deep deep deep focused
there he
uh especially i think after the the
lesson from yesterday against vidit
maybe there was one move at d7 which was
played a little too quickly quite
uncharacteristic of magnus
so today he is definitely not going to
repeat that same mistake
it's the exception and maybe magnus a
little bit frustrated here that
in his eyes maybe he allowed rook b6 i
feel like
it might have been a little bit more
expeditious to go bishop e7
um and and this would have accelerated
the process just a tad forcing bishop b3
and then returning to f6 so that
you know white is saddled with yet
another
weakness and the rook doesn't isn't
making contact with e4 but yesterday is
the exception that proves the rule the
fact that we were
you know surprised
that magnus rushed d7
the reason we were surprised is because
it's so rare for him to
uh to commit such an error even in the
most complicated end games
and we see that fabiano he is just
walking around the playing hall there
waiting for magnus to make a move for
fabiano i mean you've got to be happy at
least
uh you you at least you have some kind
of threat some kind of hope that magnus
might go
wrong
here yeah you do and uh magnus has
already taken what 15 minutes or so
he is taking his sweet time that's
that's for sure he's not rushing his
decision
um
king f2 now that we've looked at this
position for a while lanier would would
you go for king f7 or bishop c3
well i'd go bishop c3 champ king f7 is
not an easy move and it's actually not
the easiest thing to correctly evaluate
this end game because if you play a3
which is really the human move that's a
mistake and the reason that's a mistake
is because after rook a4 it may seem
like bishop b2 is a winning move
but it's not bishop takes b2
a takes b2 and simply rook before picks
off the pawn
with excellent drawing chances it does
look like magnus about to make a move by
the way i'm keeping an eye on that
uh but
that's uh you know i mentioned
previously there's this move rook b3 but
man that's a difficult move to come up
with
i'm anticipating bishop c3 check
and magnus
is still thinking i don't know if now is
maybe a good time for us to take a quick
break uh while magnus makes up
his mind and we'll return to this in
just a few minutes so don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round 12 here
at the tata steel chess tournament where
danya magnus has finally made a move
yeah and it's neither bishop c3 check
northing f7 it is rook up to f5 hunting
for that pawn on c5 and
you know i have to emphasize that it's
one of those positions where there are
multiple possible moves as long as you
stay stay the course and he did rook
five is a completely viable option and
it preserves a completely winning
position because fabia is no good way to
defend the pawn
yeah i mean what other ways rook c2 is
one option
yeah there's three ways there's rook c2
there's bishop e3
um
and then there's bishop bishop a3
all of them are
viable bishop a3 blessed bishop a3
allows bishop d4 though
and and the pawn is lost so i think this
is the
the quickest uh demise bishop e3 i don't
think fabio is going to play
because it uh leaves the a pawn
unattended
although on the other hand a3 is not
necessary a3 could be hasty due to rook
b3 we've already talked about this trap
um and rook c2 is also possible i really
don't know which of the three moves he's
going to make it's going to be one of
the three but here again bishop d4 looks
incredibly strong
and it looks like he's about to make a
move yeah he was reaching out with the
hand none of the tree options
are particularly tempting but of course
as you said uh many moons ago as soon as
the
c5 pawn drops that's the end so he will
have to try and hold on to that
yeah and i would
i would say that i i
i could see him resigning here like it
wouldn't be shocking
but
i don't think that he and he plays
bishop a3 but i understand why he's
playing i mean there are tricks that
magnus has to avoid here so
i would really call it admirable that
that fabi continues to play as
objectively as he can yeah
so bishop a3 dealing with that pawn
for now what are the options now for
magnus
well uh bishop d4 is the obvious move
but once again
you have to reckon with rook takes c6
bc6 and rook takes c4 and there is a
winning move here and that move is
rookie five it forces the trade but this
has to be calculated because
white is heading for b4 and if you look
at this king f7
uh king d3 king e6 king c4 it may look
like white is holding on but in fact he
isn't black has several winning
approaches one is to just head for the
other side of the board the other
approach is to play king d5 king takes
a4 and just bishop d4 pick up the c5 the
rest is very very easy but he's going to
have to calculate that
and if we go all the way back after
bishop d4
fabi for that reason probably just has
to part ways with the c5 pawn and go
king d2 for instance
and the simplest approach is to take on
c5 and this is still not winning on the
spot i mean magnus is going to have to
work for it
and probably bring his king up and then
maybe go rook a5 and ultimately dislodge
the rook for b6 so this is still winning
but but some finesse is nonetheless
required even here yeah fabiano he is
going to make this as hard for magnus
as he can
magnus is still thinking other than
bishop
d4 there are the moves that might be
tempting for black
well the other move is the computer
always likes king f7 here this is a very
enginey way to play though just like not
not forcing anything just making an
improvement to the position
uh but i could totally see magnus doing
that uh because white is almost in zug's
long white just says no healthy moves
and again it's important to point out
this this idea of rookie five and i
think this is part of the reason that
magnus played rook f5 is to prevent
prevent the sacrifice on c6 so that he
doesn't have to worry about it at least
until fabulous king moves away from u1
yeah king f7 could be a magnus move
bishop d4 what is it going to be
magnus once again
investing some time here he's about to
to drop under
fabiano's time but he is not worried
about that at all as we see the the view
into the playing hall where just these
two
uh remain
how do you daniel how do you if you have
two candidate moves like king f7 and
bishop d4 how do you proceed from there
to decide which one to make
well you just need to try to evaluate
which uh which technically because you
probably know magnus knows that he's
going to be winning objectively after
both of these moves he realizes that
um but he has to decide which option
allows less counterplay
you know and which which option presents
the the clearest path forward and the
clearest way to make progress but every
player has a different way of converting
advantages
magnus is one of the best advantage
converter the best advantage in the
history of chess i think
and his approach is generally to err on
the side of making improving moves and
not forcing things until
he's improved his position to the
maximum that's why i say that king f7 is
a magnus type move
king f7 magnus looks like he's
getting close but i with him i find it
harder to read i feel there are some
players you think okay we know he's
about to make a move
and he is just
picking his lip for now the hand comes
down but i don't think it's gone to any
piece
yeah i agree i think
definitely with some players when they
like raise their hand up at all you just
know they're about to make a move with
magnus
he goes through so many different
positions thinking positions in every
move
uh that you just uh never know but if he
takes another 15 minutes i mean i i
think the last thing he wants to do is
get himself into into time pressure
yeah so we're what we're on with
46 magnus still 15 moves to make a final
reminder it's been a while so you're
probably all aware by now but one of the
longest time controls on the 200 minutes
for the first 40 moves 50 minutes for
the next
and and then finally on with 60 an extra
15 minutes for the rest of the game and
of course there's also a 30 second
increment removed from move one
yeah this is probably the longest time
control on the tour by far right
and especially that final 15 minutes i
mean that is just
i don't know
it's a long time control
it is indeed um but magnus well he might
be happy to to be getting um that extra
15 minutes although what do you think
dania most likely this will end before
move 60
i mean the way it's going
i don't know i i'm not expecting fabby
to resign until it's i think if fabi
wanted to resign he would have already
resigned it's sort of the decision okay
you know if he thought that magnus uh
if he wanted to resign he would have
done so on move 40 or 41 he has
basically decided to take the approach
of trying to play objectively best moves
and hoping for a miracle which is very
admirable in the way that one should
play
so i don't think he's resigning until
until one of several things happens
until like you get into a pawn end game
or a bishop end game that's completely
lost or until magnus finds a way to set
one of his pawns in motion and
you know until it's the domination has
reached
a clear moment when the one of the pawns
is promoting you're just highlighting
there one of the others what actually
happens if black goes back to f3 we're
just repeating well the rook just came
from there yeah repeating i mean fabi
has to go back to c1 so maybe magnus
will
maybe magnus will do that i mean it's
possible that magnus will will will not
particularly like anything in this
position and revert back to you know the
idea of bishop c3 check but i find that
to be
pretty unlikely given how much time he's
already invested
in that position and now in this
position he's again taking a very very
long thing and we see fabiano it's a
tough spot for tabia fabiano as well
because you know the game is lost and
you're just sitting there hoping you
will get a chance uh you know
especially when it's magnus most likely
you want
but fabiano he's not gonna let his
emotions get the better of him i mean
he's so impressive and that's how you
save games as well like you just have to
keep asking questions and fabiano is
trying his best he's finding the most
tricky resources and that's also why
magnus is investing that time because
fabian is not making it easy for him
no and that's the thing with miracles
you know you don't think that that's by
definition you don't think they're
possible until they happen
and and i think people sometimes forget
about that they think well it's quite
clear that magnus that fabi can't save
the game well every time you thought
that as magnus looked like king f7
if every time you thought that you
resigned well there would be no uh no
swindles in chess and king f7 has been
played
by by magnus just such a nasty move
and fabi kind of runs out of
helpful moves here he just has to go
probably bishop b4 uh just just a
winning move
is there anything set for to is there
anything to say for trying to bring the
king closer
yeah there is king d2 is possible um but
but now rook f3 is probably very strong
because
this move walks right into you know all
sorts of ideas and if you
try to repeat the position now a3
is totally devastating because you know
obviously this sacrifice is no longer
possible the plot is way too close to
promotion
king f7 magnus has gotten off the board
um and well let's see the other move
you're talking about bishop b4
yeah well the engine likes rook f3 here
as well again it makes sense because the
bishop has stepped away from the a3
square and black now threatens to keep
pushing this pawn
um and finally i mean i think the
likeliest move is probably bishop b2
if i had to guess what fabi would play i
would guess bishop b2
because at the very least this uh
invites magnus to get this position
which is completely losing but at the
very least uh fabi doesn't have to worry
about two bishops he only has to worry
about one
and you know he can still make a couple
of moves here rookie too
magnus's plan though is among many
uh possible plans he can just get the
king well not to e6 that blunders rook
takes it for c there we go that could
happen one time out of a million but he
can go king e7 king d7 king c7
kick the rook out of b6 and then start
pushing the b pawn and the connected
passers yeah decide beside the game i
think in this position as soon as the
black king reaches c7 without stepping
onto these dangerous squares along the
six i think there we would see a
resignation but we're still
far away from from that as
fabi he is still considering what's it
gonna be bishop b2 bishop b4
yeah fabi is obviously suffering here
and again i think magnus has partially
had this effect on
modern chess as well as other top gm's i
think this would have been resigned
if we were commentating the 1963
uh candidates tournament in curacao for
example
uh you know somebody
even somebody like fisher or tall would
have been likely to resign this end game
and not because they
weren't resilient or they were bad
it's just that
you know with the advent of computers we
have realized how many chances there are
even in positions that look completely
lost i think that is largely thanks to
uh thanks to computers appearing on the
scene imagine having this position
against stockfish i wouldn't be
confident that uh you know that even
magnus would win this 100 times out of
100. and that is an important thing that
you know that must be mentioned when
talking about computers and their
influence for sure and well uh computers
and chess has been one of the main
topics here this year during the
tournament we had this uh conference
about uh ai with peter heiner nielsen
attending natasha regan so let me ask
you dania maybe um how do you work with
computers how do you use them uh in your
work
yeah well i'm pretty uh one-dimensional
i mostly use stockfish uh i don't really
use lila
and and other engines uh but every
player you know has to decide and mostly
of course you use computers for opening
preparation i use computers to analyze
games and to select material for
students but in terms of working on my
own game it's you know ninety percent uh
you use computers for opening and every
player has has his or her own style of
working with the computer
first of all in terms of quantity some
players turn on the computer more some
players try to analyze by themselves a
lot of the time and only verify their
conclusions of the computer although
that's becoming a lot more rare for most
gms the engine is running continuously
when you're studying and opening
because it's simply impossible you
cannot rely on yourself for anything you
have to check everything with an engine
so it doesn't really make sense anymore
to analyze on your own but
why are players like dubov so impressive
because they have managed to keep their
style
uh as fabie goes rook f2 but just to
complete the thought and then we'll get
to his move they've managed to keep
their style and make incredibly creative
moves moves that the computer initially
disapproves of so they found a way
to in many positions think even more
deeply than the computer and they use
the computer very selectively to make
sure that their moves aren't blunders
but sometimes they'll make the move that
the computer disapproves of initially
but because they've analyzed it so
deeply they've understood that from a
human perspective
uh from a human perspective the move is
very difficult to face so no computers
are not killing the game of chess and
yes there is still a lot of room for
human creativity and for humans to add
beauty to chess
some very interesting thoughts there
indeed uh and as fabiano offers a work
trade with rook f2
yeah rook f3 here seems to be the
winning move because it poses a a deadly
ultimatum if fabi takes it this is
too much to deal with this beast on f3
and if fabi doesn't take it if he moves
his bishop back
well now the bishop jack on c3 is
extremely strong fortunately
the king advances to d5
rook f3 has been played
and i think fabi's going to take that
rook and resign in three or four moves
from now
the magnus taking his time but really
finding all the moves and uh rook f3
really uh maybe we can have one more
look dania really there is nothing that
fabiano can do here everything is full
there's too many
too many past pawns and the bishop comes
into d4 so for instance bishop b2 can be
tried and magnus doesn't even have to
trade in fact bishop d8 wins the rook i
mean it wins the exchange brook before
gets skewered on a5 crazy and this is
obviously even though it's an opposite
chord bishop ndm it is completely lost
because the pawns are way too far apart
and black sting just comes into b3 and
promotes uh the a pawn
but
i mean if not bishop b2 then then bishop
d4 followed by f2 is winning because the
other bishop is going to basically come
into d3 and dislodge the king as karwana
takes the rook
and my guess is that bishop b2 bishop d8
is going to happen and then caruana is
going to resign yeah we saw the the look
while you were talking us through the
lines fabiano was looking at his score
sheet uh even before making the move
which again is often a sign that
resignation might happen soon with the
players thinking looking at the
scoresheet thinking where did it all go
wrong
and um bishop d4
is going to be played i'm giving it a 99
chance
although with magnus you never truly
know bishop d4 there's one more trick to
avoid fabby can make the devilish move
for rook before oh he blunders the pawn
of the skewer no white's winning at the
rook at 4 check this just shows that you
can never relax and those words aren't
just a meaningless cliche they're true
but in this position bishop e3 results
in complete domination look at how the
bishop and the pawn dominate the king
and now black can win in one of several
ways the easiest is actually just to
bring the king up to d5 and only then to
capture the pawn on c5 but magnus has to
find the move bishop e3 in response to
rook before
okay here he goes
yeah it looked like he was about to make
a move i think bishop d4 about
and look at the intense focus on
magnus's face as
bishop
d4 appears on the board
yep and fabi is definitely going to go
rook before i can almost guarantee it
and after bishop e3 i think he's going
to resign amended prediction
and yeah you can see from firebase face
actually the resignation happening
right there and we have a new champion
magnus carlsen is the winner of this
2022 tata steel just tournament
congratulations to the world champion
and what a performance it has been
throughout the tournament but
culminating in this huge black win
against fabiano carrana
domination i mean that's the word that
comes to mind when you think of the
current state of chess magnus is on a
completely different level he kicked it
into gear with that round two he kicked
it into geary with that round two
victory over anish and he never looked
back he didn't lose a single game he was
never even close to losing a single game
and this final round win over this final
win over caruana with the black pieces
just the cherry on top so many exquisite
games a well-deserved victory by the
world champion and we see magnus there
just folding the score sheet
neatly as uh fabiano carrana is
discussing with our main arbiter arnold
alliance magnus carlson he will be
coming out i think we're going to stick
around and wait for him his first stop
will be
the interview with leonard which will
play here live for you then he has a few
press commitments and then hopefully he
will be joining me here
in the studio very shortly so don't go
anywhere we'll be hearing plenty from
magnus
in a second
and really danny i mean as you were
saying he was never in trouble
um in this tournament what do you think
where was his fa what was his favorite
games uh
which game of matches did you like the
most
well he was never in time in trouble he
was never in time pressure
really this game is one of the
candidates but i was particularly
impressed with his win over chakriar and
the reason i was so impressed with it is
because shakur was in phenomenal for me
he'd be admitted today and carlson
always makes it look easy against
everybody doesn't matter who it is he
wins in less than 30 moves and really
the way he handled the catalan and his
two catalan wins
uh has been really unbelievable so i'd
have to single that one out but really
all of his wins this tournament have
been have been excellent
and i mean he could have he's on what i
was just looking there on the side he's
now on uh eight and a half out of twelve
he will get one point two more against
with against two both
without playing but the reason i'm
saying that he could even have gotten
potentially one more
win yesterday but i think all in all
magnus has got to be very happy
with his performance as we look at the
results here of round 12.
indeed as he breaks free
uh he's got a lead of one point
over shock and robert and uh just total
domination what else is there to be said
and incredible let's go to magnus sorry
dania
magnus carlsen you just won the tata
steel chess tournament uh 2022 and what
a way to clinch it in a black game
against fabian carolina
yeah
i'm very very happy of course
with
the um the result in total and uh also
today uh
uh i was
you know a draw was very good for me but
i was guess i was feeling a bit bolder
than than normal i kind of kind of
wanted to play he clearly wanted to play
as well so we got a good fight
but i think he went astray there i went
for
a somewhat risky plan um
with
with all of this a4 rook d8 and so on
because i would have to spend some time
at least with
queen a uh queen a8 queen c8 later
getting the bishop back in the game and
it's a question whether he can use that
time um and then i think he went for um
for the wrong plan with with knight d2
and then f3 um and um i felt that the
exchange stack was just screaming to be
be played uh after that um how did you
evaluate that oh i thought i thought i
was better probably not much um
but i think he immediately went for
completely the wrong plan with uh queen
b4 and bishop c3 i think it's very much
in my interest to
um to exchange queens there um
might seem a bit
um
uh
what's i cannot find the
uh paradoxical uh that i should exchange
queens while in exchange down but i
think my bishops are so strong
in the end game that he just has no
chance
so i think he needed to do something
something else there maybe queen b2 was
was a choice and then tried to play
queen e2 maybe later if rook d8 bishop
c3 thought that was the only way to kind
of stay afloat for him
and i feel like the end game was just
winning pretty much from the get-go
and
he found some some nice resources but i
think
eventually it's always going to win
um how would you sum up your tournament
are you satisfied with your play
i think there have been a lot of very
good moments here in in this
tournament
i think i've had nine winning positions
and i converted five of them
uh which is um
probably one or two too little uh
considering what i had
uh but there are a lot of
a lot of positives especially compared
to
the last couple of years where i didn't
play well and frankly didn't get many
chances so the huge amount of chances
that i got it's of course partly due to
my opponents playing a bit weaker than
usual but i think i also managed to
create more of them
than than normal and obviously the total
score
um plus five is is great and more more
than enough for tournament victory um
but there's always this thought that it
could have been even better um but
that will have to um that will have to
be another time but i'm i'm really
satisfied
in general
it's your eighth win here in the masters
this is a nice collection of trophies um
the ten
trophies are inside now
oh yes for sure um so um
i'm yeah as i said i'm uh
very happy to to get back to winning
ways here um
and uh
i also now got back to winning more than
50 percent of my my a groups here which
is
something that i'm kind of thinking of a
bit the last year um i didn't want to to
dip below so
um
yeah if i um
if i do this um
the same thing
next few years then i have great chances
and tomorrow is going to be a very hot
day because like you don't have to play
um
so you will have like some mini holidays
in in vacancies tomorrow do you have any
plans yeah practically it will be my my
fifth
free day uh i don't have any particular
plans uh
we'll see uh we'll see how i am i feel
and and go from
from there um but as i said yesterday
obviously you want
things to um
to be decided at the board um
but i'm really really today i'm really
really happy yeah that
i got this win now and then it doesn't
doesn't really matter i i guess if i'd
lost and shaq had won tomorrow then we
could have been tied but wouldn't have
been very likely okay well thank you so
much and enjoy your fixture thank you
magnus carlson clearly very happy with
tournament victory hopefully we'll have
him in the studio here as well and we
can pick his brains a little more but
dania first
first it is time for your round 12 rapid
recap and although magnus won the
tournament today uh really the game of
the day an amazing display
uh was played between sam shanklin who
had the white pieces and sergey karyakin
who had the black pieces let's delve
into this very exciting game film it
started off as a nimzo indian and sam
straight away on move for signaling uh
his very sharp intentions
f3 leading to some of the sharper lines
in the nimzo indian indeed and uh
karjakin also responding
in slightly offbeat uh fashion
yeah c5 and b5 kind of a benko style
idea now you know white generally
doesn't want to take on b5 in these
positions because the pawn on d5 becomes
incredibly weak i mean here uh it's just
a terrible idea to take so sam uh
following the main line reinforcing his
center with e4 uh continuing his
development and for a while they were
following relatively well known line a4
by sam trying to get sergey uh to remove
this pawn from b5 and he does sergey
takes on c4 sam recaptures and fiona at
this point they were following a very
high level game uh from a recent
tournament uh where uh the player
playing black was international master
alina kashlinskaya who is a noted nimzo
expert but sam just knew this more than
sergey did
it was really impressive preparation
from samus we can see in this spot sam
was still up close
time from the
starting clock time and he just rattled
down at this line now sergey playing 95
the bishops were exchanged on c8 and uh
bishop f4
sergey deciding he needs to push those
pawns and try and get this 93 check in
yeah and black is sacrificed upon the
compensation is clear black's got an
initiative but sam eliminating the
knight they're still following that game
and after the move knight h3 uh the idea
of which is to castle short and also to
tuck the knight back on f2 in case black
gets control of this diagonal
uh that game continued queen c5 and we
thought that queen c5 was the best move
but sergey after a long think and it's
possible that he was out of theory at
this point he decided on bishop c5
that's still decent sam going queen e2
and preparing once again to play knight
f2 sergey responding with rook b8 and
after knight f2
this is where sergey committed uh a
critical heir he probably should have
castled and sacrificed a second pawn in
this way because after king h8 white
cannot castle on account of bishop takes
f2 check but fiona he was enticed by an
admittedly tempting option that ended up
causing his downfall for sure queen b7
it looks like what could be wrong with
that move we are attacking the pawn on
b2 how could that be a mistake but
things got really crazy here sam
actually castled but he could have taken
on c4 immediately and we saw some crazy
lines there
yeah i mean the reason he probably
didn't take queen takes b2 transposes
into the game we'll take a look at that
through the game text but after bishop
takes f2 and queen takes b2
sam essentially has to go king g3 knight
h5 king h4 the engine indicates that
white is totally fine no worse for wear
but from a human perspective this is not
the easiest position to go to sam
castled short which did give sergey a
chance uh to veer off the deadly path uh
and play a move such as queen before
when he has insufficient compensation
but at least he gets a chance to castle
and the game would have went on but
sergey going head first for the
complications and taking on b2 and this
is where sam did something quite amazing
fiona indeed this is the line that we
were saying we were gonna come back to
queen take c4 it looks like a crazy move
at first because you wonder isn't that
just losing a piece after bishop f2
check that bishop cannot be captured
because the rook on a1 is hanging but no
sam's instance responds king h1 white
just gives up the piece and the problem
is look at that black king oniated
cannot castle and it's about to find
itself in a world of pain
exactly and there's two other problems
along with the king the first is that
white threatens a skewer rook ab1 wins
the rook on b8 the sec the third problem
is that the bishop on f2 is tremendously
vulnerable it's defended only by the
queen and again because of the threat of
rook ab1 black doesn't have time to pull
it back away from f2 so sergey he makes
a very tricky move queen b3 obviously he
hopes for queen takes b3 when the knight
is going to be hanging and black emerges
up a piece but sam making another
incredibly accurate move doesn't give
the check on c6 with rook takes f2 which
sergey was also hoping for after rook
hca black simply wins the night on c3
and wins the game but fiona sam going
queen c7 which is an incredibly powerful
and this is essentially the game-winning
move hitting the e5 pawn hitting g7 and
forcing sergey to go down a fatal path
queen c7 probably the move that sergey
missed he tried his best to hold on but
after queen b6 uh first e5 uh falls and
now in comes the knight with devastating
power
indeed removing the final defender of
the king and now the king is wide open
you can't cover with the queen because
you're going to lose the bishops or
giggling king e7 another check on e5
sending the king back to f7 and the
game-winning move the final piece
emerges the rook is aiming for c7 and
there is nothing that black can do to
stop him sergey resigned in this
position and it was not a premature
resignation just a couple of lines rook
bca doesn't help white trades and picks
off the rook with queen f5 and if black
tries to defend it from the other side
after rook b7 the easiest win is rook
takes f2 and yet another fork uh queen
d5 chuck whites two puns up and is
delivering checkmate sergey decided that
further resistance was futile an
absolutely stunning game by sam
shankland inflicting a loss on carrick
and in only 26 moves this is almost
unheard of
kudos to sam hope you enjoyed this game
this was your rapid recap and dania well
we are gonna go on a quick break as we
set up for magnus carlsen to join us in
the studio shortly so don't go anywhere
you don't want to miss it we'll be right
back
bobby
yeah robert
can you read devretsky's endgame manual
to us one more time yeah now we gotta
get up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it was you like i was i was gonna do it
but he said
that's what i said
i told you
let's do it all right you know what they
say though what happens in salt lake it
stays in salt lake
exactly
cheers to my super gm friends it's been
good the world championship
on chess.com
let's do this
[Music]
that was that was i was
yeah i'm i'm great
round two
bobby
yes robert
can you read devoretsky's endgame manual
to us one more time yeah
you guys have to go
[Laughter]
okay okay okay
i just actually didn't expect you to do
it that time it's funnier like i thought
he was a one-time
yeah yeah please okay okay i'm just
trying to add live with what feels
natural yeah
of course it feels natural wait so we
should expect that next yeah
okay just so i'm mentally prepared yeah
okay
what is this
it's eggs
i want an omelet with brie just [ __ ]
eat it
you eat it
wasn't expecting that that wasn't either
it was so
we could turn a little bit on the
shoulder there
the uh
faster card and unibrow i just want to
thank my sponsors uh very much for all
they do to to promote chess
um sounds like a great future credit
card faster card yeah wasn't it faster
hard
no no
y'all are respecting the wood a little
too much
not fast or hard bobby oh boy i
can't be with you two anymore
i mean i think it's i think it's
hilarious don't you think people would
would buy this
no i don't think anyone's going to buy
that
tank that's the stupidest person in my
life
well okay
i guess that's it
all right that's it that was great
keep it wrong okay
same thing
i love that
who is that guy who's that
he didn't come in with you guys
no we're going to be right back
bobby
yes robert
can you read deboratsky's end game
manual to us one more time yeah yeah
i'm sorry
[Music]
that's so funny
isn't that cool when i predict the moves
you're gonna say cause we all see things
in the same way in the same speed on
this show
isn't that cool when we do that
it doesn't make me very happy
[Laughter]
and let's bring up the analysis board as
we do that so ifon can give us her
thoughts on the uh
on the pet shop go aheady fun
uh well yeah actually that's a very good
question because i was firstly trying to
yeah danny
my throat's still dry
you're like you've already you've had
five glasses of water okay you remember
what happened last time
my throat's still dry you've already had
five glasses of water and you remember
what happened last time
it was an accident you peed your bed
[Laughter]
you're looking fresh man all six of them
again dude your haircut just looks great
wait did we start the bit yeah
you're not supposed to say that
you're not supposed to say if you start
the bit if black's a6 pawn was
transported let's say
good night guys
good night dad i've been fabio bobby
you know one more time maybe
i said i said it should i not said it
i think it's funny if we both say good
night dad i mean bobby but we need to be
instinct
welcome to the world rapid championships
from warsaw poland we're about to get
going magnus now forcing the king closer
yeah this is very very tricky for the
georgian player no and he blunders his
rook oh god oh my gosh
and magnus wins the game and that was a
lesson in just pressure pressure
pressure
duda he has three pawns more than his
opponent judah has won three in a row he
is getting off to a fantastic start
gunina and castenu two players with a
perfect score they're going to be facing
each other kustenyuk once again has
turned it around and for the first time
in the game gunana is down on the clock
gunina is gonna have to resign what
initially looked like an amazing game
from her
magnus still has the threat on the pawn
there's the threat of rook f2 magnus was
actually very clever in how he just
avoided the trade and shiro has lost on
time so we have three players in first
place right now in the open section this
round it's olivereza from russia and
magnus carlsen i think magnus is going
to wrap this up really quickly the king
moves away from the czech magnus
maneuvering his knight to a superior
position
and ali reza resigns the game the number
one and number two players in the world
right now and magnus calls him coming
out there victorious needing a win here
if he is to have a soul lead magnus just
simply retreating the king one step back
there's no stopping him from getting a
queen on the next move he's gonna win it
and he's gonna take the lead in this
tournament
carlson playing against the youngster
from uzbekistan abdusatorov has speaking
some really strong players in this
tournament and that makes me kind of
optimistic about his chances against
magnus here and magnus now is going to
give up another pawn
wow look at this for the second time
magnus is giving up pawns in order to
just get rid of them uh if there's a
check coming in here from oh my god
and magnus resigns abdu satoro takes the
lead after a win against the reigning
champion carlson will have the
opportunity to strike back with the
white pieces against napoleon chief
magnus is probably regretting this
knight cd5 now he's definitely forced to
be playing for the draw he's not going
to be catching yon na pangachi that was
surely a very disappointing game with
the white pieces it's the big matchup of
this round if casteniuk makes a draw
with the black pieces she will be
crowned world champion i would have to
give the edge to white in this position
because of the permanent name
welcome back and we are joined by the
tournament winner magnus carlson magnus
congratulations
and my first question to you has to be a
record eight victory here in vikenze
what does it mean to you
uh well i obviously had the previous
record
also
but overall now
i've uh
get my record of winning
the tournament more times than not which
was something that i was aiming for for
you this year but
first first of all i'm just very happy
to have been able to play the tournament
and um to perform
very very well
and while you're talking about those uh
eight victories is there any of them
that stands out more than others or are
they all equally special
um i do feel that most of my wins were
pretty uh pretty good and pretty uh
clean
but i did enjoy the game against
mamadiarov a lot i thought that was
probably my best game and uh
obviously the game today was was nice
but he clearly was not fabian at his
best
and uh
the conditions were sort of um
pretty easy after after a while um
since i felt that the exchange stack was
pretty obvious i did find some good
moves
after that but
i don't think i did anything
particularly difficult
the circumstances of the game were of
course different with you knowing you
would get the free point against daniel
tomorrow
how did that impact your preparation did
you feel it gave you more freedom more
liberties to maybe play for more
um yes knowing that this would be
my my last game i had some hopes
that i could perhaps play for for more
indeed
uh today especially after
yesterday was
pretty uh
was a pretty disappointing
performance i really wanted to end on uh
on a high note
today it was not like i was
setting out to take massive risks
but i at least kind of
wanted to
to play a little bit um and um
he wanted to play obviously as well
but sometimes when you're a bit out of
out of shape this can
[Music]
this can
yeah
this can lead to pretty bad results and
um that's what happened for him you
singled out the win against my media if
i guess there was another win that uh
surely is quite dear to you it was the
one that started your winning wins
against anish gear it was your first uh
classical win against him here in
vikanze was that a special moment for
you as well
um
sure there have been some some near
misses against him ever since i lost
that
infamous game back in 20 2011 but
i i'm
obviously
with him starting to
win a few games
after a while that was
that was pretty crucial but
then again i i didn't feel that i did
anything anything special in
in in that game
but i did set him some
some problems that he failed to cope
with in the opening but um
but but yeah as i said i felt overall
most of my wins were
pretty pretty good a couple of those
that we just talked about came from the
catalan an opening which lately in your
hand seems to have become a deadly
weapon can you tell us a little bit
about what's your aspiration behind that
and your feeling towards the cutling
opening
um yeah so one of the
one of the main points of my preparation
for the match against punishee was
to feel comfortable sacrificing upon
in the catalan because that's something
that i always kind of struggle with
um and um obviously i was helped by by
duboff there um
since that is his
specialty and i feel like already
i'm already improving there um for
instance against mamadiarov i i
sacrificed
upon
there
for not too obvious com
compensation
uh and i was just feeling feeling good
like it was like it was normal so i'm
definitely i'm getting the getting the
taste for for the opening do you think
that's also going to be shaping the near
future do you feel like you're a
trailblazer in that sense that's always
been quite popular but
do you feel you're breathing a new life
into the opening
no
catalan is
one of the top openings by
[Music]
by neural networks so it's not going to
be a surprise to anybody
well we're looking at your coach peter
heiner nielsen who's standing in the
corner but i'm sure he has something to
do with it magnus let's briefly talk
about uh vikanze you've played here 18
times a lot of your life time spent here
in this coastal village what is it that
makes you enjoy being here so much
well there are a few things um
obviously there is tradition which which
helps
um
but i think most of all
um the the format
uh playing so many different
players is
is uh is unique and playing against kind
of a varied
field
um
that's
something
that is unique to this tournament you
don't get that really anywhere
anywhere else
and uh
i don't know
the tradition part again i always feel
good coming here it's always
um
yeah it's so it's so it's always
always welcome i'm always kind of able
to
um to focus
here um and um
yeah this this time even though there
was
there was covet which is of course
unfortunate so that nobody can can
really come
and watch um it didn't really affect my
preparation
and everything that
that that much my daily routine was
pretty much the same probably as it
would have been even with
a lot of
people here
and i think i just managed to to focus
really really
really really well
it's interesting what you're saying and
of course we hope that next year we'll
be able to have the amateur players and
the spectators uh back is it something
that you missed do you like in general
playing in front of many fans
i think
as a chess player you obviously enjoy
people being there to
sort of appreciate what you're
what you're doing but
clearly for me there are some
[Music]
benefits as well since
i can uh
i can be um
sort of a little more more free but um
yeah i hope that people will be back
next year absolutely just a last couple
of questions recently you stated that uh
your next big goal is to work your way
up to 2900 rating in uh classical what's
your uh approach to how to get there are
you planning to play a lot or
what's the game strategy
i'm
not necessarily planning to play a lot
of tournaments
what i will say is
and what i kind of emphasized when
i i set myself that goal is that i have
to be on top every time that i play
fully just fully focused
um and to always be at my best and
this i think i managed
um very well here
it's not like i had a huge
surplus of energy i don't think anybody
does at this point
um
but i think
i really made the most of it i was
really disciplined
throughout the whole
tournament and
i think that's that's that really is the
key to having any chance of attaining
that goal
um
how often
i play
um
that will see i don't have anything
particular plan before no which has at
the end of
may but
really just
being full of focus each time that i
play that's
that's the only thing that can
give me a chance of attending that goal
very well we wish you best of luck with
that uh quest before i let you go magnus
there's one final question from a fan of
yours uh rebecca harris she is wondering
now that tata is over might there be
some more bullet matches on the horizon
for her
we'll see
we'll see magnus i'll let you go off do
you have any plans
for tonight or tomorrow will there be
any celebration
um
i don't i don't know um i'm just really
happy
with the way things ended
um
getting this last win in a good game
makes
makes all the difference in the world
for me um and there'll be due time to
celebrate
if it's now or when i get home so that
part i'm not worried about great well
magnus thank you so much for your time
congratulations uh on a brilliant
performance your eighth title here in
tata thanks for joining us and for now
back to you dania
what an incredible interview
thank you
thank you fiona
and thank you to magnus that was great
insights upon a stunning tournament and
magnus really singling out uh his game
against mamidarov but you can't really
blame him
uh for liking all of his wins because
this is what he does it seems like every
time he wins a game
it never seems to be in doubt he's
winning basically from the opening
and magnus also hinting that the catalan
is the choice of these new neural
network entrants uh like alpha zero so
uh magnus using all tools at his
disposal to optimize
uh to optimize his chances of
success and uh a wonderful interview
indeed i enjoyed listening to that
tremendously and so thank you to you as
well yes so great to see magnus in high
spirits here uh after what has been
really an incredible performance he sets
the bar so high from himself but it's
good to see him satisfied with his
performance in a great mood and uh once
again we see the results here huge win
for magnus with the black pieces against
fabiano carana to wrap up a record
eighth victory here in vikenzi um
he has here's the point clear he is
going to get one point to morgan uber
that game won't be played and um
my mediaref and report they will be
battling it out as well as geary
for the remaining podium places
indeed and uh trust me they will not let
up uh second place third place in total
steel it's not the same as first place
but uh it's incredibly prestigious so
there will be a lot of effort expended
in the last round tomorrow i do not
anticipate a lot of quick draws and uh
yeah it's unfortunate that magnus uh
doesn't play tomorrow but such is life
and we will have plenty of entertaining
games uh to round off this year's
edition of tata steel yeah one of them
i'm
looking forward to is mamedyarov against
caruana how will fabiano bounce back
he is on a roll um plenty more other
games will have to look forward to
but for now remember we'll bring up the
schedule tomorrow we start two hours
early at noon
for dania for you it's bad news
hopefully you will make it third time
i will make it i will absolutely make it
i've i've made it so far and there's
nothing like the atmosphere of the last
round so i'm sure that'll wake me up
together with the copious amount of
coffee that i'll have but this rounds
games definitely woke me up yet another
amazing effort by fabiano and uh fiona
it was a pleasure once again this was a
magical round a great atmosphere and a
lot of it is thanks to you and of course
thanks to all of
uh the thousands and thousands of fans
as well absolutely thank you so much
dania it's been
an absolute pleasure congratulations to
our two winners here magnus carlsen in
the masters argenti erigasi and the
challengers and
as you said daniel thank you so much to
everyone who's been watching us we will
be back tomorrow two hours earlier than
usual
but for now we'll let you go have a good
day or night depending on where in the
world you are and we'll see you tomorrow
i think the first time
i heard about
the tournament here was um probably
sometime in 1999 uh but the first
tournament that i actually followed was
the one in in 2000
so i would say that's my like first firm
memory of the tournament here
probably my best memory from the village
here uh
was the year that i i won and uh people
of baikon say song sang a nice little
song for for me i i really appreciated
that
i think there are people in
my team who are better than me at
working with with engines so i would say
i'm not so
good at finding ideas with it so i
generally prefer thinking on my own
solving chess is way way out there and
frankly i hope that it won't be
in a very very long time
my goal for this tournament
is to have 13 days of good preparation
and
a good mindset when coming to the board
hopefully i'll i can get back to to my
best after a couple of
um let's say frustrating performances
the last couple of years
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you